SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILK.
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS MORE PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY THREE MEMBERS AS
SUBCOMMITTEE. WILL BE A
PARTICIPATING HERE IN ONE
CENTER WILL BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY DO WE HAVE CENTER
STERN ARE. ON THE CALL. AND
SENATE STERN IF YOU'RE THERE
COULD YOU IDENTIFY ANY STAFF
MEMBER THAT'S WITH YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL DO THAT WHEN YOU
GET SERVED AT THESE. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ARE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MAKE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC BACK. FEEDBACK I
GUESS ITEVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZED THE RAGE THAT
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD. LIKE TO A NEW POLICE
SELECTOR MUSED BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING ARE I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON. YOU WHEN
YOU ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO TRUST IT COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOM SIX AT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OF ITS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHICH TESTIFIED
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS.
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPER. PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER IN EXCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND IT WILL NOW
SIT OUT TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX VOTE
AND- SIX FOUR. AND THE X. X.
CODE IS FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN SIX
OH NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
IMPORT COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR. US TO
HEAR. YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU TO MESS
WITH THE DEVICE YOU'RE-
WATCHING TIED TO HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IS IMPORTANT THAT.
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING ASSIST CUSTOMER IN AN
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE. DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE ROAD. A
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS IS A MUTED. PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE. TO STREAMLINE
HEARING PROCESS CONDUCTED
HEARING. IN A CLOSE TO THIS.
MANNER AS DISCUSSED. BUT MAYBE
SOME LACK TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE OF ALL.
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. LASTLY FOR EVERYONE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT HERE TODAY
PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASCOT
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES- IS MR CENTER STERN
ON THE LINE. DO WE KNOW. I SEE
THAT I SEE NOBODY OKAY WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- AT THAT
TIME. OKAY BEFORE WE START-
WITH THE WE HAVE SEVEN ITEMS UP
FOR DISCUSSION- I'D LIKE TO
HAVE A BRIEF STATEMENT ON A
BEFORE WE START WITH THAT
GREENHOUSE GAS- FUND
EXPENDITURE PLAN THERE IS NO
ACTION BEING CONTEMPLATED ON
THE PLANET THIS MORNING'S
HEARING THE SUBCOMMITTEES ON A
REALLY TIGHT. TIME FRAME DUE TO
THE COVERT RESTRICTIONS AND
OTHER FACTORS SO THIS IS SIMPLY
THE INITIAL FORAY INTO THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN AS I
LEARNED KEENLY FROM THIS
WEEKEND'S IMPEACHMENT TRIALS
THE ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
TO IS THE POWER OF THE PURSE WE
ARE THE LEGISLATURE HAS UP TO
THE SENATE. TO DEVELOP AN
EXPENDITURE PLAN WE HAVE SOME
GUIDELINES AND SUBJECT SINCE
OBJECTION SUGGESTIONS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHAT IS THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY THAT
CONTROLS THE PERSON THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE RULES OF THE
CURRENT CAP AND TRADE MARKET
PERCENT OVER A YEAR AGO AND
THEY'VE BEEN BAKED INTO THE
MARKET SINCE THAT TIME MARKET
PARTICIPANTS ARE WELL AWARE OF
THE CAP AND TRADE RULES IN
EFFECT HAMPEL NOTICE OF THEIR
AFFECT. THERE'S NO ACTION
CONTEMPLATED TO ALTER THOSE
RULES AT THIS HEARING THE KELLY
P. SECRETARY HIS SIGNAL HIS
CONCURRENCE WITH THE FULL.
FORWARD ASSUMPTIONS MADE BY THE
AIRPORT AND THE FLAT SCOPING
PLAN APPROPRIATELY NEED TO BE
RE EXAMINED WE HAVE A WRITTEN
LETTER FROM LAST SUMMER
ASSOCIATING THIS SUB COMMITTEE
CONCURS IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
LOOK AT THE ISSUES ESPECIALLY
AS THE AIRPORT. AND IT'S HERE
IN PARK ON AN UPDATE OF THE S.
B. AB THIRTY TWO A SCOPING PLAN
AND ASSOCIATED RULE MAKING AS
IT MOVES INTO THE SB THIRTY TWO
SCOPING PLAN. FINALLY I NOTE
THAT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE MUST ACT
ON A BUDGETS IN THE OF THE
AGENCY AND ITS SUBSIDIARY
BOARDS DEPARTMENTS IN ALL AND
OFFICES. I'VE CHECKED WITH THE
PROCAMP FOR POSSIBLE
ALTERNATIVES THERE'S JUST NO
AVAILABLE ROOMS SO IN ORDER TO
DO SO THE COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
KNOW HOW THOSE ENTITIES INTEND
TO PROCEED ON ISSUES. LIKE CAP
AND TRADE- SO THAT IT WILL BE
BETTER AND- OF BUDGET AND WITH
THAT- GO TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN. MESSINESS I SEE
CENTER STERN AYE WILL STATUS
ACCORDING TO THIS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN. THE. BIG PACKET.
THANK RADIO WHEN YOU HAVE THAT
TIME NOBODY LIKES THAT. FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN. THIS IS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SMALL
GRANT PROGRAMS. OKAY PLEASE
PROCEED. US SECRETARY OF HEALTH
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING K.
Y. CASKEY AND MEMBERS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT INTRODUCTION
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK KIDS
TODAY- UNFORTUNATELY FOR YOU
YOU'LL PROBABLY HEAR LITTLE TOO
MUCH FOR MAYES OUT OF TRYING TO
KEEP MY WORDS BECAUSE I CANNOT
REALLY IN THIS MORNING- AGAIN
MY NAME IS JEREMY LIN'S HOW THE
AND THE SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AND- BEFORE I
START I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
INCREDIBLY PROUD I AM OF ALL
THE WORK BEING DONE BY THAT.
SIXTY TWO HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
EIGHT KELLY P. A. AND THROUGH
TODAY'S HEARING I HOPE WE CAN
ENDEAVOR TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF SOME OF THE GROUND
BREAKING PROGRAMS AT LEAST AS
THEY INTERSECT AS YOU POINT OUT
THE BUDGET ONE OF THOSE- I HAVE
TO STATE HAS A REALLY REALLY
SPECIAL PLACE IN MY HEART IS
THE E. J. SMALL GRANTS PROGRAM-
THIS IS BEEN GOING FULL I'M A
NUMBER IF HE IS. AND IT REALLY
DOES CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WORK
TO EMPOWER COMMUNITIES WORKING
ON A WIDE VARIETY OF SOLUTIONS
TO SOME OF OUR TOUGHEST
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES IT
SINGULARLY FOCUSED ON FUNDING
PROJECTS THAT MAKE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE A SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND
THROUGHOUT THIS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT YEAR HAVE IT NINETEEN
THE MONSTER THE FUNDING HAS
ONLY INCREASED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ELEVEN THE PROGRAM APPLICANTS
REQUESTED FULL MILLION AND
GRANDSON'S FAMILY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION IN AVAILABLE FUNDS
THE GROUNDS AWARDED LAST YEAR
FUNDED CHAD THINGS LIKE
IMPLEMENTING NEW CHEMICAL
EXPOSURE ENCODED NINETEEN
SAFETY MEASURES THE NAIL SALON
WORKERS. ENGAGING HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ACROSS CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND CLIMATE ACTION
PLANNING WE FUNDED GROUPS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
ELSEWHERE THE SUPPORT FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO
TRANSITION INTO WORKING IN THE
COMMUNITY GARDENS AND
INSTALLING COMMUNITY BASED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE FIND THAT
CUTTING EDGE RESEARCH EXAMINING
BASS AND MATERNAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES AFFECTING BLACK
MOTHERS AND FAMILIES IN FRESNO
AND AT A TIME WHEN OUR FRONT
LINE WORK IS SHOWN HOW
CRITICALLY ESSENTIAL. AND
VULNERABLE THEY CAN BE WITH ALL
IS THAT FUNDED THE- LED
ORGANIZED. TO ALL HEALTH NOW
THAT'S INTO. IS THE SAME AS NON
ENGLISH. INDIGENOUS OUT FEET
INCLUDE SPEAK. FIELD LAB AND
THAT ARE JUST. A FEW IS. OF THE
EXAM- IT'S IS ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS IT'S KIND OF BEEN.
KICKED AROUND FROM FUNDING
SOURCE THE FUNDING SOURCE OVER
THE YEARS- IT COULD BE REALLY
BUT WHEN I TALK TO PEOPLE.
ABOUT EQUITY CLIMB
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IS THE
FIRST THING I GENERALLY TALK
ABOUT BECAUSE- IT HAD A REALLY
FOCUSES ON THE NEEDS OF
COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN WHAT WE
THINK THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES
ARE- AND IT. IS ORIGINALLY WAS
FUNDED FROM. A WHOLE HOST OF
DIFFERENT- SOURCES PENALTY
ACCOUNTS FROM WASTEWATER
DISCHARGE ACCOUNT- POLLUTION
CONTROL FIND. AND SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECTS- TOSCA AND BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUNDS OF
ALSO. OVER TIME IN A LIMITED
WAY SUPPORTED THIS PROGRAM SO.
IDEALLY WE DO WANT TO USE IT
FOR PENALTY FOR THIS PROGRAM
AGAIN. BY IN LIGHT OF CURRENT
THEM MONSIVAIS THE EVOLUTION
CONTROL WASTEWATER DISCHARGE
FUNDS TO FILL BUDGET FOR
CHOKEHOLDS THOSE ACCOUNTS WERE
NOT FEASIBLE. IN THIS BUDGET
CYCLE SO- AND WE HAVE TO COME
THE FINAL TO DEFRAY THIS OUT OF
WELL AS HELPFUL SO AG SAYING.
THAT WE WANT THAT ONE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR TO COME TOUGH-
TO THIS YEAR AT A MINIMUM INTO
WAY ABLE TO SECURE IT IT
TENTATIVE FUNDING SOURCE. AND
THAT'S HOPEFULLY MORE
CONTINUOUS AND HOPEFULLY IS A
VIABLE- OPTION TO KEEPING THE
PROGRAM GOING- I WANT TO GROW
THE PROGRAM I THINK. THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIBRATION BE
DOING. I'M SO WITH WITH VERY. I
AM VERY INTENT ON ANYTHING I
CAN DO TO PARTNER WITH ANY OF
YOU ON THIS COMMITTEE TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO STRENGTHEN THE
PROGRAM. GROW IT- IT IT MEETS
AN INCREDIBLE NEED AND EVERY
SINGLE PROJECT IS FUNDED I READ
THROUGH ALL OF THEM- I JUST ONE
DAY LIKE WOW THIS IS MATERIALLY
SHAKING. OUT COMMUNITIES FOR
THE BETTER SO- THE PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF YOU THAT IS. ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION APPROPRIATION FOR
THIS YEAR TO COME OUT OF PASTA.
THANK YOU- LMAO YOU READ THE
STAFF REPORT THE STAFF REPORT
TALKS ABOUT YOU KNOW THIS IS
THESE ARE GREAT PROGRAMS LET'S
STIPULATE WHAT THE SECRETARY
THAT THERE THE CJ- PROGRAMS ARE
GOOD. BUT SOME OF THAT IS TOXIC.
HARM BUT SOME OF IT AIR
POLLUTION HARM SOME OF CAN GO
FOR COME FROM BEVERAGE. SOME
ITS WAYS WATER IS SUPPORT FOR
ALL OF SOURCES THAT AFFECT
THESE COMMUNITIES. AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS K. IS TAKING IT OFF
FROM THE TOSCA ACCOUNT. CAN
YOU. COMMENT ON THAT AND GIVE
ME YOUR INSIDES. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROSS
BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- YOU'RE RIGHT-
MISTER SHARON AS A SECRETARY
MENTIONS- THERE IN THE PAST
THERE HAVE BEEN KIND OF A
VARIETY OF. A SPECIAL FUNDS
THAT HAVE BEEN USED TO SUPPORT
THESE ACTIVITIES- THIS PROPOSAL
HERE WITH- WOULD USE JUST THE
TOSCA FUND RATHER THAN THE
NEXUS SPECIAL FUNDS IN THE
PAST. BUT WE DO THINK KIND OF
EXPLORING- USING SOME MIX OF
SPECIAL FUNDS. AS IS DONE BEEN
DONE IN THE PAST AS IT IS. AN
ALTERNATIVE WORTH EXPLORING
THAT WOULD- MORE CLOSELY MATCH
SORT OF THE MIX OF ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE FUNDED HERE WHAT'S THE
FUNDING SOURCES- AND THAT'S
BOTH KIND OF IF THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVES THE- DGSE REFORM.
PROPOSAL THAT'S IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WHICH IS- IN THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE CONTINGENT ON
THAT. OR IF IT DOESN'T WE DO
THINK YOU KNOW KIND OF
EXPLORING SOME OF THOSE-
ALTERNATIVES ARE WORTHWHILE.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN DOING AND WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
EXPLORE WHAT'S POSSIBLE THERE.
YEAH THE CHAIR HAS A BILL TO
INCREASE THE FUNDS ON THE- DGSE
AND THE THAT. TOXIC AND
HAZARDOUS WASTE WE HAVE MORE
THAN JUST A PASSING INTEREST I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT. YOU
KNOW WE IF THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AND I'D LIKE TO BE. SUCCESSFUL
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND THERE'S A NEED
TO IT IF IT DOESN'T WE'RE WE
GET TO BE ACTIVE WE HAVE. ALL
THE- ALL THE FUNDING. IN THE
ANTICIPATED- I TEXAS OF CONTROL.
ARE WAS THERE A HAND UP.
FINANCE ONE OF YOU WEIGH IN
HERE WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT A
WHOLE GROUP OF VIA. THE SOCIAL
ILLS PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTING A LITTLE BIT TO
KEEP THESE EACH A- THINGS OFF
WE ARE. HOPEFUL THAT WE GET A
TWO THIRDS VOTE BILL TO REFORM
THE TSC FROM FEES BUT- IS THERE
A MORE. IT IS WHAT DO YOU SAY
ABOUT OUR STAFF COMMENTS ON
THIS. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR
LIZZY ARE YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M SO WE DO RECOGNIZE
WE HAVE UTILIZED AVAILABLE
PENALTY REVENUES FROM VARIOUS
FUNDING SOURCES TO MEET THIS
DEMAND BUT AS THE SECRETARY
NOTED. HI THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM SO WE BELIEVE THAT
INSTEAD OF RELYING ON. UNSTABLE
POTENTIALLY PENALTY REVENUES ON
A YEAR TO YEAR BASIS NIGHT THIS
PROPOSAL INSTEAD WILL USE ARE
YOU- TOSCA ENVIRONMENTAL FEE
REVENUES TO PROVIDE A
SUSTAINABLE AND ONGOING I'M
SOURCES FOR THE PROGRAM. I'M
KIND OF CRAZY HOT NOTED THAT
THE PROPOSAL IS CONTINGENT ON
THE PASSAGE OF THE GOVERNANCE
AND REFORM BUT WE BELIEVE.
SUSTAINABLE FINDINGS FOR THIS
PROGRAM. WELL I KNOW FOR ME
KICK ASK INTO BECAUSE I KNOW A
LOT OF LIKE THE AB SIX ONE
SEVEN. HI E. J. PROGRAMS ARE
ALL MOST OF THEM ARE AIR
POLLUTION OR NOT
DECARBONIZATION WE'LL GET TO
THAT LATER ON HERE IN THE
HEARING- BUT YOU HAVE. OF
SETTLEMENTS THAT YOU'VE HAD
WITH VOLKSWAGEN AND CHRYSLER
DAIMLER AND THOSE ARE AIR
POLLUTION- FUNDS ISN'T ANY OF
THAT MONEY AVAILABLE FOR A
PURPOSE. TO COMPLEMENT WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THESE OTHER
AGENCIES YOU TELLING THIS
COMMITTEE THAT THERE'S NO MONEY
AVAILABLE FROM THESE AIR
POLLUTION SETTLEMENTS. NOW WHAT
AND WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
SUPPLEMENTS FUNDING HAD
SETTLEMENTS TO PROVIDE FUNDING
INTO POTENTIALLY BEAVAILABLE
AND ARE. WEARING BLACK AT
ARTICLES LIKE THIS POINT IS TO
UTILIZED MONEY FROM. OKAY
CENTRESTAGE HAVE A QUESTION I
DON'T SEE HAND UP I SEE OR HEAR.
FIVE OTHERWISE THIS IS WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THIS MATTER-
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SOME OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT WE LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THAT AND- THIS
IS THAT'LL CONCLUDE THAT THIS
PUT THAT PORTION OF ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTEEN. LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF MISS
RIGHT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHY CASKEY HERE KASKY
HERE DOLLY. DOLLY HERE MCGUIRE
HERE MCGUIRE HERE STERN. I'M
HERE AT THE CENTER SIR DO YOU
HAVE ANY STAFF WITH YOU IN THE
ROOM OR IN YOUR OFFICE. MORNING
DISTANTLY AWAY FEW OFFICES
WHERE JEREMY WOLFE MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR BUT I'M- JUST ME THANK
YOU FOR THAT OKAY I DID AND I
DID HAVE A COMMON ON THE TASK
ITEM BUT- YOU CAN- RESERVISTS
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT. OKAY THANK
YOU- LET'S IMPORTATION OF A
FOURTEEN THIS IS OUR OVERSIGHT
HEARING AYE CAPTAIN TREES WE
HAVE. OF FOR DISTINGUISHED
PANELISTS READ THE HAVE THEM
INTRODUCE THEM YOU CAN GO ON
THE WEBSITE READ ABOUT THEM
LET'S START OFF WITH. THE
LEGISLATURE'S OWN ANALYSTS
OFFICE MISTER BROWN. YOU CAN
BEGIN. WELCOME CARE RANDOLPH
THEN A SECTOR BLUMENFELD AND-
PROFESSOR CALLING WOULD ALSO.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR SHERIDAN
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- I DO AN
ESTATE UP FRONT I'M NOT- AND A
NON VOTING MEMBER OF THE
INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHAT SHE'LL
HERE- MAYBE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
LATER ON- BUT I WILL BE
SPEAKING THIS MORNNG OF COURSE
IN MY ROLE AS- AN ANALYST FOR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SINISTER STOP SO AS TO. MAKE
THAT CLEAR I'M SO SORRY I KNOW
WE CAN WE HAVE A LOT WHAT IF
YOUR PANEL LESSONS ALL TRY TO
BE BRIEF WITH MY COMMENTS I
JUST WANT TO KIND OF MAKE A FEW
I LEVEL COMMENTS FIRST I THINK
IMPORTANT FOR THIS CONVERSATION
IS JUST A LITTLE CONTEXT FOR
THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
GOALS AND- WHERE WE'VE BEEN
WHERE WE ARE AND- WHERE WE'RE
GOING WHAT THEIR GOALS ARE- IN
PARTICULAR THE- AMBITIOUS
NATURE OF THE TWENTY THIRTY
GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS SO JUST
FOR CONTEXT. THE STATE HAS NOT
IT'S TWENTY TWENTY GREENHOUSE
GAS SCHOOLS A FEW YEARS EARLY-
AND THAT'S A THAT'S A GREAT
SUCCESS- BUT I THINK JUST FOR
CONTEXT AGAIN THE ANNUAL
EMISSION REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO
MEET THE TWENTY TWENTY GOALS
LAID OUT IN AB THIRTY TWO WERE
ROUGHLY 1% REDUCTIONS IN
EMISSIONS PER YEAR ANNUALLY-
WHEREAS THE TO MEET THE TWENTY
THIRTY GOAL IT'S CLOSER TO A
FOUR PERCENT- ANNUAL. EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO YOU TO
MEET THAT GOAL SO- THAT THE
GOALS ARE MUCH MORE AMBITIOUS
KIND OF GOING UP TO TWENTY
THIRTY AND I THINK THE- ONE OF
THE OF COURSE THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS IN ONE THAT
YOU MIGHT EXPLORE IN THIS
HEARING IS WHAT IS THE NEXT OF
POLICIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO ADOPT IN ORDER TO.
ACHIEVE THOSE AMBITIOUS GOALS-
AS YOU KNOW THE STATE HAS A
WIDE VARIETY OF- PROGRAMS-
REGULATORY PROGRAMS INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE
STATE'S. ECONOMY WIDE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AND SO SORTING
THROUGH SORT OF A MIX OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THIS MONTH
MOST LIKELY TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS AND ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS
AFFECTED LEE IS VERY IMPORTANT-
IN IN AND KIND OF THAT. THAT
CONTEXT THINK- I ALSO WANTED TO
KNOW. AS PART OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPING. THAT THE
EVERY BOARD ADOPTED- IS A-
THEIR A GROWING. ROLE I DON'T.
FOR AND TRADE- TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY TARGETS- I DON'T.
BASIS IN TWENTY THIRTY NEARLY
HALF OF THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
WERE. IDENTIFIED TO COME FROM
CAP AND TRAD- AND SO. AS AN
OFFICE I FAILURE WE DO THINK-
RELYING ON CARBON PRICING AND
CAP AND TRADE IS A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO. REDUCE
EMISSIONS BUT THERE ARE NO
THERE ARE JUSTIFICATIONS FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL AND SO
WE THINK EXPLORING SORT OF THE
MIX OF CAP AND TRADE VERSUS
OTHER. POLICIES AND PROGRAMS IS
AN IMPORTANT ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND I'M SURE THAT
WILL BE PART OF THIS HEARING-
SO I THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO
GET TO IS YOUR WHATEVER THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES ON WHAT.
ROLE IT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
COUNTRY PLAY GOING FORWARD-
JUST HAVING THE PROGRAM IN
PLACE IS NOT. NOT SUFFICIENT TO
ENSURE THE PROGRAMS ACHIEVING
THE GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE
HOUSE WHERE OF THE STATE HAS
FOR IT SO- IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM THE DESIGN OF THE
PROGRAM. MATTERS A LOT INSTEAD
I GETS TO THE SECOND POINT
THERE'S A LOT OF- A LOT OF
IMPORTANT DESIGN DECISIONS
AROUND BUT CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND HOW YOU'D LIKE TO
HAVE IT STRUCTURED- I'M GONNA
HIGHLIGHT. ONE IN PARTICULAR AT
ONE THAT HAS AN ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR. A FEW YEARS
ESSENTIALLY SINCE THE EXTENSION
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THROUGH AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT SWITCHES
THE- OF THE OVERALL SUPPLY OF
ALLOWANCES THAT ARE OUT ON THE
MARKET AND WHAT'S KNOWN AS SORT
OF A BANK OF ALLOWANCES- AT. AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW ALLOWANCES CAN
BE KIND OF THAT ARE USED IN THE
PRIOR YEAR CAN BE HELD ONTO AND
BANKS AND USE FOR COMPLIANCE IN
THE FUTURE YEAR. AND THERE'S A
LOT OF GOOD REASONS TO HAVE
THAT DESIGN FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM BUT AS RESULTS- IF
EMISSIONS ARE LOWER THAN THE
NUMBER OF ALLOWANCES THAT ARE
OUT THERE IN THE INITIAL YEARS
OF THE PROGRAM YOU CAN HAVE A
SITUATION. WHERE THERE'S A
LARGE NUMBER OF ALLOWANCES THAT
ARE YOUR AVAILABLE TO USED. AND
YEAR. AND PA. THAT WHEN YOU GET
OUT I. LATER OUT THIRTY LARGE.
ALLOW COULD BE USED TO COMPLY
WITH THE- THE PROGRAM AND AS
RESULTS- THE STATE MIGHT NOT BE
CLOSE TO IT- AND THERE'S JUST A
MISSION TARGETS OUT TO TWENTY
THIRTY. SO I'M HAPPY TO KIND OF
EXPLORE THAT ISSUE IN A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL BUT I JUST WANT
TO SORT OF WHY GET AS ONE KIND
OF. VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AS IT
RELATES TO SORT OF THE
STRINGENCY OF THE PROGRAM.
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS SET UP IN
A WAY THAT- SUFFICIENT AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURES. OF GOALS OUT TO.
OUT TO TWENTY THIRTY- AND SO I
WILL KIND OF- MAYBE STOP MY
COMMENTS JUST. HIGHLIGHTING
THOSE COUPLE THINGS THERE- JUST
AND ENDED BY SAYING- WE ARE
HERE AS YOUR STAFF AND- HERE TO
HELP YOU. SORT THROUGH SOME OF
THESE BIG IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
AROUND THE ROLE OF CAP AND
TRADE AND IMPORTANT DESIGN
FEATURES A PROGRAM- AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF
WHERE YOU'RE GOING FORWARD. YOU
KNOW MISTER BROWN- SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD. INHERITED INHERITED
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AS
WELL AS- CHAIR RANDOLPH TO
RANDOLPH IS COMING IN.
APPROPRIATE LATE RIGHT AT THE
TIME THAT AB THREE NINE EIGHT
IS TAKING. THIS TAKING A
AFFECT- I'D SO THEY WEREN'T
AROUND- IN THE RULES AS AS THEY
ARE TODAY. WHEN THE ENVIRONMENT
CALL THE COMMITTEE WAS SIX
EXPERIENCING THE HORROR
CONSIDERING THE EXTENSION OF
CAP AND TRADE AND- AND I. I
LOSE SLEEP AT NIGHT. KNOWING
THAT. WE WERE TOLD THAT WE
COULDN'T AMEND THAT BILL WERE
STAFF AND YOU IN PARTICULAR
WERE SAYING THAT. THIS
ALLOWANCE PROBLEM. WASN'T VERY
BIG PROBLEM DON'T RULE OVER ALL
THESE ALLOWANCES FROM THE- AB
THIRTY TWO PROGRAM TO THE- AB
THREE NINE A PROGRAM AND- THAT
POLITICAL THIS. WAS MADE. AND
NOW WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
SO- COMING BACK TO YOU BUT- OF
SECRETARY- BLUMENFELD GOOD
MORNING ONCE AGAIN. GOOD
MORNING JACK- BESTIVAL REALLY
APPRECIATE- WHAT ROSS JUST SAID
AND YOU'LL FOCUS ON THIS- OKAY
ABOUT LOSING SLEEP AT NIGHT I'M
I LIKELY DON'T LOSE SLEEP ATNIGHT THINKING ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR VOTE BY DELE SLEEP
AT NIGHT THINKING ABOUT THE
CLIMATE EMERGENCY AND- I AM A
CRISIS THAT WAY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU ALL. AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOCUS ON CLIMATE CHANGE- YEAH
WE HAVE BASICALLY CAPS THE
FOCUS. ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
OF THE LAST FOUR YEARS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ABDICATED ITS RESPONSIBILITY
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AT
A PARTICULAR. THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IT HELPS SHOP
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE DO I'M
AND YEAH ONCE AGAIN FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME'S JERRY
BLUMENFELD I'M THE SECRETARY OF
AB CALLIE PA. I'M AND I ALSO
WANT TO EXTEND A VERY WARM
WELCOME TO CHAIR RANDOLPH I'M
YOU'LL HEAR FROM NEXT- IN HER
NEW ROLE AS YOU MENTIONED CHAD-
SHE IS THE CHAIR OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. HE'S GOT THAT
COMMITMENT AND COMPASSION AND
SMOCKS TO GET US EXACTLY WHERE
ROSS DESCRIBED AS GOING WHICH
IS A TWENTY THIRTY GOALS I JUST
WANTED AS DIE I'M- J. Y. CASKEY
WITH A BIT OF. HISTORY IS
RUSTED AYE I WOULD MAKE SURE
I'M NOT OVERLAPPING BUT REALLY
JUST FOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT CALIFORNIA IS
PLAYING A GLOBAL LEADERSHIP
ROLE WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE
CHANGE I'VE NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE
AMBITIOUS GOALS BUT WE HAVE
AMBITIOUS ACTION. AND REALLY
BEEN A POSITIVE FORCE FOR
DRIVING ENHANCED EFFORTS BY NOT
ONLY THE GOVERNMENTS AROUND THE
WORLD BUT ALSO. THE U. S.
GOVERNMENT HOPEFULLY AS I'LL
AND ON WITH THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE BY DID MINISTRATION SO.
AS WE HAD YOU HAD THE
LEADERSHIP REALLY REQUIRES BOTH
INTEGRATION AND TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE NO SINGLE THING
IS GOING TO SELL OUR CLIMATE
PROBLEM THERE IS NO SILVER
BULLET- ARE KIND OF PROGRAMS
BUILDING A LONG HISTORY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION ACROSS THE STATE.
AND AS YOU HAD FOR ME THE FALL
AND LITERALLY JUST BEFORE ON
THE LAST ITEM THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE. EQUITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN THIS
CONTEXT. I BIPARTISAN AFFECTS
BANDED MINISTRATIONS AND HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM STRONG
LEADERSHIP AND THREE GOVERNORS.
ARE PARTNERS IN THE LEGISLATURE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THE NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE
SECTORS. AND OUR REGULATORY
AGENCIES. CALIFORNIA AND THIS
REALLY THE MY IMPORTANT THING-
J. Y. CASKEY KNOW THIS WE TALK
TO. HIM I COUNTRY WHAT THEY TO
KNOW. HOW IS CAL GROWN OUR
ACCOUNT WHILE REDUCING
EMISSIONS THE SAME TIME. THE
CARBON INTENSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS
DECLINING. AND WE ARE AMONG THE
MOST AMBITIOUS TARGETS IN THE
WORLD AND EMPLOY MORE
CALIFORNIANS. MORE CALIFORNIANS
IN THE CLEAN ECONOMY THAN ANY
OF THE STATE IN THE NATION. WE
WILL ALSO DECOUPLED OUR
EMISSIONS. I'M MISSIONS
REDUCTIONS EFFORT SO WE GROWING
THE ECONOMY WHICH IS GROWING BY
TWENTY SIX PERCENT. BY REDUCING
CARBON EMISSIONS BY THIRTY
PERCENT. APPLE VALLEY THE
BRAKES REDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
INCLUDES POLICIES CHRIS
BUILDING EFFICIENCY. RENEWABLE
POWER OUR RENEWABLE FUELS ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. CLEAN AFRAID
OPTIONS AN ECONOMY WIDE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM. AND PROTECTION
OF OUR NATURAL WORKING LANDS.
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
AND I WANTED TO GO THROUGH JUST
A FEW QUICK EXAMPLES THAT. YOU
IN THE PUBLIC CAN CONCEDE THAT
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE GOALS BUT
WITH WITH CHEATING THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S ACHIEVED ITS
TWENTY TWENTY RENEWABLE ENERGY
GOALS ALLEY. TODAY 63% OF THE
STATE'S ELECTRICITY RETAIL
SALES. COME FROM CARPENTRY
SOURCES. YOU TO NATIONALLY
ENERGY EFFICIENCIES
CALIFORNIANS NOW USE 31% LESS
ENERGY THAN THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN. AND THE STATE'S
APPLIANCE AND BUILDING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS HAVE
RESULTED IN A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS. IN CONSUMER SAVINGS
OVER THE PAST FORTY EIGHT.
WE'VE ALSO ACTED AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL BACKSTOP AS I
MENTIONED TO THE FORMER TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. SIGNING OF
OLIVE TREE FRAME- COME CLEAN
CAR STANDARDS WITH FIVE
AUTOMAKERS AND FIGHTING TO
PROTECT FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. IN
TIMES OF ASK QUALITY.
CALIFORNIA IS A GLOBALLY
RECOGNIZED LEADER ON THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND MY HOME TO EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. TOTALING 45% OF THE
COUNTRY'S ELECTRIC CARS. NO WAY
BY COMPARISON HAS THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THAT BEING SAID WE
LOVE NO WAY FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO MISSED THE SUPERBOWL ADVERT
WILL FERRELL THEY ALL WENT TO
NORWAY TO LOOK AT HOW TO DO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE GOT MORE
THAN TWICE THE NUMBER OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WILL FERRELL
COULD JUST. STATING CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE TO THIRTY FOUR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS AND
EASY'S ON THE STATE NUMBER ONE
VALUE TO EXPLORE AT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. AND
CALIFORNIANS CAN NOW CHOOSE
FROM SIXTY FOUR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE MODELS. LAST YEAR THE
END RESULT IS BOARD ADOPTED THE
TRYING TO CLEAN TRUCK RULES.
THE FIRST IN THE NATION PROGRAM
TO ENSURE RAPID TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION MEDIUM TRUCKS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. PLAYING OUT HOW FREIGHT
SECTOR AND GOODS MOVEMENT IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING%
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE. IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
BURDENED BY THESE ALL AND TOXIC
EMISSIONS ALONG AFRAID
CARDINALS. WILL ALSO CLEANING
UP OUR FUELS CALIFORNIA'S LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD HAS
RESULTED IN THE DISPLACEMENT.
OF NEARLY SEVENTEEN BILLION
GALLONS OF PETROLEUM BASED FUEL
AND WILL SOON BE LAUNCHING OUT
PROCESS AS YOU HAD FROM ROSS.
TO LAUNCH THE SCALPING PLAN
WHICH WILL CHART THE COURSE TO
CARBON. NEUTRALITY IN TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. WILL CONTINUE TO
EQUITY INTO OUR PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE SCOPING PLANS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
LEADERS WILL CONTINUE TO HELP
US SHAPE OUR CARBON NEUTRAL
FUTURE. WILL BE SOLICITING
MEMBERS TO THE E. J. ADVISORY
COMMITTEE NEXT MONTH.
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY
EXPERIENCING WORSENING IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE LAST YEAR WE
EXPERIENCE AS MANY OF YOU FELT
PLEASANTLY THE HOTTEST AUGUST
ON RECORD. AND SOME OF THE
LARGEST WILDFIRES IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
ACCELERATE OUR ACTIONS ON
CLIMATE AND ISSUED EXECUTIVE
ORDERS ON ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES NATIONAL WETLANDS TO
MOVE US TOWARDS AN EQUITABLE
LOW CARBON AND RESILIENT FUTURE.
ON THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM IN
SPECIFICS I'M THIS IS BEEN A
KEY STRATEGY IN OUR PORTFOLIO
TO ACHIEVING OUR GHG REDUCTIONS
SINCE AB THIRTY TO ASSIGN. LAST
SUMMER AS YOU MENTIONED I SEND
YOU A LETTER ABOUT USING THE
NEXT COPING PLAN UPDATES
REVIEWS THE ROLE OF CAP AND
TRADE IN MEETING ON TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET. THAT IS STILL
THE PLAN AND THE SCOPING PLAN
UPDATE WILL BEGIN THIS SPRING
BUT THE FINAL PLAN THE COBBLED
IN LATE TWENTY TWENTY TO FOR
CONSIDERATION. WE'RE CALLING ON
THE OUR CLIMATE POLICIES TO DO
MORE IN THE NEXT DECADE. WE
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
ACCELERATE THE RATE OF EMISSION
REDUCTIONS DRAMATICALLY.
OPPORTUNITIES TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN THE CASH IN TRADE
PROGRAM WILL BEGIN AS PART OF
THE PUBLIC PROCESS TO UPDATE
THE SCOPING PLAN. DO SO NOW
WOULD BE PREMATURE. THE
PROGRAMS IN THE LAST DECADE IS
VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE ONE
THAT CAME INTO PLACE JUST SIX
WEEKS AGO. I'M TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY THIRTY THE CASH
DROPS BY 4% EACH YEAR THAT'S
TWICE THE RATE FROM WHAT IT
DROPPED IN THE LAST DECADE AND
THAT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL. IN
TERMS OF EMISSION REDUCTIONS
IT'S EQUIVALENT TO RETIRING
TWELVE CEMENT LINES IN OUR
STATE- YEAH. AND THIS PROGRAM
JUST CAME INTO EFFECT SIX WEEKS
AGO WAS THE ONE THAT WAS
DESIGNED THROUGH LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION. AS YOU KNOW AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT PLACE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS ON THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM FROM TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY THIRTY.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ALONG WITH
THE AMBITION PROVIDED BY.
SENATE BILL THIRTY TWOS GHG
REDUCTION TARGET FORM THE BASIS
OF HOW THE PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE TO ACHIEVE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS THROUGH TWENTY
THIRTY. IN RECOGNIZING THE
PROGRAM'S ROLE IN ENSURING COST
EFFECTIVE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT
REQUIRED TOP TO ADD A PRICE
CEILING TO ENSURE THAT WOULD
NOT BE ADDRESS IMPACTS TO THE
ECONOMY. ENERGY RAISING
CONSUMER. IS A PARTICULARLY. AT
A TIME WHEN ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TODAY AS
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR UTILITY
BILLS. EIGHTY THREE NINETY
EIGHT ALSO REQUIRES COBB REMOVE
ALLOWANCES THAT REMAIN UNSOLD
AT AUCTION FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS FROM GENERAL
CIRCULATION CORRESPONDING TO
PERIODS OF LOW DEMOTT. DURING
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
WHEN THERE'S POLITICAL
UNCERTAINTY WE REMOVED ABOUT
FORTY MILLION ALLOWANCES FROM
GENERAL CIRCULATION. THIS
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE MAY BE
PERIODS WHERE THE MANTRA
ALLOWANCES WOULD BE LOVE AND
THE NEED TO ADJUST ALLOWING
SUPPLY WOULD REFLECT MARKET
TOMORROW. SINCE DEMAND WAS LOW
DUE TO LOWER EMISSIONS DURING
THE PANDEMIC UNSOLD ALLOWANCES
WILL NOT BE AUCTIONED AND LESS
DEMAND INCREASES. THE LIMIT ON
OFFSETS THE COULD BE USED TO
COMPLY WITH THE PROGRAM BETWEEN%
TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY
TWENTY. EIGHT PERCENT. AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT REQUIRED THAT WE
LIMIT THAT TOO HOT SO HALF OF
THAT AMOUNT STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WITH ALL THESE
REQUIREMENTS AND LAW COBB
UNDERTOOK AN EXHAUSTIVE NEARLY
TWO YEAR RULE MAKING TO AMEND
CAP AND TRADE REGULATIONS. TO
CONFORM TO THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION IN AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT. THE BOARD ALSO VOTED TO
REMOVE ALLOWANCES FROM TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY THIRTY IN
RECOGNITION THAT WE ACHIEVED
OUR TWENTY TWENTY TAGLIATELLE I
WOULD BE BELOW THE AB THIRTY
TWO TARGET IN TWENTY TWENTY.
THIS IS TO FURTHER ADJUST THE
PROGRAM IN RESPONSE TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REPORTING AND MODELING. COBB
TOOK THESE AMENDMENTS AT THE
DIRECTION OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND EXISTING PROGRAM MEETS THE
AUTHORITY AND MANDATE PROVIDED
BY THE LOCAL IMPORTANTLY AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT KEEPS INTACT
THE DECADES LONG THERAPY ED
DISTRICTS TO REGULATE
REFINERIES AND OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES HARMFUL CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS. AND TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS THAT AUTHORITY IS
NOT ALTERED IN ANY WAY. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO SEE
THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THREE NINETY EIGHT AND A CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM AND TO
REVIEWING THE ROLE THE PROGRAM
AND MEETING OUR GHG TARGETS AS
PART OF THE UPCOMING TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SCOPING PLAN. UPDATE
ANY CHANGES WOULD NEED TO BE
CAREFULLY THOUGHT THROUGH AND
ACCOMPANIED. BY ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS THESE AS
PART OF THE COB RULEMAKING.
WHAT HAPPENED TRADE PROGRAMS
PURPOSE IS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. 80% ACROSS 80%
OF THE STATE'S FOSSEL SECTORS
THE AUCTION REVENUE BENEFIT IS
AN IMPORTANT THING TO
HIGHLIGHT. DAY ARE IN SANCHEZ
WILL GO INTO THESE NUMBERS IN
GREATER DETAIL IN A FEW
MINUTES. THE DAY THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM HAS GENERATED
ALMOST THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN AUCTION PROCEEDS TO FUND
CRITICAL CLIMATE INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS. NOTABLY OF THE SIX
POINT THREE BILLION THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN IMPLEMENTED ABOUT
55% OF THOSE PROCEEDS. HAVE
PROVIDED BENEFITS THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
COMMUNITIES WHERE INVESTMENTS A
CAT ARE REALIZING A WIDE RANGE
OF BENEFITS INCLUDING INCREASED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES CLEAN ATHLETES
YOUR MISSION VEHICLES. ENERGY
AND WATER SAVINGS AND GREEN-
MORE VIBRANT COMMUNITY. THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
REQUIRING SALES OF ALL NEW
PASSENGER VEHICLES TO BE ZERO
EMISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
AND ALL OPERATIONS OF MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES TO BE A
100% ZERO EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. WILL AGGRESSIVELY
MOVED THE STATE FURTHER AWAY
FROM ITS RELIANCE ON CLIMATE
HOLDING FOSSIL FUELS WHILE
RETAINING AND CREATING JOBS
SPURRING ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY. THE
TRANSPORTATION EXECUTIVE ORDER
TACKLES EVERY ELEMENT OF HOW WE
MOVE GOODS AND PEOPLE THROUGH
THE STATE FROM POLLS AND RAIL
YARDS TO HIGHWAYS AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. IT'S
DESIGNED TO CLEAN UP THE AIR IN
THE MOST VULNERABLE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FAST. INVESTMENT
EVIDENCE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER
WE'LL SEE SEVERAL FORMS OF
RETURNS INCLUDING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDING ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DEDICATED TO
JUMPSTARTING THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE EXECUTIVE HOLD
IMPLEMENTATION. WILL WITH
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED MILLION AND
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INVESTMENTS AND I PROPOSE ONE
BILLION IN INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL ON DELIVERING A CLIMB
AND SEVEN BUDGET THAT LISTS OUT
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE ALSO
HOPEFUL AND EXCITED TO HAVE
WITHIN YOU FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION. THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSISTENT
ATTACKS ON HEALTH SCIENCE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION COST
US PRECIOUS TIME. WE'VE SEEN AN
IMMEDIATE FOCUS ON THE
PROVIDING TEAM ON A CLEAN CAR
AGENDA OUR ON GOING LEFT RIDGES
POWERFUL SUPER POLLUTANTS FROM
WASTE AND OIL AND GAS. UNDER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
PRIORITIZING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ACROSS THAT CLIMATE
APHIDS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND OTHER
CRITICAL PART AS AN OUT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE ON
CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. AS WE RACE TOWARDS A
CARBON NEUTRAL FUTURE. THANK
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING COMMENTS AT THE END OF
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY
ENERGY OKAY NO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT FURTHER OVERSIGHT
AND I'VE- I WAS REMINDED WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE CLEAN
CAR PRODUCTION DEAD YOU KNOW
TESLA MANUFACTURING FACILITIES
IN MY DISTRICT. DURING THE
PANDEMIC THEY HAVE GONE FROM
TEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES TO
TWENTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES MAY I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF NOISE
ABOUT. THE LAWN MOWER MOVING TO
TEXAS AND I WONDER HOW THAT'S
WORKING OUT OF MINUS TEN
DEGREES THIS MORNING BUT BUT
THIS ISN'T THERE THERE ARE
IMPACTS THAT WE HAVEN'T BRUSHED
ON THANK YOU. CHEER RANDOLPH
WELCOME TO SUBCOMMITTEE. TO THE
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
HERE TODAY AS- I BEGIN MY FIRST
FEW MONTHS OF MY TENURE HERE AT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD. I FEEL
INCREDIBLY PRIVILEGED TO DO
THIS WORK THE MONUMENTAL TASK
OF REDUCING AIR POLLUTION AND
COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE- AND
THEN- AS YOU MENTIONED WE SEE
RECORD COLD HITTING STATES THAT
ARE ILL PREPARED FOR THAT
IMPACT- AND ADDS SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD. MENTION E IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SEEING CLIMATE
IMPACTS HERE- AND WE NEED TO BE
FIGHTING IT AS EFFECTIVELY AS
WE CAN. YOU'RE ALSO REMINDED
THAT- THAT LAKE OF GLOBAL THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS ARE FELT MOST STRONGLY
BY THOSE WHO ARE LEAST EQUIPPED
TO HANDLE IT. AS WE DISCUSSED
THE COMPLEX NUANCES OF HOW WE
DO THIS WORK. WE NEED TO KEEP
IN MIND THAT WE NEED TO BE
PROTECTING THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE. AS WE DO THIS WORK.
I JUST STARTED RECEIVING
BRIEFINGS ON CARBS MANY
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE STATE'S
WORLD LEADING CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES. I LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING PARTNERING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON LONG TERM CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT NATIONALLY AND
GLOBALLY AS WELL. FOR I SPEAK
ON THE SPECIFICS OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE CARBS ORIGINAL
MISSION THE REDUCTION OF AIR
POLLUTION AND THE PROTECTION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS CITED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
HARPIST ASSISTANT WE FOCUSED ON
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION IN THE
MOST BURDEN COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE. AS WE PURSUE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND TO MAINTAIN OUR
EFFORTS TO REDUCE AIR POLLUTION
IN PRIORITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. THE MASS YOU MORE. DID
THAT END THERE ARE SEVERAL NEW
REGULATIONS UNDER DEVELOPMENT
OR RECENTLY ADOPTED THAT
CONTINUE TO DIRECTLY TARGET
POLLUTION IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AS CHAIR BLOOMING AS SECRETARY
OF WOMEN SHALL DISCUSS ONE
REGULATION REQUIRES ZERO
EMISSION DELIVERY TRUCKS AND
CARGO HANDLING EQUIPMENT. BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AND ALL
TRACKS TO HAVE ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
I NAY REGULATION ENSURES THAT
TRUCKS BUT STILL USE
CONVENTIONAL FUELS- ULTRA CLEAN
WATER ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS COME
ONLINE. AND UNDER EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM WE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH AIR DISTRICTS IN
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WHAT SPECIFIC PLANS
AND USED FOCUSED TOOLS TO
DIRECTLY REDUCE LOCAL POLLUTION
AND REDUCE EXPOSURE FOR
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS. NOW I WANT
TO KNOW HOW THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM FITS WITHIN OUR OVERALL
CLIMATE PLANNING WILL BE AB
STAGE TO CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
THE PLAN. THE FIRST AB THIRTY
TWO SCOPING PLAN COMPLETED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT SERVED
AS THE STATE'S ACTIONABLE PLAN
FOR HOW TO ACHIEVE THE STATE'S
TWENTY TWENTY GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOAL. LAYING OUT
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS TO NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS BY TWENTY TWENTY. LOOTED
AND MIX IT INTENT IS
REGULATION. AND A CARBON SHE IN
THE FORM AS CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. THE SCOPING PLAN ALSO
AS NOTED EARLIER INCLUDES. AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OR THE E. JACK THIS
REMAINS AN IMPORTANT SPACE FOR
US TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR VIEWS ARE
INCORPORATED INTO ARTWORK. I TO
SKIPPING PLAN UPDATES IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FOLLOW THE
INITIALS AT THE PLAN. THE
TWENTY THIRTEEN SKIPPING PLAN
UPDATE REVIEWED THE PROGRESS OF
THE PROGRAM AND LAID THE
FOUNDATION FOR LONGER TERM
EMISSION REDUCTIONS BEYOND
TWENTY TWENTY. THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN UPDATE
LAID OUT THE PLAN TO ACHIEVING
THE TWENTY THIRTY GREENHOUSE-GAS GOALS SET BY SB THIRTY TWO.
TO REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS 40%
BELOW NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY THIRTY AND AGAIN
UNDERSCORED THE NEED FOR A
PACKAGE OF COMPLEMENTARY
MEASURES. AS WE ALL KNOW THE
STATE NOT ONLY A TEACHER TWENTY
TWENTY ALL THAT DID SO A FULL
FOUR YEARS EARLY. IT WAS THE
SWEET OF POLICIES IN THE
SCOPING PLAN NOT JUST THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM THAT HELPED
US MEET THAT TARGET. THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO COPING PLAN
CULTURE MANY OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS TO BECOME MORE
STRINGENT FROM. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY THIRTY HELP
ACHIEVE THE TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET. RAMPS THAT WERE
INCREASED IN STRINGENCY INCLUDE
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD AND THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. YOUR CAR BEGINS
WORKING ON ANOTHER SKIPPING
PLAN UPDATE THAT WILL EVALUATE
OUR PROGRESS FOR ACHIEVING THE
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET. AND LAY
OUT THE PATH FOR ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY. THE
SCRAPPING PLAN UPDATE IS NOT
JUST A FORWARD LOOKING DOCUMENT
BUT ALSO A FIVE YEAR
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW OUR
PROGRESS WE EXAMINE OUR
PROGRAMS AND CONSIDER
DEVELOPMENT IN EACH SECTOR TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CASE
MAY BE WARRANTED TO ENSURE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE PATH TO ARTICLE.
THIS INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT
MODELING AND ANALYSES TO ENSURE
THAT ANY CHANGES OUR DATA AND
SCIENCE BASED AND EVIDENCE
DRIVEN. NOW I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT- BEFORE TALKING ABOUT
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM IN
MORE DETAIL TO GIVE A
DISCLAIMER UP FRONT. I HAVE TO
USE CAUTION WHEN DISCUSSING THE
FUTURE OF THE PROGRAM AND ANY
FUTURE CHANGES WE MAY MAY. I
HAVE A FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
AS THE MARKET ADMINISTRATOR
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE NEXT
AUCTION IS TOMORROW TO ENSURE
THAT NOTHING IN MY TESTIMONY OR
RESPONSES TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS WILL SWAY THE MARKET
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER. WE KNOW
POLITICAL UNCERTAINTY AND
STATEMENTS WE MAKE AS
ADMINISTRATORS CAN IMPACT
MARKET. SPECIFICALLY IT HAD HAS
BEEN THE CASE SINCE THE
PROGRAM'S INCEPTION INCEPTION
ANY POTENTIAL ADJUSTMENTS TO
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM WILL BE
STRESSED DISCUSSED IN AN OPEN
PUBLIC PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL STAKEHOLDERS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SAME INFORMATION. AS
MENTIONED THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM WAS AUTHORIZED BY AB
THIRTY TWO IN TWO THOUSAND SIX.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT LAID OUT THE ROLE
OF THE LEGISLATURE ENVISIONED
FOR THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
IN ACHIEVING THE TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET. THE LEGISLATURE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM IN EIGHTY
THREE NINETY EIGHT. THOSE
CHANGES WERE OUTLINED BY
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD. BUT
INCLUDED REDUCING THE ASSET
USAGE LIMIT AND ADDING A PRICE
CEILING AMONG OTHERS. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CARBON MENDED THE CAP
AND TRADE REGULATION TO ALIGN
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION
IN AB THREE NINETY EIGHT IN A
ROBUST REGULATORY PROCESS AND
THOSE CHANGES TOOK EFFECT ON
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR. AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT
LEGISLATIVELY DESIGN PROGRAM
HAS ONLY BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
SIX WEEKS. AS A RESULT THE
IMPACT OF THESE CHANGES ON THE
PROGRAM THE MARKET AND THE
REGULATED ENTITIES IS NOT YET
NOW. KARBALA NEED TO COLLECT
DATA TO ANALYZE THE EFFECTS OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S CHANGES AS
PART OF THE NEXT COPING PLAN
UPDATE. AT THAT TIME IF
NECESSARY SCIENCE BASED AND
EVIDENCE DRIVEN CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM IF BE PROPOSED AND
EXAMINED. THIS IS THE STANDARD
PRACTICE AT HARPER COLLEGE
PROGRAM AND SINCE THE ADOPTION
OF THE CAP AND TRADE REGULATION
IN. TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE
LAMENTED THE PROGRAM EIGHT
TIMES TO IMPROVE IT. MY KIDS
AND SAID ABOUT THE PROGRAM'S
DESIGN AND PRICING BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER THE
CONTEXT OF ITS ADOPTION. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX WHAT
CALIFORNIA PROPOSED WAS GROUND
BREAKING ITS POTENTIAL IMPACT
AND NOW. THE EUROPEAN UNION'S
EMISSIONS TRADING SYSTEM WAS IN
ITS INFANCY. AND FOR THOSE WHO
WERE HERE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX MANY IN THE LEGISLATURE
EXPRESSED GRAVE CONCERNS BUT
THE BROADER AB THIRTY TWO
PROGRAM CALLS FOR ENERGY THE
BALL. AND THAT THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM RESULT WOULD
RESULT IN ECONOMIC RUIN FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE
CONTEXT OF THESE CONCERNS AND
THE RELATIVELY UNTESTED CONCEPT
OF A GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
MARKET. HARD DEVELOP THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM TO LIVE UP TO
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PUT IN STATUTE THAT
REMAIN IN EFFECT TODAY. THIS IS
FRANKLY THAT IT DIDN'T. CHANGE
COST EFFECTIVE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. AND WE
CAN SEE THE RESULTS WE ACHIEVED
OUR TWENTY TWENTY CALL. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN NOT ONLY WITHOUT
HARMING THE ECONOMY BUT AT
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
HIGHLIGHTED CALIFORNIA GROUP TO
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD AND IT'S BECOME A
MAGNET FOR BUSINESSES
RESPONDING TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
LEADERSHIP ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO UNDERSELL
THE CHALLENGE WE FACE AS WE
LOOK TOWARDS TWENTY THIRTY AND
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. MUCH OF OUR
REDUCTIONS HAVE COME FROM A
MASSIVE TRANSFORMATION IN THE
ENERGY SECTOR AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS TO RENEWABLES. AND THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS WHERE
WE MUST NOW SHIFT OUR FOCUS
SINCE IT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. AND OVER 90% OF
THE HARMFUL DIESEL AIR
POLLUTION IN THE STATE.
TRANSITIONING CALIFORNIA'S
MASSIVE PERSONAL AND COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE FLEETS HE ZERO
EMISSIONS WILL REQUIRE A
DIFFICULT UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL
OF EFFORT. BUT IT WILL BENEFIT
BOTH CLIMATE CHANGE AND AIR
QUALITY BECAUSE ZERO EMISSIONS
AND ZERO EMISSION. I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE BY REITERATING MY
ENTHUSIASM FOR WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA. AND AS
WELL AS WORKING TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE OUR AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS SUCH AS CODIFYING THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER. TO
MAKE CARBON NEUTRALITY OCAL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE IS WELL AND
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM OUR
LARGEST SOURCES IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. THANK
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU AND THAT
WE- DO APPLAUD THE HISTORIC
WORK THAT THAT CARPETS DONE ON-
LUCIAN AND THAT CONTINUES TO BE
A MAIN ROLE THAT WE HAVE I KNOW
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CARBON
PROGRAMS WE GET A LITTLE FUZZY
WERE PEOPLE TALK ABOUT. THAT
DECARBONISATION IS THE SAME
THING IS IT AIR POLLUTION AND
WE KNOW KNOX AND SOCKS ARE OF
AIR POLLUTION PROBLEM NOT
NECESSARY THE METHANE PROBLEM
AND THE CARBON PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE SO WE'RE GLAD WE HAVE.
PEOPLE HERE THAT KNOW THAT OUR
NECKS PROFESSOR FROM STANFORD I
HAVE YOUR BOOK HERE MAKING
COMIC POLICY WORK FOR FROM THE
SECRETARY YOU FOR FROM THE
ALLEY- IN YOUR FOR FROM THE NEW
TO. A CHAIR OF THE AIRPORT.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW WE
CAN MAKE THE WESTERN CLIMATE
INITIATIVE POLICY WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. MISTER COLLINS
PROFESSOR CALLING FOR. GOOD
MORNING CHOI PESKY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
AND GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- LET ME JUST SAY A
FEW WORDS ABOUT THE CONTEXT OF
WHERE WE'VE BEEN A THINK OF THE
THREE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS LAID
THIS OUT. VERY WELL- I THINK
WHAT WE ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
TALKING ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IS
IT'S IMPORTANT EMPHASIZE THIS
PROGRAM IS ABOUT HALF OF THE
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE PLANNED. IN
THE MOST RECENT SCOPING UNTIL
WE TALK ABOUT THE MIX OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE POLICIES
AND THERE ARE MANY AND MANY OF
THEM ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL HOW TO
TREAT IS FAR AND AWAY THE
BIGGEST IN TERMS OF THE PLANNED
ROLE FOR THE NEXT STAGE OF THE
CLIMATE POLICY PORTFOLIO- AND
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
AND GET THAT RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST SORT OF ONE AMONG
MANY. IT'S BY FAR THE BIGGEST
ELEMENT OF THAT PORTFOLIO- AND
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE IT. IS A
QUESTION OF WHERE WE GO IN THE
FUTURE AND THE QUESTION I THINK
OF SCIENTIFIC INTEGRITY TO TALK
THROUGH WHAT ALL OF THIS MEANS-
I THINK A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS FRANKLY A
PRETTY FUNDAMENTAL DISCONNECT
ON THE WAY SOME OF THE
DECISIONS WERE MADE IN THE PAST
ABOUT. HOW TO IMPLEMENT THE
ROLE FOR THAT PROGRAM- AND I'M
I'M CONCERNED THAT IF WE REPEAT
THAT EXERCISE WITHOUT A DEEPER
COMMITMENT. TO SCIENTIFIC
INTEGRITY AND TRANSPARENCY WILL
END UP IN A SIMILARLY
CONFLICTED POSITION- BUT I
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
REMARKS MADE. BY THE SECRETARY
AND THE NEW BOARD CHAIR. HAVE
THAT KIND OF DISCUSSION
INAPPROPRIATE. OF PUBLIC
REGULATORY PROCESS IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE THAT IS HOW
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO SHOW ITS
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES AND
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S JUST
CRITICAL IMPORTANT. BEFORE I
GET INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE TO
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION- I AM
OFTEN A SPEAKER YOU INVITE TO
SPEAK ABOUT CAP AND TRADE
ISSUES WHICH MEANS I DON'T GET
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITIES TO
COMMENCE THE BOARD- FOR THEIR
SUCCESS ON ISSUES LIKE THE
CLEAN TRUCKS ROLL IN MOBILE
SOURCE REGULATIONS WERE THINK
IT'S UNEQUIVOCAL THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN OF THE
GLOBAL LEADERSHIP- FOR FRONT.
ON THESE ISSUES- NEVERTHELESS I
THINK WE DO HAVE TO TALK OPENLY
AND FRANKLY ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM GOING INTO THE
NEXT SCOPING PLAN. THE FUNDING
ISSUE- FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS
WHEN ONE LOOKS AT THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPE AND THE MOST
RECENT PLANNING DOCUMENT HOW
THE STATE IS GOING TO ACHIEVE-THE SB THIRTY TWO GOAL. WE SEE
NOT ONLY THIS MAJOR EMPHASIS ON
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. BUT
A DISCUSSION OF THE CAMPING
TRIP PROGRAM IS A WAY TO
ENSURE. THAT THE STATE WILL
ACHIEVE ITS GOALS BECAUSE IT
WILL PERFORM SOME SORT OF HARD
CAP LIKE FUNCTION AND REDUCE
EMISSIONS NO MATTER WHAT- WHEN
ONE LOOKS AT THE LANGUAGE AND
ANALYSIS IN THE SCOPE AND PLAN.
AND COMPARES IT TO THE LANGUAGE
AND THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN RULES I
THINK THERE'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT DISCONNECT. IN HE
MODELING AND TECHNICAL WORK AND
ASSERTIONS THAT ARE MADE AS
BETWEEN THOSE TWO. POLICY
PROCESS HE'S NOT DISCONNECT
THANKS THE SOURCE OF A LOT OF
THE TENSIONS WE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY- SO ONE OF THE THINGS I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT IN MY
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING IS THAT
THE INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS
MARKET ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I
WHERE I SERVED AS THE SENATE
APPOINTEE- ROADS PACIFIC WE ON
THIS ISSUE. AND I UNDERSTAND
IT'S BEEN INCLUDED IN THE
BACKGROUND MATERIALS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. I BRING THIS
UP BECAUSE THE BOARD HAS A
NUMBER OF CHOICES ABOUT HOW TO.
PROCEED WITH THE WAY IT THANKS
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IN THE
SCHOOL COMPOUND PROCESS AND
THEN IN ANY FUTURE REGULATORY
PROCESS USE THAT MY DEMAND THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. AND THE
I AM ACT CHAPTER ADDRESSES SOME
OF THESE TENSIONS AND ISSUES
HISTORICALLY AND I HOPE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE CAN WORK
THROUGH AND TALK ABOUT. BECAUSE
CONSISTENCY BETWEEN THE SCOPING
PLAN. AND THE REGULATORY
PACKAGE- UNDERLYING THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL TO
MEET WHATEVER SET OF GOALS AND
DECISIONS. THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BOARD
WANTS TO TAKE- SO I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT AREA
TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THE POTENTIAL
FOR CONSISTENCY TO RESOLVE SOME
OF THESE TENSIONS. I WANT TO
ADD THAT. IN A COUPLE OF THE
THINGS I'VE HEARD MAY BE
RELEVANT FOR THE COMMITTEE'S.
CONSIDERATION THE- QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER THE PRO IS FOR.
WELL IS AN- AND TECHNO CONTRA-
I MEAN THAT'S I UNDERSTAND THAT
MEANS IT'S ALSO FREQUENTLY
SOMEWHAT DELTA FOLKS. AND
SOMEWHAT COMPLICATED- PART OF
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THERE
AREN'T VERY CLEAR TECHNICAL
METRICS TO TRACK PROGRAM. AND
THE I MAC AMONG OTHERS HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD PRODUCE THESE
KINDS OF METRICS WHICH ARE
STANDARD AND OTHER CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE THE
EAST COAST REGGIE PROGRAM. AS
WELL AS THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
EUROPEAN UNION PROGRAM. ALL
THESE METRICS TO TRACK THE
QUESTION OF THE NUMBER OF
OUTSTANDING ALLOWANCES AND ALSO
TO THE PROGRAM. INDEED THE
RESOURCES FORTY ONE HAS SUCH A
METRIC FOR THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD BUT- FOUR YEARS HAS
BEEN. UNABLE OR UNWILLING TO
PRODUCE SUCH A METRIC FOR THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. YEAH I
AM ACT DEVELOPED A METHOD I
PUBLISHED A PEER REVIEWED
SCIENTIFIC PAPER TO SHOW HOW IT
COULD BE DONE. WE HAVEN'T
REALLY HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT HOW
THE BOARD MIGHT CONSIDER
POSITIONS. AND I MENTION THIS
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
TRACK WHAT'S GOING ON IF YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO USE EVIDENCE
BASED. BASED METHODS TO FIGURE
OUT WHETHER OR NOT THE PROGRAM
IS DOING WHAT WE WANTED TO DO.
AND I THINK THERE'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITIES TO AIM
FOR A HIGHER BAR IN THE CYCLE-
AND USE EVIDENCE TO GUIDE SOME
OF THESE DECISIONS BECAUSE FROM
MY POINT OF VIEW THAT IS. NOT A
FAIR DESCRIPTION OF THE WAY
THINGS WENT DOWN PREVIOUSLY.
AND THAT IS NOT A COMMENT WITH
RESPECT TO. THE NEW LEADERSHIP
OF CALLIE PA AND THE NEW. CHAIR
BOARD. I THINK. THE OTHER.
COUPLE THINGS TO MENTION BRIEF-
RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE
PREMIER RESOURCES BOARD
COMMITTED THE STAFF TO PRODUCE
AN ANALYSIS OF THE NUMBER OF
ALLOWANCES THAT ARE BANKS-
AFTER THE PROGRAM'S TWENTY
TWENTY. COMPLIANCE PERIOD. OF
COMPLETES. AND THAT ANALYSIS IS
DUE BY THE END OF THIS YEAR SO
WE WILL PRESUMABLY HAVE SOME
FORMAL PUBLIC STATEMENT FROM
THE BOARD ON THESE METRICS. ARE
WHERE I THINK WE ARE GOING TO
SEE THAT THE NUMBER OF BANKS
ALLOWANCES IS FAR IN EXCESS OF
WHAT THE BOARD SAID IN ITS
PREVIOUS WERE MAKING STATEMENT
I THINK THAT WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS. SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES IN THIS PROGRAM-
THE LAST THING I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT. BOTH THE
SECRETARY AND THE NEW BOARD
CHAIR REFERENCE THE IDEA THAT
THE A BETWEEN NINETY
REGULATIONS TOOK EFFECT JUST
SIX WEEKS AGO- THIS IS TRUE AS
A MATTER OF LAW THE REGULATIONS
TOOK EFFECT IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR. BUT OF COURSE THEY WERE
FINALIZED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO MENTION
THIS BECAUSE I THINK EVERY
SINGLE PARTICIPANT IN THE
MARKET HAS BEEN TRADING ON THE
BASIS OF THOSE PERFECTLY
UNDERSTOOD REGULATIONS. SINCE
THOSE REGULATIONS WERE
COMPLETED. SO WELL IT MAKES
VERY GOOD SENSE. TO BE CAUTIOUS
AND THOUGHTFUL AND THE MARKET
REGULATOR'S ROLE AS A
FIDUCIARY. I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE RULES AND
PERFORMANCE OF THE MARKET HAS
BEEN CRYSTAL CLEAR TO EVERYBODY
PARTICIPATING IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS- AND THAT I DON'T
THINK IS A- GOOD REASON TO-
TALK ABOUT DEFERRING. A MORE
DETAILED CONVERSATION ON WHAT
SHOULD BE DONE- IF INDEED.
THERE IS POTENTIALLY AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN
THE FUTURE- I THANK. MISTER
CHAIR THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
PLACE FOR ME TO LEAVE MY
REMARKS AND I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. WELL WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
SHARE THAT AMBITION HAS ALL THE
PANELISTS HAVE TODAY TO REALLY
DECARBONIZE. OUR SOCIETY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I GUESS YOU
KNOW WERE. LET'S LET'S GO BACK
TO THE BALANCE I MEAN WE'VE WE
KNOW THAT THE- THERE'S A-
RELIANCE ON. THE CARPENTRY TO
REDUCE TO MEET OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THIS OUTLINED IN-
AB- THIRTY TO THE FOR THE-
SECRETARY- THE- A CHAIR DO YOU
PLAN TO REFILL IT VISIT THIS
BALANCE OF CAP AND TRADE AND
OTHER MEASURES IN THE NEW
SCOPING PLAN WHAT THE WEIGHT
OF. OF THE RULE OF CAP AND
TRADE SHOULD BE WILL START OFF
WITH THAT GET PEOPLE'S INPUT.
TAGS YES BASICALLY THE ANSWER
IS YES- THAT THE- SCOPING
PLANS- PROCESS WILL RELY ON
AND- ANALYZING THE- EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND IT'S ALREADY- TO
DETERMINE HOW TO ACHIEVE
REDUCTIONS AND THEN. DETERMINE
WHAT ADDITIONAL REDUCTIONS I
NEED TO BE. ADDRESSED BY CAP
AND TRADE SO- WE KNOW THAT FOR
INSTANCE THE AS THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND IS GOING TO HAVE
SAID- THE IMPACT ON HOW WE LOOK
AT. AT THE ROLE OF OTHER
EMISSIONS REDUCTION STRATEGIES
THAT WE WILL ABSOLUTELY-
ANALYZE THAT IN THIS. EXCELLENT
SECTOR BLOOMFIELD YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD. NO I THINK- J.
RANDALL SAID IT REALLY
ARTICULATELY WHICH IS AND JUST
TO KIND OF MAKE THE POINT THAT
DANNY AINGE AND RANDO. MAKING
IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU KNOW
THAT WHEN YOU GO AND TALK TO
THE COB FOLKS THERE ARE A LOT
OF PHD. PEOPLE THAT THAT
RELEASE DIDN'T HAVE VERY VERY
CRITICALLY ABOUT MAKING SURE WE
USING METRICS AND BASING ON
SCIENCE AND OUTCOMES AND THAT
AND I THINK THAT'S RIGHT COBB'S
BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL SAYS. DJ
RANDALL'S POINT DISCOVERY
PROCESS ALLOWS US TO DO THAT
AND- NOW JUST AS ONE FOOTNOTE.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT THE
GOVERNOR CAME OUT WITH TO GET
TO A 100% ZERO MISSION AND-
THANK SALES BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE WHO WILL HAVE A DRAMATIC
IMPACT ON HOW THAT. HOW WE LOOK
AT THOSE DIFFERENT- BALANCE IT
IS INSPECTED SAYS YEAH IT. IS
AN IMPORTANT POINT WE WE'VE
MADE A LOT OF REFERENCES TO THE
LOSCO THE PLAN- I WHEN I WHEN I
TALK ABOUT THE SCOPING PLAN AND
THE CROSSES THAT- LEANNE AND
HER TEAM WILL UNDERTAKE- I DO
IT IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT CLIMATE THING THAT
WILL HAPPEN- IT IN THE NEXT.
DECADE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT
REALLY WILL WILL SHAPE HOW
THINGS HAPPENED SAID WE WILL
PUT IN A LOT OF EMPHASIS ON
THAT AND I ENVISAGE REALLY IS
MAKING SURE IT'S- BUT A LOT OF
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. A LOT OF
AS JAY RANDOLPH MENTIONED
EQUITY AND OTHER CONSENSUS THE
TABLES SET YET THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT PROCESS AND- IT'S OUR
JOB IS TO LISTEN AND LEARN AND
CALIBRATE. YEAH WELL WE'LL GET
TODAY EXPENDITURE PLAN ON THE
NEXT AND NEXT THING I KNOW WERE
WERE EAGER TO GET TO THE DOES
THAT PROGRAM AND I'VE OBVIOUSLY
EAGER TO FIND OUT WHY C. B. R.
P. IS NOT FUNDED BUT THAT'S I'M
GETTING AHEAD OF MYSELF ON THE
ON THE ISSUES- ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR ME SINCE WE
INCLUDED IN OUR- MATERIALS HERE
THE- RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE-
EIMAC THE INDEPENDENT.
EMISSIONS MARKET ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MISTER BROWN YOU SIT
ON THAT BUT YOU'RE NOT A OF
VOTING- MEMBER I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS FOR THE SECRETARY-
AND THE CHAIR RANDOLPH IS THAT.
ARE YOU ANTICIPATING
CONSIDERING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND HOW THEY
HOW TO HAVE THIS CONSISTENCY
WITH THE WITH THE NEW SCOPING
PLAN AND THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM THIS BALANCING ACT THAT.
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO GO ON-
PROFESSOR CALL WORDS. TALKED
ABOUT THE MATCH BE AT THAT. YES
ABSOLUTELY- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONSIDERING ALL IMPACT
INCLUDING- THAT FROM THE PUBLIC
AND THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE SUCH
AS IRAQ AND THE- EIGHTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT OFF WORSE- SO WELL
WE CAN'T REALLY. A SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION THE PURPOSE OF
THE LANDSCAPING PLAN PROCESSES
TO REALLY ANALYZE ALL THAT IN
PLACE AND I UNDERSTAND IT AND
DEVELOP THAT THE CORRECT PLAN
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU THAT'S
THAT'S BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
BE TOO MUCH OF A LAWYER BECAUSE
I WANT TO GET TO VICE CHAIR
DOLLIES BUT HE ANTICIPATES THE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO DO
REGULATIONS AND THE SCOPING
PLAN DO EXPECT THOSE TO RUN.
CAN CURRENTLY THAT YOU START
WITH THE- THE RULE REVIEW AND
THE SCOPING PLAN OR
CONSECUTIVELY. OR DON'T KNOW.
SORRY I WAS HAVING A LITTLE
TROUBLE GETTING MYSELF LAST-
FAN OF NEW FOR A MOMENT- SO AND
WE DISCUSSED EXPECTING FINAL
KICK US IN THE SPRING AND WILL
BE HOLDING WORKSHOPS AND
RELEASED A DRAFT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WITH THE WITH THE
GOAL OF THE FINAL PLAN IN LATE
TWENTY TWENTY PM- AND I REALLY
THINK WE NEED TO- GO THROUGH
THAT PROCESS IN UNDERSTAND WHAT
ADDITIONAL CHANGES- WOULD BE
NEEDED AS WE CONSIDER- OR AFTER
WE CONSIDER. THAT SORT OF THE
ROLE OF THECAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND SO- GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY ON THE OUTCOME AND
THAT AND THE PROCESS OF THE
SCOPING PLAN- I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE CAN MAKE A SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION AS TO KIND OF A
REGULATORY TIMELINE- OR EVEN
WHETHER AT SIGNIFICANT
REGULATORY CHANGES ARE
NECESSARY SO I THINKTHAT IS A
KIND OF A TO BE DETERMINED TO
QUESTION. OKAY BECAUSE I KNOW
THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE A LOT OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND EARLY ACTION
AND THINGS THAT HE WANTS TO DO
WHEN AND HOW WE CAN MEET THE
MOMENT RIGHT WE CAN MEET THE
MOMENT SO HOPEFULLY PEOPLE IN
FINANCE WE CAN DO THESE THINGS
CONCURRENTLY TO SHOW OUR TO
SHOW THE WORLD OUR AMBITION
HERE AND IN CALIFORNIA. MISTER
BROWN. YOU HAVE ANYTHING THAT
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON. MY
LOOKING AT THE EVERYBODY'S FACE.
OKAY A CENTER DOLLY HAS
QUESTIONS WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA SAY ON I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL THE NEW- FOLKS WHO ARE. AT
THE AIRPORT IN EPA- BUT I WANT
I JUST WANNA MAKE SOME GENERAL
COMMENTS TO START OUT WITH. AND
I SAID TO THE LAST GO BEING
HEARING- WHAT THAT TIME WAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- CHESBRO AND WE
HAD- MARY NICHOLS THERE AND WE
ASKED THEN- I ASKED. ABOUT
TOTAL CARMEN CARMEN IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
CARBON AND WILL MOSTLY FOCUS
TODAY'S BEEN ON. EMISSIONS
DRIVE FROM TRANSPORTATION AND
WE DON'T REALLY TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT THERE'S BEEN
A HUGE AMOUNT OF CARBON-
RELEASE FROM FOREST FIRE. AND
SO IT'S BEEN ONE OF MY PET
PEEVES I'VE I TALK ABOUT ALL
THE TIME AND I TYPICALLY GET.
ALVO DID. MOSTLY ON MOST
COMMITTEES I SAID ON- MAYBE
IT'S BECAUSE I'M I'M IN A
DIFFERENT- LOOK THOUGHT PROCESS
I GUESS. BUT WHAT I WANTED TO
SAY IS THAT. WE NEED TO LOOK AT
HOLISTICALLY AT OR CARBON
OUTPUT BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE CAN DO ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT AND I WANT TO SHARE
ALSO THAT. I'M A FARMER. AS
FOOD FOR PEOPLE EAT THAT I'M
I'M PRETTY SURE EVERYBODY HAS
TO HAVE THAT MOSTLY EVERY DAY.
EXCEPT IN THAT TO AND I COMPETE
WITH COMPANIES THAT. AND FARMS
THAT ARE IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRUGGLING. I'LL JUST BE HONEST
WITH YOU ALSO HAVE A TRUCKING
BUSINESS. AND I'VE BEEN
IMPACTED BY I BELIEVE THE
BIGGEST TAX PUT ON CALIFORNIA'S
INDUSTRY. WHICH WAS AB THIRTY
TWO NOW I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT I AM ALL FOR.
CARBONITE I THINK WE SHOULD
REDUCE OUR- CARBON FOOTPRINT I
THINK WE SHOULD REDUCE
POLLUTION I THINK THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE IMPACTED I WANT TO
HELP THEM. BUT I THINK IT'S HOW
WE GO ABOUT IT. IT'S THE
PRIORITY OF HOW WE SPEND THE
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN.
BASICALLY TAXED OR ARE FORCED
TO PAY FOR THEIR MISSIONS. AND
I BROUGHT UP SEVERAL TIMES IN
AND I THINK THE PUBLIC IS
CATCHING ON TO THIS STUFF. BUT
THE FACT THAT WE SPEND. HUGE
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS ON
TRANSPORTATION A TRAIN THAT
WE'RE BUILDING THAT I'VE IN MY
MIND I BELIEVE WILL NEVER BE
COMPLETED. AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE FRUSTRATION AND I HEARD- MR
BLUMENFELD SAY THAT YOU KNOW
THE CONNIE GREW BY TWENTY SIX
PERCENT. AND WE'RE LEADING THE
WORLD AND HOW WE DO. YOU KNOW
CARBON REDUCTION BUT I'D LIKE
TO KNOW WHERE THE ECONOMY GREW
DID IT GROWTH PACIFIC LEE FROM.
OUR CARBON GOALS OR DID IT GROW
BECAUSE WE HAVE A- AND MEGA
AMOUNT OF WORLD CORPORATIONS
THAT PAY. IN CAPITAL GAINS TAX
THAT'S IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BUDGET AND FIND OUT WHERE THE
MONEY COMES FROM THERE
ACTUALLY- THAT HE PUT OUT A
REPORT THAT SEVEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED TAXPAYERS PAID
60% OF OUR TAXES AND THOSE ARE.
VERY WEALTHY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE GETTING
CAPITAL GAINS SO I'M VERY MUCH
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ECONOMY-
AND THE LONG TERM- LOOKING OF-
THE LONG TERM EFFECTS OF THE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE HERE.
AND SO I THAT'S THE COMMENT I
WANT TO MAKE AYE AYE I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW. YOU KNOW. I THINK
THAT WAS THE PROFESSOR THAT
SAID EVIDENCE BASED POLICY. AND
THE MATRIX IS VERY IMPORTANT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I'M GONNA BE
LOOKING THIS MATRIX WE DON'T
COULD WILDFIRE WE'RE LYING TO
OURSELVES IS SAYING HEY WORRY
REDUCE EMISSIONS WERE NOT WE
BURKE FOUR MILLION EIGHT. FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION ACRES LAST
YEAR. HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
ACRES EVERY YEAR. PAST THAT AND
WE'RE GONNA BURN MORE AND WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT.
TRANSPORTATION WHEN WE AND I
KNOW WE THE LEGISLATURE HAD TO
FORCE. BY LEGISLATION SB NINE
ONE WHICH I WAS A BIG PLAYER IN
TO GET T DONE TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING IN CARBON REDUCTION
ON FUELS. AND I'VE SAID IT IN
THIS COMMITTEE EARLIER. LOOK
THERE'S THREE THINGS THAT CAUSE
WILDFIRE OXYGEN IGNITION AND
FUEL. IF THE ONE THING WE CAN
CONTROL IS FUEL WE NEED TO
REDUCE THE FUEL LOADING IN OUR
WATERSHEDS. IF WE'RE GOING TO
REDUCE CARBON AND IF NOT IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOU DO.
WE'RE GONNA BURN. SO I'M ON
BOARD I THINK THE WAY WE DO IT
IS THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON GETTING TAKING CARE
OF OUR WATERSHEDS WHICH IS OUR
WILL OUR QUOTE WATER QUALITY IN
OUR WILDLIFE IS PROTECTED WHEN
WE DO THAT AS WELL. I WANTED TO
TOUCH ON ONE LAST THING AND
THEN I'LL BE HAPPY TO SEE.
LISTEN BACK ABOUT WHAT'S IT AND
I THINK IT'S WRONG THAT WE HAVE
THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT ARE.
ARE WHICH I THINK RUN
CONSTITUTIONAL UNDER THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY THE GOVERNOR'S
DONE EXECUTIVE ORDERS. TO GET
US TO TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WITH
ALL ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
THAT'S GREAT NO PROBLEM BUT HOW
WE GONNA GET THERE AND STILL
HAVE AN ECONOMY AT THE END OF
THE DAY HOW MY GONNA RUN MY
FORM AND HOW MY NEIGHBOR'S
GONNA RUN THEIR FARMS ON ZERO
MISSION IF ISSUES BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. TELL ME HOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE AND THEN.
I'LL DECIDE WHETHER I'M GONNA
STAY IN CALIFORNIA OR NOT
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF BUSINESSES
OUT THERE THEY'RE GOING IS A
GREAT IDEA AND EVERY FEELS GOOD
ABOUT IT. WE DO POLICY AROUND
HERE ON FEELING GOOD NOT.
FACTUAL MATRIX WHICH I HEARD.
IN EVIDENCE BASED POLICIES.
IT'S ALL BE CRITICAL OF THOSE
WE ASKED. SHARE NICHOLS FIVE
YEARS AGO WHAT ABOUT FOREST
FIRES AND YOUR ANSWER WAS
THAT'S A NATURAL DISASTER WE
DON'T COUNT THAT. THAT'S WRONG
I'M BREATHING NOT SMOKE EVERY
YEAR AND SEWER ALL THE
CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE AND
THEY'RE GETTING TIRED OF
HEARING HEY WE'RE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING BUT ALL THEY'RE DOING
IS REGULATING THIS AREA. AND
NOT FOCUSING ON A HUGE EMITTER.
AND ON TOP OF THAT WE'RE
SPENDING MONEY ON THE TRAINING
THAT DOESN'T GET US ANYTHING
AND IT'S BILLIONS OF DOLLARS I
THINK THAT WE'RE GONNA THE
PEOPLE ARE GONNA WAKE UP TO
THIS I HOPE. AND THROW PEOPLE
OUT OFFICE THAT ARE MAKING BAD
DECISIONS. AGAIN I WANT TO CAP
OFFICE SAYING IN CLOSING THAT I
AM FOR. A GOOD SOLID CLIMATE
POLICY THAT MAKES SOME SENSE
THAT ACTUALLY DOES SOMETHING
THAT HELPS. CALIFORNIANS
BREATHE CLEANER AND WE STOP
EMITTING IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
THE LEADER IN THE WORLD AND
MUST BE THE LEADER IN THE RIGHT
WAY AND LET'S BE TRANSPARENT
ABOUT IT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. MISPRICED YOUR THIS I
THANK YOU JUST SO WE'RE ALL
CLEAR CENTER STERN CENTER
MCGUIRE CENTER MINING NOW
RETIRED MYSELF THIS SUB
COMMITTEE WAS THE FIRST SUB
COMMITTEE THAT CAME UP WITH THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR. OF
FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND THAT WAS INCORPORATED IN A
FIVE YEAR PLAN FOR NINE A ONE
SO THERE'S SOME HOPE THAT THE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS THAT WE DO
TODAY HERE AND THE HARD
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE A WE ASK
HAVE ARE THE NUCLEUS WHENEVER
NOBODY KNOWS EXCEPT FOR THE
ANELISTS OF THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE IN TV LAND- CENTER STERN
YOU HAVE YOUR HAND UP. THE
FLOOR YOUR WEIGHT ARE THE
PANELISTS ANY COMMENTS ON. OR
THOUGHTS ON A CENTER DOLLIES-
SUPPORT OF MATRIX AND
PRIORITIZING- OUR SPENDING PLAN
TO GET THE DEEP CARBONIZATION.
YEAH GERMAN HELP FROM CALLIE PA
JUST- TERMS AS SENATOR DOLLY OF
FESTIVAL THANK YOU FOR THAT
WHAT YOU ENDED ON WHICH IS HE
YOU KNOW THE GOAL OF MOVING
FORWARD ON A MATRIX BASED
COMMONSENSE APPROACH TO- TO
HERITAGE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS I THINK THAT'S
EVERYONE'S GOAL- AND FRANKLY
HAVING THAT BIPARTISAN. FOCUS
WE MAY ISAGREE ON ON WAYS OF
ACHIEVING IT BUT HAVING THAT
THAT BIPARTISAN FOCUS TO BEGIN
WITH I THINK IT'S BEEN WHAT'S
HOW CALIFORNIA IT IS FAR AS IT
HAS- INTENDED JUST WANT ONE
ELEMENT WHICH WAS THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT- IT WAS NOT TAKEN
UNDER THE EMERGENCY ORDERS THAT
EXIST ON THAT BECAUSE OF IT IS
THE GENERAL AUTHORITY OF THE
GOVERNOR TO ISSUE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND THEN. JUST ON THE ON
THE POINT ABOUT- IT'S OUR
ABILITY TO ACHIEVE THAT I'M
GENERAL MOTORS- TWO WEEKS AGO
CAME OUT WITH A GOAL WHICH IS
THAT OLDER VEHICLES SOLD. I'M
ACROSS GM WILL BE A 100% ZERO
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
THE W. HAS HAD A GOAL OF TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN TO SELL ITS LAST
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE BUT
THE POINT THAT I WANT TO MAKE
TO YOU AND- HOW THE FOLKS IN
AGRICULTURAL AND OTHER AREAS
IS. A SALES MANDATE SO IT'S
SAYING TO THE COMPANIES BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE USUAL AT
LEAST SELL. ELECTRIC VEHICLES
SO THE ENTIRE FLEET OF VEHICLES
THAT ARE RUNNING I MEAN YOU
COULD BUY IN IN TWENTY THIRTY
FULL AN INTERNAL COMBUSTION
VEHICLE- YOU COULD BUY ONE NOW
AND STILL DRIVE IT IN TWENTY
FORTY SEVEN M. IT JUST TO BE
REALLY CLEAR IT IS NOT A.
PROHIBITION ON PEOPLE DRIVING.
HELLO VEHICLES IN TWENTY THIRTY
EIGHT NANA THE INTO THIRTY IT'S
VERY- THE MANUFACTURE HAE NOT.
TO SELL AND THE LAST THING I
WANTED TO SAY ADAM. IS JUST A
BIG THANK YOU TO YOU AND
AGRICULTURE IN GENERAL- YOU
HAVE DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH A R. B. AND
US. ON REDUCING EMISSIONS- AND
AS WE'LL TALK ABOUT WITH THE
PHAM A PROGRAM. WHEN DEPUTY
SECRETARY LEARN SANCHEZ GOES TO
THE BUDGET- THOSE PROGRAMS TO
REALLY HELP CLEAN UP THE AIR IN
PLACES LIKE THE SAN JOAQUIN AND
SOUTH BECAUSE OF. FARMERS IN
AGRA BEEN A TREMENDOUS
TREMENDOUS. PADA AND SUPPORTER
AN INNOVATOR AND THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE REDUCE AB POLLUTION I
JUST WANTED TO APPRECIATE YOU
FOR THAT. CENTER CALLING. I
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS I
WANTED TO JUST ADD. ONE LAST
THING THAT JUST CAME TO MIND IS
THAT. DO WHEN WILL WE START
PUTTING. THE ADMISSIONS OF
FOREST FIRE IN OUR CALCULATION.
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T DO THAT I
BELIEVE WE DON'T CALCULATE. THE
MISSIONS THAT COME OFFOF FIRE
INTO THE CLIMATE ACTION PLAN WE
AT LEAST WE DIDN'T ON UNDER THE
LAST COPING ARE YOU PLANNING
ON. IN THIS SCOPING PERIOD
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE AMOUNT
OF MISSIONS THAT ARE- RELEASED
UNDER FORCE FIRE. DETERMINING
THAT- INPUT INTO DISCUSSING
PLAN WILL BE PART OF THE
PROCESS GOING FORWARD. THAT'S A
STRAWBERRY B. YES YES IT WAS I
DIDN'T WAS THAT A YES OR NO
MAYBE OKAY. WE WILL EXAMINE
THAT QUESTION. WELL I ATTEMPTED
TO RUN A BILL TO HAVE THAT
HAPPEN AND IT HASN'T BEEN
SUCCESSFUL- SO DO WE DO THINK
WE NEED LEGISLATION TO. GIVE
SOME DIRECTION. WELL I GUESS I
WOULD SAY- IT. YOU KNOW WE ARE
REGULATORY PROCESS REALLY IS
ABOUT AND GETTING ALL OF THE-
INPUT AND- ARGUMENTS FOR AND
AGAINST VARIOUS DECISIONS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IN THAT
PROCESS AND SO THAT IS- OUR
PLAN GOING FORWARD. SO WOULD
YOU AGREE THAT- FOREST FIRES
ARE. A BIG PROBLEM OF OUR-
EMISSIONS FOR CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT YOU KNOW FOREST FIRES ARE
CRITICAL ISSUE AND- IT IS. AS
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD MENTION
IT'S YOU KNOW ADDRESSING ISSUES
RELATED TO NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR AS COPING PLANNED AND
ALICE'S AND DISCUSSION. MISTER
CHAIR I WONDER IF I MIGHT OFFER
A QUICK RESPONSE THE CENTER
DIALING PLEASE PROFESSOR SAN
CENTER I JUST WANTED TO AFFIRM
YOUR YOUR- ASSERTION THE
POOREST EMISSIONS FIRE MISSIONS
ARE NOT INCLUDED IN TODAY'S
INVENTORY. AS OF CARBS MOST
RECENT DRAFT EMISSIONS REPORT
EMISSIONS FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIRES WHICH ARE UNLIKE
ANYTHING ANY OF US EVER LIVE
THROUGH. WERE SLIGHTLY OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION TONS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE IT'S ABOUT TRIPLE THE
WORST FIRE SEASON BEFORE THAT.
I'M AND IT'S ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
THE COVERAGE OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AN ANNUAL BASIS
AS TO THE POLICY DECISIONS THE
BOARD MIGHT TAKE IN THE FUTURE
I'LL JUST FLAG. THE DISCUSSION
AROUND- GOVERNOR BROWN'S CARBON
NEUTRALITY EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WHICH I HEARD
THE SECRETARY AND CURRENT CHAIR
SAY WOULD BE PART OF THE NEXT
COUPLE PLAN PROCESS. I DON'T
THINK ONE CAN TALK ABOUT CARBON
NEUTRALITY WITHOUT THINKING
COMPREHENSIVELY ABOUT BOTH THE
CARBON BENEFITS AND EMISSIONS
CONCERNS RELATED TO NATURAL
WORKING LANDS INCLUDING
FORESTS. SO I WOULD CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT THIS BECOMES PART OF
THE CONVERSATION EVEN THOUGH I
WOULD BE SOMEBODY WHO WOULD SAY
WE OUGHT TO MANAGE OUR ENERGY
SYSTEM IN OUR LAND SYSTEMS WITH
DIFFERENT GOALS AND DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES WHERE PERHAPS YOU
MIGHT HAVE A DIFFERENT POINT OF
VIEW BUT I DO THINK EVENTUALLY
THOSE CONVERSATIONS HAVE TO
COME TOGETHER. NOT FOR THE
REASONS YOU SUGGESTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT
I AGREE- THAT THEY'RE TWO
DIFFERENT POTS BUT THEY THEY
DO- STILL OF. THERE'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MISSIONS AND- I'LL BE
LOOKING FORWARD TO READING YOUR
BOOK BY THE WAY. THERE ISN'T
THAT THERE IS A NICE PIECE ON.
NPR THIS MORNING WHEN I WAS
DRIVING UP ABOUT PROFESSOR
BURDON AND STANFORD TALKING
ABOUT. TODAY THERE'S ABOUT
SIXTY DAYS WERE THE POLLUTION
FROM WILDFIRES AS- IT GOES OFF
THE CHARTS COMPARED TO A DECADE
AGO WHEN IT WAS LIKE THREE OR
FOUR. AND THAT'S NOT A COVERED
ENTITY. WE HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED
THE PATTY. THE ANNUAL TARGETS
FROM THE SCOPING PLAN VERSUS
THE CAME OF TARGETS A CAP AND
TRADE AND THAT'S IN OUR REPORT.
CENTER STERN EUROPE. SANDERSON
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR QUESTION
OKAY THANKS MISTER CHAIR-
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION I
KNOW I KNOW WE'RE- CONSISTENTLY
TALKING ABOUT CAP AND TRADE
RIGHT NOW BUT- I APPRECIATE THE
WIDE RANGING. REDUCE FLUID
NATURE OF THE CONVERSATION- AND
IT IT ONLY UNDERSCORES FOR ME I
GUESS WHAT- ALEJO POINTED OUT
TO BEGIN WITH WHICH IS THAT.
THERE'S A BROADER FRAMEWORK
AND- I THINK THIS REGULATION
GETS A LOT OF ATTENTION BUT I
APPRECIATE THE THAT THE LAST
DISCUSSION ON THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PIECE AND SOME OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION GOALS THAT-
REALLY ARE VERY DIFFERENT
FUNCTION IN THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND- AND I DON'T THINK
THERE'S GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER. HAS RECEIVED NEARLY- THE
ATTENTION- OR- OR FOCUS THAT IT
DESERVES IN THAT. AT THE TRAP.
RIGHT NOW. FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS
AND FOR PEOPLE STRUGGLING IN
POVERTY IS OFTEN ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TRAP THAT THEY'RE IN
WITH THEIR VEHICLE FOR DRIVERS
FOR SUPER COMMUTERS AROUND THE
STATE FOR WORKING PEOPLE WHO
ARE STRUGGLING THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
SPENDING MORE THAN HALF THEIR
INCOME SOME OF THE DATA WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT. SHOWS THAT
HOUSEHOLD SPENDING MORE ON
TRANSPORTATION THEN FOOD AND
HEALTH CARE COMBINED RIGHT IN
THE HEART OF A PANDEMIC YOUR
SPENDING NO INCOME DISPOSABLE
INCOME OR TAKING THEIR EDT
CHECK AND THEN HAVING TO BUY
GAS AND FIX THEIR CAR TO GET
AROUND KEEP THEMSELVES ALIVE.
THE TRANSPORTATION IS TRULY A-
JUST LIKE POWER AT A MATTER OF
LIFE AND DEATH FOR MANY PEOPLE
AND I THINK IT UNDERESTIMATES
WHEN WE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT OUR
GOALS AT I. JUST WANT TO. POINT
OUT THAT THIS TRANSPORTATION
EMPHASIS THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE
AND FOCUSING ON CALIFORNIA'S A
MARKET MOVER IS NOT A NEW THING.
HI YOU KNOW BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO THERE IS A BILL
CALLED AB FOURTEEN NINETY THREE
THAT SAID THERE RESOURCES BOARD
SHOULD EXPLORE ALL COST
EFFECTIVE IN TECHNOLOGICALLY
FEASIBLE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
FROM THE AUTOMOTIVE SECTOR. FOR
LIGHT DUTIES PARTICULARLY AND-
NOW WE ARE GOING TO HAVE AN
ELECTRIC F. ONE FIFTY COMING
OUT. THEY CAN PULL LIKE FIFTY
TRAIN CARS OF TORQUE AND- THE-
VERY POLITE TO THE SECTOR IS
GOING TO BE- ACCESSIBLE BY A
WHOLE NEW GENERATION OF MIDDLE
CLASS AMERICANS AND- YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU HAVE A- MONTHLY
VEHICLE BUDGET. SAY TWENTY FIVE
OR THIRTY DOLLARS TO FILL UP
YOUR CAR AND MAINTAINING. FORTY
DOLLARS VERSUS. FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ARE YOU FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE ECONOMICS OF.
HOUSEHOLDS IN THIS STATE SO I
ACTUALLY THINK IT'S A POVERTY
FIGHTING TOOL AND I THINK IT
WILL UNLOCK PEOPLE'S DISPOSABLE
INCOME TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
HEALTH AND THEIR KIDS- AND I. I
REALLY WANT TO KEEP OUR
OURSELVES FOCUSED ON THAT IN
THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR AS WE
LOOK AT THESE AMBITIOUS GOALS.
ANYTHING MY BIGGEST CONCERN
HERE IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ITSELF HAS NOT BEEN AMBITIOUS
ENOUGH. AND THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING WHAT IT
CAN TO MOVE THE PUSH THE
ENVELOPE. AND TO RESPOND WITH.
WITH URGENCY- ON THINGS LIKE
SAID CERTAIN NO ONE TARGETING
CARBON NEUTRALITY IS A LONG
TERM GOAL BUT ALSO UNITE I
DON'T THINK. CARBON NEUTRALITY
IS GOING TO BE ENOUGH. AND I
FRANKLY THINK IT'S- A BIT OF AN
ARBITRARY. GOAL GETTING TO ZERO
SOUNDS GOOD OR YOU KNOW
NEUTRALITY I GUESS SORT OF THIS
TAKEN HOLD BUT IF YOU. IF THE-TRUE GOAL IS TO REVERSE THESE
TRENDS AND TRY TO KEEP THESE
FOREST FROM BURNING AS- A
CENTER DOLLY SO. APTLY POINTED
OUT AND YOU KNOW IN OUR MY
COMMUNITIES BURNED TO AN- ARE
WE LOST A LOT OURSELVES. BUT IF
WE CAN ACTUALLY REVERSE OUR
HISTORIC TRENDS. AND GET TO A
PLACE OF CLIMATE RESTORATION.
FORGET NEUTRALITY BUT ACTUALLY
GET TO NEGATIVE EMISSIONS AND
START REMOVING CARBON DIOXIDE
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO CATCH UP
IT'S GOING TO BE TOO LATE. NO
STATE'S GOING TO BE ON FIRE
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING. SO
I YOU KNOW. I DO WANT TO SORT
OF POINT OUT THAT. THE DANGER
IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR IS
TO. IS TO JUST SPEND TIME SORT
OF. LOOKING FOR HOLES IN
CRITICIZING BUT NOT TO TAKE BIG
LEAPS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE. THE
SET IS THE MINISTRATIONS TARGET
ON A FURTHER HORIZON AND IF
THIS BY ADMINISTRATION IS
ACTUALLY GONNA OUTPACE
CALIFORNIA. IN TERMS OF SETTING
ITS ITS TARGETS AND AMBITIONS-
WE'VE GOT SOME CATCHING UP TO
DO EUROPE IS IT 55% BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS. BY
TWENTY THIRTY WE'RE ONLY A 40%
OUR GOALS ARE MUCH LESS THAN
THE U. K. AND MANY OTHER.
NATIONS ARE ACTUALLY WITH
SMALLER SMALLER AGGREGATE
ECONOMIES IN OURS PERHAPS- BUT
BUT COLLECTIVELY THE E. U. FOUR
DOOR SARS- SO I'M I'M CONCERNED
THAT THE PLANNING EXERCISE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW FRANKLY IS
NOT AMBITIOUS ENOUGH AND THAT
THE MODELING EFFORTS. UNDER WAY
THEY WILL DRIVE THIS SCOPING
PLAN. ARE GOING TO SORT OF
SHOOT FOR. I YOU KNOW THESE
THESE THESE NUMBERS WE'VE
CHOSEN AND LORET EXECUTIVE
ORDER BUT NOT PURSUE ALL COST
EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGICALLY
FEASIBLE GOALS- SOME WONDERING
IF EITHER L. A. O. OR AND MAYBE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION CAN CAN
COMMENT ON. HOW HOW MUCH WE'RE
POTENTIALLY LEAVING ON THE
TABLE RIGHT NOW- IF WE DON'T
PLAN BIG IF WE IF WE SORT OF
INCREMENTALLY INVEST FOR
INSTANCE RIGHT NOW- AND ANY
SORT OF JUST PLAN FOR THAT
FORTY PERCENT. BUT DON'T GO
BEYOND IT- IS THERE A RISK THAT
WE LEAVE A NUMBER OF COST
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS- ON THE
TABLE TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR MAY
ALREADY FIND TO BE COST
EFFECTIVE BUT WE'RE NOT
PURSUING THEM. WHO'D LIKE TO
TAKE THE FIRST CRACK AT THAT
I'M I'M REMINDED OF- THE END OF
PROFESSOR CALLING WERE WORDS
BOOK THAT SAID YOU KNOW DEEP
CARBONIZATION MUST BE EARNED
THE OLD FASHIONED WAY. THROUGH
INDUSTRIAL POLICY INVESTMENT
EXPERIMENTATION AND SCALING OUR-
THUNDERSTORM RAISES A GOOD
POINT POINT ABOUT AMBITION AND
THIS THE CRITIQUE THAT SOME
PEOPLE DON'T THINK WE'LL GET TO
MAKE THE FORTY PERCENT. FIFTY A
TARGET THAT WE HAVE THAT'S
THAT'S LESS THAN EUROPEANS.
LET'S SEE. WHO'S WAVING THEIR
HAND- MR SHARE THIS IS ROSS
FROM LA I CAN KIND OF TAKE A
STEP AND I RESPONDED TO SOME OF
THOSE COMMENTS THAT'S OKAY WITH
YOU- YEAH I MEAN I THINK YOU
KNOW. A LOT OF THE COMMENTS HE
MADE SENATOR STERN REALLY SORT
OF RELATE TO YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOAL AND SORT OF
WHAT WHAT TYPES OF AMBITIONS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS FOR SORT OF
ITS LONG TERM CLIMATE GOALS WE
HAVE THAT AS YOU MENTIONED THAT
TWENTY THIRTY. GOAL IN
STATUTES- I THINK THERE ARE
KIND OF IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
ABOUT YOU KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT
DOES THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
KIND OF THOSE LONGER TERM GOALS
AND HOW AMBITIOUS DOESN'T WANT
TO BE OUT OF TWENTY THIRTY BUT
ALSO SORT OF BEYOND THAT. AND
DEPENDING ON KIND OF WHERE YOU
STAND ON I'M KIND OF THAT LEVEL
OF AMBITION. IT CAN MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE AND SORT OF WHAT
TYPES OF POLICIES YOU MIGHT.
WANT TO ADOPT IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS SO. YOUNG
MID TERM TARGET YOU KNOW MIGHT-
UP TO TWENTY THIRTY- YOU MIGHT
KIND OF LOOK AT A CERTAIN SET
OF POLICIES TO TRY TO ACHIEVE
THAT YOU KNOW 40% REDUCTION UP
TO TWENTY THIRTY. BUT IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT REALLY A MORE
AMBITIOUS LONG TERM GOALS IN
PARTICULAR. YOU MIGHT THINK
ABOUT KIND OF A DIFFERENT
STRATEGY FOR ACHIEVING THOSE
LONG TERM GOALS AND NOT
NECESSARILY SORT OF THE SAME
SET OF ALL SEASON STRATEGIES OR
CAN WE DO NOT NEED. A LONG TERM
GOAL. I APOLOGIZE IF YOU'RE
HEARING SOME. NOISE OUTSIDE. MY
WINDOW. I THINK I JUST HAD A
LOAD TRUCK MISTER. SO I YOU
KNOW. YOU GET TO HAVE A- I
DON'T KNOW LEAVE BLOWER YEAH.
SO- I'M SORRY I YOUR POINT IS
RIGHT ON BUT I MEAN IT YOU KNOW
IN THE END THEY'RE SORT OF THE
THERE'S A- A DIFFICULT
BALANCING ACT I KNOW THAT
YOU'LL YOU'LL HAVE TO KIND OF
WRESTLE WITH THEM TRYING TO
KIND OF. SORT OUT BOTH THE AND
THE AMBITION BUT ALSO SORT OF
THE COST OF MEETING THOSE
GOALS- ANSWER THE MIX OF
POLICIES THAT ARE- KIND OF-
BEST ABLE TO MEET THOSE GOALS
IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY I GUESS
ONE OTHER THING. I DO WANT TO
MENTION AND I THINK YOU KIND
OF. TOUCHED ON THIS- AS WELL IS
I GUESS WHEN THINKING ABOUT THE
MIX OF POLICIES AND KIND OF
WHERE THE STATE WANTS TO GO AND
HOW AMBITIOUS IT WANTS TO BE.
IN ITS LEADERSHIP ROLE THINKING
ABOUT WHICH POLICIES DO KIND OF
HAVE THAT THE BIGGEST IMPACTS
AND KIND OF. YOU KNOW WHAT WILL
BE ADOPTED OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT TECHNOLOGIES
MIGHT CALIFORNIA BE ABLE TO
PUSH THAT ARE LIKELY TO BE
ADOPTED IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AND HAVE THAT KIND OF. A
BIGGER- IMPACT AND INFLUENCE
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA- IT COULD
BE SORT OF IN AND OUT POLICY
DEMONSTRATION CONTACTS MAYBE
CALIFORNIA CAN SORT OF
DEMONSTRATE HOW TO. IMPLEMENT
CERTAIN POLICIES OR KIND OF YOU
KNOW HOW TO DESIGN CERTAIN
POLICIES IN A WAY THAT THAN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS CAN LEARN
FROM- WE THINK THOSE ARE KIND
OF VERY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS AND THINKING
ABOUT. HOW CAN CALIFORNIA
HOUSE- HAVE THE GREATEST
IMPACTS AND KIND OF YOU KNOW
THAT IN THE CLIMATE CHANGE
WORLD AT LEAST. THINKING ABOUT
KIND OF SOME OF THOSE BIGGER
PICTURE QUESTIONS AND WORKING
KIND OF CALIFORNIA DEMONSTRATE
OTHER JURISDICTIONS OR SORT OF
INFLUENCE WHAT OTHER
JURISDICTIONS ARE GOING SO.
THOSE ARE- I THINK MY SORT OF
INITIAL COMMENTS BUT THE OTHERS
ARE YOUR. COMMENTS ARE ARE. OR
SORT OF VERY CRITICAL KIND OF
THE- BIG PICTURE BY. ABOUT THE
STATE'S GOING. HAPPY TO- CAN TO
THE CONVERSATION AROUND. D. THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR STAFF REPORT
TALKS ABOUT THIS. MOMENT IN
TIME WE HAVE A NEW CHAIR AT
SAID. OPPORTUNE MOMENT TO DO
THE SECRETARY BLUMENFELD YOU
HAD YOUR HAND UP. THANK YOU
CHAD- I WOULD JUST SAY. AS TO
MAINLY TO SENATOR STAND I WAS
OUT WITH THE GOVERNMENT- AND AS
SIGNATURE NATURAL RESOURCES ON
THE DAY AFTER THE ORANGE KIND
OF APOCALYPTIC SKY- BLANKETED
MUCH OF THE BAY AREA AND HE
SAID. THAT SAME CONCERN ABOUT
AMBITION- AND BASICALLY SAID.
WE NEED TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT
EVERY SINGLE POLICY AND
UNDERSTAND CAN WE ACCELERATE
IT- HALF HOW AN WE DO THAT AND
SECONDLY WHAT AREAS ARE WE NOT
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT THAT WE
NEED TO CITING. I'M FROM THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THAT BOND
TO DECLINE IS SHED IN ADDITION
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SB ONE
HUNDRED GOAL. THAT THE BY THE
DEMONISATION PUT OUT ITS TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE HOUSES TWENTY FORTY
FIVE- WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT WE'RE DOING HOW WE'RE
DOING AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO
ACHIEVE THAT- IN IN EVERY
SINGLE SECTOR- YOU KNOW WE
GOTTA HAVE PLACE I THINK WHERE.
WE HAD MORE THAN A HUNDRED
LAWSUITS AGAINST THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WE ARE MY
HEADSPACE CERTAINLY HAS HAD TO
CHANGE IN THE LAST MONTH FROM A
PLACE WHERE IT'S VERY
DEFENSIVE. AND WE'RE REALLY-
DEALING WITH ENORMOUS HEADWINDS
TO WE GOT TAILWINDS NOW LIKE
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO HOW WE
GONNA DO IT HOW WE CAN I THINK
ABOUT IT DIFFERENTLY- BECAUSE
THE SIZE IS ALSO AS AS DANNY
AND OTHERS WE'RE GONNA AND
LIANG CAN CAN. ATTEST THIS IS
YOUR SHOWING THE IMMEDIACY OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IT RIGHT WE
REALLY AT. I THINK THE
WILDFIRES- THE FLIP SIDE THAT
SIDE OF THE WILDFIRES IS A LOT
OF IT WAS CALLED BY DROUGHT.
I'M AND DEAD TREES- FROM
BEATLES NOW THE INFESTATIONS
THAT WERE CRIME RELATED WE YOU
KNOW BOTH THE WILD FIRS
THEMSELVES BUT WHY THAT BECAUSE
I'M ON THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WE GET INTO THE SEA
LEVEL RISE FLOODING ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS- YEAH WAY I'M VERY
WORRIED ABOUT US MOVING INTO
THE DROUGHT AND DRY WEATHER
CONDITIONS THIS SUMMER. SO DID
THE ALL OF THE ABOVE POLICY
WHETHER IT'S WATER RESILIENCY
PORTFOLIO ALL OTHER THINGS I'M
I'M A 100% ON BOARD REVIEWS AND
THAT THE STAND WE NEED WE NEED
TO LOOK UNDER EVERY ROCK-
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
HOW WE CAN ACHIEVE IT BECAUSE
FRANKLY OF CALIFORNIA'S NOT
DOING IT. OTHER PLACES AROUND
THE WORLD ALL IN STATE WE CAN
WAIT THIS WELLS THAT WE THAT
LEAD. ROLE WE NEED TO PLAY AN I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE- AND THE ENTIRE LED. TO GET
THAT DONE. FIVE YES. VERY QUICK
RAISE AN EXAM- OF THIS APPROACH
IS IN THE- SB ONE HOW RIVER
THAT THE- AT PC ENERGY
COMMISSION AND CARBS- WORKED ON
ALL LAST YEAR IT WILL BE
TRANSMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
SHORTLY- WHERE WE DID THE- PART
OF THE ANALYSIS WAS TAKING A
LOOK AT- IF WE WERE TO MOVE
BEYOND THE SPECIFIC STATUTORY
GOAL IN SB ONE HUNDRED AND WHAT
MIGHT SOME DIFFERENT SCENARIOS-
FOR ELECTRICITY SALES- THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO LOOK AT AND-
AND WHAT THE VARIOUS- AND-
IMPACTS OF. OF MOVING BEYOND
JUST THE STATUTORY MANDATE
WOULD BE SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE
WHERE WE DID TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- RIGHT OUT SOME
SCENARIOS BEYOND THE LEGAL
LANGUAGE OF THE STATUTE. OKAY
LET'S CONTINUE OUR AMBITIONS.
US SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
TO THE PANEL IS PRESENT TODAY I
JUST LIKE TO VERY QUICKLY GET
TO THE G. G. R. A FORMULA SO IS
WE KNOW 60% OF THAT FORMULA IS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED 40%
THEN IT IS SPENT FOR OTHER
INVESTMENTS RELATED TO CLIMATE-
WHICH MEANS THERE ARE.
SIGNIFICANT OTHER NEEDS FOR
ADAPTED POLICY INITIATIVES. IN
INVESTMENTS LIKE MILES WHAT
LIKE WILDFIRE MITIGATION THAT'S
BEING CROWDED OUT IN A COUPLE
OF STATISTICS. SO WHEN IT CMES
TO THE ISSUE OF WILDFIRES IN
TWENTY TWENTY. MORE CARBON- WAS
GENERATED FROM WILDFIRES IN ANY
OTHER ECONOMIC SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TWENTY.
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION HUNDRED
TWELVE MILLION METRIC TONS IT'S
A COLLECT ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
MILLION CAR. IN WHAT WE ALSO
KNOW AS FIVE OF THE SIX LARGEST
WILDFIRES IN OUR HISTORY
HAPPENED LAST YEAR LARGEST
WILDFIRES IN OUR HISTORY OF ALL
TAKING PLACE IN THE LAST DECADE.
IN THE CHALLENGE THAT WE SEE TO
IT ESPECIALLY WITH CONNOR FOR
FORESTS WHICH ARE SOME OF OUR
BEST THINKS. IT WILL TAKE
NEARLY A CENTURY TO BE ABLE TO
RE GROW TO THEIR FULL MATURITY.
I IN THE CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
FACED WITH NOW WITH WHILE THEM
FIRE IS THAT THIS STATE PROUDLY
IS DOING MORE TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE. THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THIS UNION. BUT THESE WILDFIRES
NOW ARE SETTING OUR AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE WORK BACK HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE FULL STOP. SO WE
HAVEN'T EVEN GONE INTO THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF WILDFIRE
SMOKE IN HOW IT'S IMPACTING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND THIS PAST YEAR
IT WAS LITERALLY WEEKS AT A
TIME WEEKS AT A TIME NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO THE G. G. R. F.
IS UNSTABLE. IT'S AN UNSTABLE
FUNDING SOURCE- DUE TO ITS
DESIGN NOW THE CHAIR OF THIS
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY
CASKEY HAS BEEN VERY FOCUSED-
INTONATIONS ARE WANTING BETTER
BRING STABILITY. TO THE FORMULA
BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO COME
TOGETHER TO GET TO DO THAT THIS
YEAR. CANDIDLY FOR US NOT TO
COMMIT THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE
WILDFIRE SMOKE INTO ACCOUNT I
BELIEVE IS A DERELICTION OF
DUTY- AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE A
TO SEE THE SECRETARY'S STRATEGY
THE ADMINISTRATION STRATEGY. TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE G. G. R.
F. ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT NOW TO BE A MITIGATE
WILDFIRES IN MR SECRETARY
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK SIR
TRULY. YOU OF THAT COMING IN A
VERY CHALLENGING TIME FOR THE
STATE BUT IF YOU CAN JUST GIVE
US SOME LIGHT. IN REGARDS TO
HOW WE CAN MAKE ROOM IN THE G.
R. F. TO HELP MITIGATE
WILDFIRES WOULD WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT MR SECRETARY
FUTURE CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE
FOR HIM TO DEAL WITH THAT THE
FUNDING STABILITY QUESTION
FIRST AND THEN. BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE GOT A GREAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SOME NEW
FEES AND TAXES SOME OTHER IDEAS
OF HOW THE FUND CLIMATE PROGRAM
SECURITIZATIONS THE FORCES OF
MONEY BUT THERE'S A FUNDAMETAL
REFORM ON THE STABILITY OF THIS
FUN. THAT MIGHT- PERFECT. HELP
OUT. SECTOR AS THANK YOU JAZZ
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M- I DON'T
GET TO A OF OURSELVES BECAUSE
WE GOT A PRESENT COMING UP OUT
OF THIS ON THE G. CARE ACT
BUDGET WAS EXPLICITLY DEALS
WITH KIND OF. WHAT FUNDING KIND
OF CURRENTLY GOING AND I AND I
THINK TO THE SENATE IS FINE AND
THAT THE ALLOCATION. WE'VE
REALLY PRIORITIZED- A NUMBER OF
FACTORS. BUT BASICALLY I AM
LOOKING AT EQUITY ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND HEALTH AS THE
THREE ELEMENTS THAT THAT WE
WANT TO PRIORITIZE THIS LIMITED
CHAD STARTED THIS HEARING-
CLEARLY ARTICULATING THAT THOSE
ARE ISSUES THAT YOU GET TO
PROGRAM AND MAKE THE DECISION
ON. WE TRIED THROUGH THE
DISCIPLINE THAT WE HAVE ALL
THIS BUDGET PROCESS TO USE THE
LIMITED FUNDING I'M IN A WAY
THAT MAXIMIZES ACROSS THE
ENTIRE CLIMATE PORTFOLIO WALL
WHAT WE CAN DO THAT WOULD OPEN
TO OBVIOUSLY HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION WITH YOU AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING THAT MAYBE IN
IN THE NEXT SESSION IT IN I'M
I'M ABSOLUTELY FINE WITH THAT
AND I THINK THAT MAKES SENSE
THAT JUST IF YOU DON'T MIND.
JUST MR SECRETARY. YOUR
STRATEGY THE ADMINISTRATION
STRATEGY ON TO BE ABLE TO FREE
UP SOME ADDITIONAL ROOM. A TO
HELP MITIGATE FIRES YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN GET INTO THE FORMULA
INSTABILITY HERE- IN THE NEXT
SECTION OF THIS HEARING BUT IF
YOU DON'T MIND. JUST TALKING TO
US ABOUT YOUR STRATEGY TO BE A
FREE UP SOME FUNDING FOR
WILDFIRE MITIGATION. DOES AND I
THINK THAT IT WAS PRESENTED AT
THIS COMMITTEE ALL. PERHAPS I'M
BETTER NOW THAT I'M DOES IT
BILLION DOLLAR WILDFIRE
PROGRAM- THAT. THAT IS IN FRONT
OF THE LEGISLATURE FROM. THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
NOT. VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT
BUT MOST OF THAT IS ONE TIME
RIGHT. SO THIS IS AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE THIS IS A CRISIS IT'S
BEEN IN THE STATE FOR TEN
YEARS- IT'S GROWING WORSE. SO I
I'M VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID
LAST WEEK BUT A LOT OF IT IS
ONE TIME FUNDING. OKAY PJ THAT
AB. I GUESS THE POINT IS. THE
WHAT WE'VE I THINK GOT IN THE
TRAP OF AND I THINK HE'LL
YOU'LL POINTING OUT IS IF IT'S
A G. JARETH LI. FUNDING PLAY I
MEAN THE GOVERNOR THAT. THIS IN
THIS BUDGET WANTED TO CUT-
GENERAL FUND MONEY AND YET IT
IS ONE TIME MONEY BUT- THE
POINT IS. THERE ISN'T
SUFFICIENT MONEY IN THE IN THE
G. GERAK IN THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND WHICH COMES FROM
CAP AND TRADE. REVENUES TO DO
NEARLY ANY OF THE THINGS THAT
WE NEEDED TO DO THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT- ELECTRIC VEHICLES
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT I'M-
I THINK THE JAIL WAS TALKING
ABOUT. SOME OF THOSE FUNDS IF
YOU LOOK AT WILDFIRE.
PREVENTION THE MONEY JUST
SIMPLY ISN'T THAT SO PART OF
THE QUESTION THAT THAT- THAT I
THINK YOU'RE RAISING IS ABOUT
THEIR CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS
MESSES THE NON CONTINUOUS. I'M
THERE IS ONLY A 40% THAT'S
AVAILABLE- IT'S A REALLY ISN'T
A LOT OF. A LOT OF THERE IS
VERY LITTLE HEADROOM TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE THESE THINGS AROUND I
WE TRY. THE BEST THAT WE CAN
THROUGH A DISCIPLINED APPROACH
TO PRIORITIZE THAT THE G. CARE
ACT FUNDING. I'M WE'LL TALK
ABOUT HOW WE DID THAT BUT IT ON
TO YOUR QUESTION IS THEIR
ABILITY TO FREE UP MORE MONEY
WITHIN THE G. CARE ACT- I THINK
THE ANSWER IS NO. IT YOU KNOW
AND I'LL TURN IT BACK TO MISTER
TERRY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERS ON THAT IN YOUR HONESTY
AND I THINK THAT- LOOK BOTTOM
LINE IS. TWENTY SECONDS
RESEARCHER IS THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS FORMULA ONE TO BE
A TO BRING MORE STABILITY TO
FORMULA AN ADDITIONAL ROOM TO
BE A TACKLE SOME OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT ARE IMPACTING.
BOTH THE CLIMATE AND THE HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE LOOK FOR
TOWARD NEXT TO. A PART OF THE
HEARING ON THE DISCUSSION THANK
YOU. OKAY- I COULD GO FOR OUR-
BUT WE'RE OUT OF TIME- ANYTHING
ANY OF THE PANELISTS. LAST
SPOTS THAT. ONE TO LEAVE THE-
THE- SUBCOMMITTEE WITH- IF NOT
WE'LL GO INTO THE EXPENDITURE
PLAN HANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE JANET VERSIGHT-
IMPORTANT IDEAS WILL CONTINUE.
HI I KNOW I'M A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE. HAVE RESIGNED FROM THE-
ONE THE PALACE I'LL BE TALKING
DIRECTLY WITH THE AIRPORT ABOUT
THE CONCERNS THAT THE RATE OF
RACE ON THE OFFSET PROGRAM AND
IT'S GOING ON BUT WE'VE WE'VE
RUN OUT OF TIME SO WE'LL GET TO
THAT LATER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER- FIFTEEN WHICH IS
THE. VARIOUS PROGRAMS FOR CAP
AND TRADE WE HAVE THE CAL
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD CAL FIRE
AND- SEDIA FAITH. LET'S START
OFF WITH CAL EPA THEN WILL
FOLLOW IT UP BY THE- KELLY-
AND- THE FINANCE DIRECTOR I
BELIEVE WE'RE LOSING SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD. LEAVES ME BAY YOU
SAID JAY YOU GAIN DEPUTY
SECRETARY LAWRENCE CHANGES TO
THE PERSON WHO HAS THE
UNENVIABLE TASK OF KIND OF
BRINGING TOGETHER ALL THESE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS IN THE
BUDGET SO SHE'LL GO THROUGH F.
I'LL STAY HERE AND QUESTION DO
YOU HAVE I LEARNED ALL OF
MYSELF OR ANYONE ELSE CAN ONS
OF BOBBY. I'M NOT. THE YOU SIR
THANK YOU SIR THIRTY SUCH
IMPORTANT MATTERS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS REYES AND
THE RESPECT OF THE PUBLIC IT'S
HERE IN THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT THESE ARE.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUDGET
CONSIDERATION SO GO AHEAD
DEPUTY. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY. AS I MENTIONED MY NAME
IS LAUREN SANCHEZ AND I SERVICE
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE
POLICY AND INTERGOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA EPA.
AS YOU FOR THIS MORNING TWENTY
TWENTY WAS AN UNPRECEDENTED
YEARS OF ACCELERATING CLIMATE
IMPACT IN EVERY CORNER OF OUR
STATE FROM RECORD BREAKING HEAT
TO DEVASTATING WILDFIRES AS
VICE CHAIR DOLLY HAS
HIGHLIGHTED. DESPITE THE
EXTREME CHALLENGES WE FACE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
AND ENFORCE OUR PROGRAMS AIMED
AT PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. WE INSERTED IN
A FOCUS ON EQUITY IN ALL OF OUR
WORK AND ADVANCE STARTING
VICIOUS CLIMBING GOALS WHICH
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THIS
MORNING. GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS
CONTINUED TO PRIORITIZE OUR
CLIMATE ACTION WITH THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. I KEEP HELLER
OF THE PROPOSED CLIMATE BUDGET
IS THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND EXPENDITURES PLAN I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
PLAN TODAY. TO DATE THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM HAS GENERATED
ALMOST THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN AUCTION PROCEEDS TO FUND
CRITICAL INVESTMENT PROGRAMS.
THANKS TO YOUR LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP AND DIRECTION TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. AS ENVISIONED IN
SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE IN AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY DIRECTING
ROJECTS TOWARDS COMMUNITIES IN
NEED IS A KEY OBJECTIVE OF THE
FUND. WE CONTINUE TO SET AN
EXAMPLE FOR OTHER NATIONAL AND
SUBNATIONAL CLIMATE PROGRAMS BY
EMPHASIZING COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. AND EQUITY IN
PROGRAM DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION. NOTABLY OF THE
SIX POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
HAS ALREADY BEEN LEGISLATIVELY
APPROPRIATED AND SPENT ABOUT
55% OF THOSE PROCEEDS HAVE
BENEFITED DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN SO OUR SINGLE
LARGEST ANNUAL INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRIORITY
POPULATIONS TO DATE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EXPENDITURE
PLAN INCLUDES ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION INCLUDING SEVERAL EARLY
ACTIONS FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT ADVANCE THE
STATE'S PRIORITIES OF ONE
EQUITY AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
TO PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THREE DRIVING A GREEN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WHILE
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THE EXPENDITURE PLAN
ALSO ADVANCES THE GOVERNOR'S
RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDERS ON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND NATURAL
WORKING LANDS. THE PLAN
PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM CREATED THROUGH IT AB
SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH REDUCES
EMISSIONS AND COMMUNITIES WITH
DISPROPORTIONATE EXPOSURE TO
AIR POLLUTION THROUGH TARGETED
MONITORING COMMUNITY EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS AND
INCENTIVES GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS. THE BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TWO
HUNDRED THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM. WHICH
IS DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE
SUSTAINABLE OPERATIONS FOR
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AND
ENSURE THAT THE ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO CURRENTLY LACK
SAFE DRINKING WATER RECEIVE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THE OTHER THESE INVESTMENTS
REFLECTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITIZATION OF PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH IN THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THE
PLAN ALSO PROPOSES SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DEDICATED
TO THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND THE MAIN DRIVER
OF HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION. AND
TO SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE GOVERNOR'S IO ON STEPS.
PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN THIS
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE INCLUDES.
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
EQUITY FOCUSED TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS WHICH TOGETHER FIND
FOR EXAMPLE LOW INCOME CAR
SHARING PROGRAMS VANPOOL VAN
POOLS FOR AGRICULTURE WORKERS
AND SCHOOL BUSES IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES. THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE PROGRAMS INCLUDING
INCENTIVES FOR CLEAN TRUCKS
BUSES AND OFF ROAD FREIGHT
EQUIPMENT THE SO CALLED H. FIT
PROGRAM RAN OUT OF FUNDING IN
TWO WEEKS AS AN ILLUSTRATION OF
HIGH DEMAND FOR THESE
INCENTIVES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION FOR THE FARMER PROGRAM
WHICH FUNDS CLEANER ADD
VEHICLES AND ENGINES. THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WHICH RECEIVES
THE BULK OF FARMER FUNDING HAS
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
PENDING APPLICATIONS TODAY.
TURNING OVER OLDER AND HIGHER
POLLUTING VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IS ESSENTIAL TO
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AS
MANY CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO
SUFFER FROM POOR AIR QUALITY IN
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HAVE BORNE THE BURDEN THE
BURDEN OF POLLUTION FOR TOO
LONG. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FURTHER PROPOSES THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE
LEGISLATURES ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND TO
CLEAN UP CONSTRUCTION AND
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT AND
LIGHT AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
ON OUR ROADS. THE OTHER WITH
THE CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
PROGRAMS WHICH INCLUDE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRANSIT PROJECTS
TRANSIT ORIENTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THE TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS RIGHT KEY PILLAR OF
THE TRANSITION TO AN EQUITABLE
SUSTAINABLE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
THE ADMINISTRATIONIS NOT
PROPOSING CHANGES TO OUR
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
PROGRAMS WHICH ACCOUNT 465% AND
FUTURE REFERENCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL ALSO
REFLECTS OUR COMMITMENT TO
BUILDING CLIMATE RESILIENCE
THROUGH OUR NATIONAL WORKING
LANDS AN URGENTPRIORITY AS HAS
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED NUMBER OF
TIMES THIS MORNING FOR THE
NETWORKING LAND SECTOR IS TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE IN OUR FORESTS. TO
PROTECT OUR WET WATERSHEDS AND
WILDLIFE AND RESTORE OR WASTE
VALUABLE ROLE AS A CARBON SINK.
INCLUDED WITHIN THIS PLAN IS
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN INVESTMENTS TOWARDS
SB NINE A ONE TO SUPPORT
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE. AND
SUSTAINABLE FORESTRY INCLUDING
A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
IN EARLY ACTION FUNDING. TO
MAKE HOLD THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR FROM THE
TEACHER ASKED. THIS PROVIDES
VITAL PROGRAM FOR STATE
PROGRAMS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
CONSERVATION GROUPS FOR
PROJECTS. THAT REDUCE FUELS FOR
WILDFIRE REFORESTED DAMAGE
ECOSYSTEMS AND PRESERVE
VULNERABLE LAND. WE'RE JOINED
THIS MORNING BY CHIEF PORTER
AND THE CAL FIRE TEAM FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
PROPOSAL. ANOTHER KEY PILLAR OF
OUR NATURAL WORKING LANDS
EFFORTS IS OUR CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION. TO SUPPORT THEY ARE
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY TOWARDS CLIMATE SMART
I. AS PART OF THAT PACKAGE THE
BUDGET INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CDFA IS HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE GRANTS
FOR ON FARM SOIL MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES I THANK SECRETARY
ROSS WHO IS ALSO WITH US THIS
MORNING FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM. I
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD EXPRESSED
EARLIER WE ARE EAGER TO WORK
WITH OUR NEW FEDERAL PARTNERS
ON OUR COLLECTIVE CLIMATE AND
EQUITY AGENDA. IF I DIDN'T
HARRIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
RECENTLY PROPOSED JUSTICE FORTY
AN INITIATIVE TO SPEND 40% OF
INVESTMENTS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO ADVANCE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. THIS
INITIATIVE BUILDS ON YOUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND
DIRECTION TO PRIORITIZE OUR
INVESTMENTS IN DISADVANTAGED IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. THANKS
FOR YOUR ONGOING SUPPORT IN OUR
TIRELESS EFFORTS ON
ADMINISTRATION WIDE CLIMB
pINVESTMENT PROGRAMS WE HAVE
LESSONS AND STRATEGIES TO SHARE
WITH OUR NEW PARTNERS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
ADVANCE PARTIES OF CLIMATE
EQUITY PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND DRIVING A GREEN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
AND I ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. PERFECT OF MISTER
BROWN WITH THE L. A. L. WILL GO
TO YOU- NEXT COULD YOU
INCLUDING YOUR COMMENTS YEAH
WE'VE WE'VE WE JUST HAD A-
SESSION ON THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND WE KNOW THAT. AB
SIX ONE SEVEN IS A POLLUTION
CONTROL PROBLEMS ARE PROGRAM
VERSUS A DECARBONISATION OR
DEEP DECARBONIZATION PROBLEMS
AND THERE'S TRADE OFFS WITH
TAKING MONEY THAT COULD BE USED
FOR. DECARBONISING AND GIVING
IT TO. EQUITY PROGRAMS ARE NOW
CALL VERSUS- CRITERIA POLLUTANT
PROBLEMS IN AND THE TRADEOFF
THAT WE HAVE WITH THAT. AND
THEN THE SECOND PART PREFERRED
LIKE YOU. TALK TO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE CLEAN TRUCK THE H. FIT
IS OVERSUBSCRIBED WE KNOW THAT
THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL ENGINE
PROGRAM IS OVER SUBSCRIBED BUT
THE- CLEAN CARS FOR ALL OUR
INTEREST IN THE THAT THAT'S
UNDER ITS SUBSCRIBER. THE CVR
PETE HAD BEEN OVER SUBSCRIBED
SO WE'VE GOT MONEY. HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION GOING AT TEN
UNDER SUBSCRIBER PROGRAM IF YOU
COULD TOUCH ON THAT AND WE'LL
GET FOR HER FROM. THE AGENCY
ALSO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
YEAH SO I WILL TRY TO KIND OF
TOUCH ON THOSE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS AS I CAN I MAKE MY
WAY THROUGH OUR COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSED AT CALTRAIN
EXPENDITURE PLAN I DO WANT TO
NOTE- WE HAVE- ANALYSIS OF THE
PLAN UP AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE AT L. A. O. DOT CA DOT
GOV- A LOT OF THAT ANALYSIS IS
ALSO INCLUDED IN YOUR GENDER
TODAY AND SO I'M JUST GONNA TRY
TO. SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE KEY
POINTS FROM THAT- I KNOW
THERE'S KIND OF A LOT OF
NUMBERS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PACKAGING KIND OF DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS- I DO WANT TO KIND OF
HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE. AGAIN
THAT THERE IS BOTH THE CURRENT
YEAR COMPONENT TO THIS PACKAGE
AS WELL AS A BUDGET YOU'RE A
COMPONENT ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION-
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE. MILLION
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- I THINK IT IS- AS
IT IS KIND OF BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
ALREADY- IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS THE DISCRETIONARY
PACKAGES QUITE A BIT LESS THAN
IT HAS BEEN IN PRIOR YEARS AND
THAT'S FOR A COUPLE DIFFERENT
REASONS. ONE JUST LOWER REVENUE
LOWER EXPECTED REVENUE COMING
AND RELATIVE TO A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. AND THEN
SPECIFICALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE DISCRETIONARY PACKAGE AND I
THINK THIS IS WHAT- SENATOR AYE
MCGUIRE WAS ALLUDING TO. THERE
IS A PORTION OF FUNDING WHICH
IS SORT OF MOVED INTO THE
CONTINUOUS OF CORPORATIONS-
CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS NOW
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT. OF THE
ANNUAL REVENUE ANOTHER SIGNAL
FOR OF WHAT DRINKING WATER AS
PART OF THAT SO THAT JUST KIND
OF FURTHER REDUCES THE- AMOUNT
OF MONEY AVAILABLE IN THE
DISCRETIONARY- PORTION OF
FUNDING- AND I WON'T GO THROUGH
ALL THAT ALL THE DIFFERENT- THE
SANCHEZ- TOUCHED ON KIND OF A
LOT OF THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS-
I WON'T GO THROUGH THOSE. AGAIN
JUST TO MAYBE HIGHLIGHT YOU
KNOW THAT THE PROPOSED FUNDING
WOULD WOULD REALLY GOING TO
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE IN THE PAST
COMMONLY RECEIVE G. G. R. S.
BUT THERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS
LIKE CRP WHICH WAS MENTIONED
THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED AND
PRIORITISED IN THIS PACKAGE. SO
I THINK OUR OUR HE COMMENTS ON
THE PACKAGE OVERALL AT A HIGH
LEVEL ARE. ONE WE DO THINK THE
REVENUE ESTIMATES OF THE
MINISTRY ATION IS ASSUMING.
REGION AND REASONABLE- FOR NOW-
BUT OF COURSE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THERE IS A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
AS YOU KNOW AROUND CAP AND
TRADE REVENUE IN A LOT OF.
VOLATILITY IN THE REVENUE
SOURCE THAT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP
IN MIND IF YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT YOUR- OVERALL PACKAGE.
THE SECOND POINT IS- WITH THE
CURRENT REVENUE ESTIMATES ON
THE PROPOSED EXPENDITURES- THE
ESTIMATED FUND BALANCE AT THE
END OF BOTH THE CURRENT YEAR IN
THE BUDGET YEAR- IN OUR VIEW
IS. STILL RATHER IS RELATIVELY
SMALL- ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AT THE END OF
BUDGET YOU'RE WITH HIS PROPOSED
PACKAGE. AND SO WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND
GIVEN THE VOLATILITY OF THE
REVENUE. SOURCE THAT IT'S A
RELATIVELY SMALL FUND BALANCE
SO KEEP THAT IN MIND WHEN KIND
OF THINKING ABOUT THE OVERALL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT YOU'RE-
I'M GOING TO BE ALLOCATING. IN
BOTH THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
YEAR. AND FINALLY ON THE- JUST
ON THE EARLY ACTION COMPONENTS-
WE THINK THAT CERTAIN
COMPONENTS OF THE PACKAGE ARE
MORE JUSTIFIED FOR EARLY ACTION
THAN OTHERS- IN GENERAL THERE
ARE JUST. NO TRADE OFFS WHEN
YOU WERE SPEAKING ABOUT EARLY
ACTION- PACKAGE- YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO GET THE MONEY OUT THE
DOOR A FEW MONTHS EARLIER BY
ADOPTING. SOME CURRENT YEAR
FUNDING BUT THAT- ALSO SORT OF
LIMITS TO KEEP TRADE OFF IS
THAT NOT NOT WHEN THAT SORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO.
DELIBERATE OVER- THOSE PROPOSED
EXPENDITURES AND SO IT- WE
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
STRONG JUSTIFICATION FOR EARLY
ACTION AND- I'M CERTAIN
PROGRAMS WHICH YOU LIKE- HAVE.
A STRONGER JUSTIFICATION AND
OTHERS AND I THINK IN
PARTICULAR THE- A WILDFIRE
FUNDING AND SB NINE OH ONE
FUNDING THIS POST CONSISTENT
WITH- STATUTORY. GUIDANCE IN SB
NINE OH ONE AND WE ALSO THINK
THERE'S- THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE A CASE THAT'S- AND BY
PROVIDING OUTSTANDING EARLY-
SOME OF THOSE FIRE REDUCTION-
PROJECTS- OR FOREST HEALTH
PROJECTS COULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
ARE PRIOR TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO A FIRE SEASON SO THERE'S-
IF. THERE'S ANY OF THOSE THAT
ARE A REASON TO. ACTUALLY.
INCLUDE THAT AS EARLY ACTION.
THERE ARE RECOMMENDED. ARE
FIRST- I CONSIDERED. THE EARLY
OUT PACKED TO AND LESS THAN
DIMINISH. IS AND- THAT WOULD
YOU KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER YOU KNOW INSTEAD
SORT OF PROVIDING A LOT OF THAT
FUNDING AS PART OF ITS OVERALL.
BUDGET YEAR PACKAGE- WITH THE-
EXCEPTION OF- YOU KNOW WHAT. AN
ALTERNATE WOULD REALLY JUST BE
TO FOCUS ON THE WILDFIRE PIECE
OF THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE AND
THEN. THE LASER OF THE
ALLOCATIONS FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER ITEMS- AND SO- UNTIL YOU
YOU DECIDE ON YOUR- BUDGET YOUR
PACKAGE. ANOTHER OPTION IS THE
LEGISLATURE DOES IDENTIFY SOME
REALLY HIGH PRIORITY PROGRAM
SORT OF LIKE TO GET THE MONEY
OUT THE DOOR A FEW MONTHS
EARLIER- LOOKING AT JUST HOW
MUCH MONEY ESSENTIALLY. WE
ALREADY HAVE IN THE BANK FOR
DDR ASK GIVEN THE REVENUE
UNCERTAINTY- EVEN OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF OPTIONS WE THINK KIND
OF FOCUSING ON. WHAT WE KNOW-
WE HAVE AVAILABLE IN TERMS OF
RESOURCES AND- BY OUR
CALCULATIONS THAT'S RIGHT NOW
IT AT ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION SO MAYBE SORT OF
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF SPENDING
IN THE CURRENT YEAR TO. THAT
AMOUNT- IS IT IS A GOOD PLACE
TO START. AND THEN OF COURSE
YOU'LL NEED TO KIND OF. WANT TO
SORT OF REASSESS YOUR RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AFTER WE
HAVE THE RESULTS FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE OPTIONS AS YOU CONSIDER
YOUR- YOUR BUDGET YEAR PACKAGE.
OF ONE KIND OF LONGER TERM
ISSUE WAITED WHILE HIGHLIGHTED
IS- THINKING ABOUT I MENTIONED
THE FUND BALANCE IN THE
RELATIVELY LOW FUND BALANCE-
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IS. ROUGHLY 5% OF KIND OF IN
YOUR ESTIMATED ANNUAL REVENUE.
WOULD YOU THINK THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT KIND
OF. IN THE LONG TERM IN
PARTICULAR IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND GOING FORWARD. THINKING
ABOUT TRYING TO BUILD UP THE
RESERVE FUND THAT'S FINE GIVEN
THE REVENUE VOLATILITY. THAT
COULD KIND OF HELP YOU KNOW
HELP ENSURE LONG TERM FUND
SOLVENCY AS WELL AS MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT MORE. FUNDING
PROJECT ABILITY FOR THE
PROGRAMS GOING FORWARD IF
THERE'S A LARGE RESERVE FUND
THAT COULD KIND OF WHETHER SOME
OF THE- SOME OF THAT-
ACTUATION. RENDON OVERTIME. AND
FINALLY- YOU KNOW WHEN IT COMES
TO ALLOCATE FUNDS. TO PRO- YOU
KNOW THAT'S A THINK A OF
BUSINESS. REALLY DEPEND ON KIND
OF WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES ARE AND
HOW THEY ARE THEY MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES- MR
AT. YEAH SURE MENTIONS SB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND PARTICULAR I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF A- YOU
KNOW ONE GOOD EXAMPLE OF YOU
KNOW THAT PROGRAM IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS- AND YOU KNOW.
ULTIMATELY KIND OF YOU KNOW HOW
YOU PRIORITIZE THAT PROGRAM
COMPARED TO OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
FOCUS MORE ON. GREENHOUSE GASES
OR FORCED HELL OR SATAN
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
REALLY SORT OF COMES DOWN TO
WHAT YUR PRIORITIES ARE. IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW. LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION REDUCTIONS CLIMATE
CHANGE- ACTIONS OTHER TYPES OF
BENEFITS RELATED. TO FORESTRY
IN WILDFIRE AND THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS- AND ONCE YOU HAVE. ONE
OF THOSE RARITIES. AREN'T
RUNNING AROUND- I THINK LAST. I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED MR CHER WAS
ON THE- DIFFERENCE
TRANSPORTATION RELATED PROGRAMS
AND THE MAN FOR THOSE PROGRAMS
AYE YOU'RE RIGHT H. H. THAT WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED ALONG. A LONG
TIME AGO- AND- ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT C. B. R.
P. DOES HAVE SOME MONEY
AVAILABLE STILL TO PROVIDE
FUNDS FOR I THINK THE ESTIMATES
ARE FOR OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS THERE ARE STILL SOME
FUNDING AVAILABLE- PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDES MORE REBATES- BUT
I THINK THINKING ABOUT-
CERTAINLY KIND OF WHAT THE
DEMAND IS FOR THE PROGRAMS AND
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT AND- HISTORICALLY BEEN
OVERSUBSCRIBED THINKING ABOUT
THAT AND TAKING THAT INTO
ACCOUNT AS ONE OF THAT KIND OF
KEY FACTORS THAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT. PRIORITIZING
YOUR LIMITED RESOURCES THAT YOU
HAVE MISTER CHARLES. AND THE
FINAL IT SO I JUST DID WANT TO
CUT TOUCH ON. THE ISSUE. THE
REASON AND IS RETURNING FOR.
IT'S JUST A GENERAL MATTER. WE
DO THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
THINKING ABOUT BOTH OF THOSE
PIECES TOGETHER- ANSWER GOING
TO CONTINUALLY ASSESS YOU KNOW
WHETHER THE CURRENT MIX OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED BOTH
IN THE CONTINUOUS PREPARATIONS
AND DISCRETIONARY. ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES AND SO-
YOU KNOW THINKING ABOUT THOSE
TWO PIECES TOGETHER I KNOW WE
OFTEN FOCUS ON THE
DISCRETIONARY HE'S THINKING
ABOUT- BOTH DISCRETIONARY
CONTINUOUS WE THINK THIS WOULD
WORK TO ENSURE THE MONEY IS
GOING TO HIS LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES SO APOLOGIES IF I
WENT A LITTLE BIT LONGER BUT-
HAPPY TO ANSWER. I'M GOING TO
KEEP A LITTLE BIT LONGER
UNIQUE SITUATION WE HAVE ONE
TIME MONEY YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T
PICK UP THE NEWSPAPER AND HEAR
ABOUT WE'VE GOT EXCESS MONEY IN
THE BUDGET MAYBE MORE EXCESS
MONEY AND IT'S NOT LOST ON
ANYBODY ON THIS PANEL THAT
RESOURCES IS ALWAYS GET LEFT
BEHIND WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
ONE TIME MONEY THEY'RE THEY'RE
WE'RE NOT HAVING FUN SPENT SO
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THAT. YOU
KNOW ONE ON GOOD AS SENATOR
MCGUIRE PUT UP THE ONE TIME FOR
ONE YEAR FUNDING FOR THE
HEALTHY FORESTS OR EVEN THE
CLEAN TRUCK PROGRAMS DIEM DON'T
YOU THINK THAT THOSE ARE COULD
BE GIVEN THE IMPACT THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE. REASONABLE
EXPENDITURES FOR GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME MONEY WITH THE EXCESS
OF FUNDS TO COME UP AND THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. FOR CAP AND
TRADE CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
OTHER LONG TERM PLANS WE HAVE I
MEAN NOT THAT TO GIVE UP ON IT
BUT THAT VALANCE THAT WE SAY
THERE'S MONEY HERE USES ONE
TIME MONEY TO JUMP STARTED THE
TRUCK PROGRAM AND JUMPSTART
THE- THE FORESTS IN A
PRESCRIBED BURN SIDE. THE
VEGETATION WHAT SAY YOU MISTER
BROWN YEAH I MEAN I THINK IT'S
COMPLETELY REASONABLE TO BE
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW NOT JUST
THE G. R. S. BUT ALSO OTHER
FUND SOURCES AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE- WHEN THINKING.
ABOUT YOU KNOW I FUNDING ON A
PROGRAMS OR ANY PRO REALLY- SO
I THINK- YEAH ACROSS OUR OF
NUGENT FUND FOR A- THAT'S A
IT'S A REASONABLE THING TO LOOK
OUT I THINK. YOU'RE THE ONLY-
PERHAPS SORT OF OBVIOUS THING
TO POINT OUT IS YOU KNOW TO THE
EXTENT WHERE USING GENERAL
FUNDS THOSE ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES IS NOT AVAILABLE
FOR- ANY OF THE OTHERS-
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND KIND
OF OTHER THINGS THAT COULD BE
FUNDED BUT- ANSWERED EXTENTS.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE- HIGH
PRIORITY FOR THE USE OF THOSE
ONE TIME FUNDS THAT'S THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER-
AND CONSIDERED IN THE CONTEXT
OF BOTH THE GDR OF PACKAGES
WELL AS I KNOW THEY- EIGHTY
EIGHT EXTENSION WAS MENTIONED
BUT JUST SORT OF THE BROADER
SUITE. OF ON THE POLICIES AND
FUNDING SOURCES AS IT'S TRYING
TO PIECE TOGETHER ITS PACKAGE
AND- THE FUNDING OF PROVIDES
FOR- IT'S GOING TO PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU AND ONE OTHER THING
YOU HAVE INSTRUCTED THEIR
FEISTY THIS COMMITTEE AND THAT
THE- SENATE IN GENERAL ABOUT.
TARGETING SOME MARKET FAILURES
IN THE IN THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAMS TO LOOK AT. PILOT
PROGRAMS AND DEMONSTRATION
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN PUT IN
THAT SCIENCE ESEARCH THAT WERE
THAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS NOT
GOING. TO TAKE CARE OF THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO. THE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO THIS
PROPOSAL HAS NONE OF THAT YET-
HOW CAN YOU GIVE US SOME
CONTEXT OF WHAT WHAT THE
IMPORTANCE IS TO MAKING THESE
INVESTMENTS IN THESE PILOT
PROGRAMS. SO THAT WE THAT NEXT
GENERATION OF TECHNOLOGIES DONE
THAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS NOT.
COULD HAVE ALWAYS INVESTED THEM.
YES I THINK OUR COMMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND THIS
ITEM AS YOU MENTIONED ARE KIND
OF. REALLY AND THE VAN OF YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THE- THE MOST
APPROPRIATE ROLE FOR
GOVERNMENTS AND KIND OF SOME OF
THESE CHANGES AND AN EMISSION
REDUCTION ACTIVITIES SENDS. WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT CAP AND
TRADE IN CARBON PRICING TO SORT
OF TRY TO ADDRESS YOU KNOW SOME
OF THAT THE EXTERNALITIES
ESSENTIALLY ASSOCIATED WITH-
WITH CARBON EMISSIONS BUT- THAT
DOESN'T. NECESSARILY GET YOU
ALL THE WAY THERE AND THERE ARE
I THINK SORT OF STRONG.
RATIONALES FOR SOME GOVERNMENT
SUPPORT FOR- RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES- PILOTS
AND DEMONSTRATIONS FOR. EARLY
STAGE TECHNOLOGIES TO. THE YOU
KNOW PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE DEGREE TO WHICH THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES WORK AND KIND OF
HELP THAT. THE MARKET FOR THOSE
TYPES OF. ACTIVITIES AND SO WE
DO THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE
PLACE TO THINK ABOUT IF YOU
CAN'T HAVE LIMITED FUNDS. HOW
TO SORT OF FILL GAPS OR KIND OF
YOU KNOW HOW TO- FUND
ACTIVITIES WHERE THERE'S A
STRONG SORT OF RATIONALE FOR
SOME SORT OF GOVERNMENT. OUR
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT FOR THOSE
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS- IT IT IT I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE FUNDING
COULD GO TO. SOME PILOT AND
DEMONSTRATION ACTIVITIES BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT FOR THEM- AND
THERE MIGHT BE I THINK- EVEN IN
THE AGRICULTURAL AREA OTHERS I
THINK. POTENTIAL FOR SOME-
PILOTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS BUT-
OVERALL A LOT OF THE MONEY I
THINK IT'S GOING TO KIND OF.
MORE DEPLOYMENT- INCENTIVES ON
A LOT OF CASES AND SO THAT'S
JUST THAT'S ONE KIND OF
IMPORTANT THING THE LEGISLATURE
THINK LAUGHTER. AFTER WAY AND A
PARTLY GETS BACK AT SORT OF THE
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION WE HAD
AROUND SORT OF NEAR TERM
VERSUS. LONG TERM GOALS THOSE
THOSE PILOTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS
AND SUPPORT FOR THOSE- KIND OF
EARLY STAGE TECHNOLOGIES AND
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS-
HAVE MORE OF A KIND OF LONG
TERM FOCUS WEARING IT I THINK
THE HOPE IS THAT OVER TIME SOME
OF THOSE TECHNOLOGIES WILL BE-
THE COSTS WILL COME DOWN IN
THAT THEY- THEY WILL BE
pTHE OF THE LONGER TERM GOALS.
BUT THAT'S SORT OF THAT I THINK
THE TENSION THAT YOU YOUR FACE
AND OF HOW TO. AND TRYING TO OF
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. ALLOCATE
YOUR FUNDS ACROSS DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS IS PARTLY THAT THAT
SORT OF SHORT TERM VERSUS LONG
TERM FOCUS. AND THERE'S WHERE
THE FUN BEGINS- ALL RIGHT.
LET'S MOVE THE FINANCER YOU GET
A LITTLE FLAVOR AND WITH. WHAT
THE- CHAIRS THINKING ABOUT WHAT
DO YOU HAVE ON THIS EXPENDITURE
PROGRAM AND THE- AND THE-
POINTS HAVE BEEN RAISED SO FAR.
HI YES THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ADDITIONAL TO ADD AT
THIS TIME BUT ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
YOU MIGHT HAVE. WE'RE LIMITED
WITH TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S GO TO A- DIRECTOR PORTER
WITH CAL FIRE- AND ANGELA LOTS
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN THIS WEEK
YOU HAVE A- THE ITEMS ON THE-
THE NATURAL WORKING LANDS. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING SHARE AND
ECONOMIC CAMERA WORKING THIS
THIS MORNING- AND MEMBERS ALSO
THANK YOU SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
AND EPA FOR PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
TOPIC. AGAIN MY NAME IS TOM
PORTER CAL FIGHTER- DIRECTOR
AND STATE FORESTER- CAL FIRES
FORCED HEALTH AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS INVEST GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS. IN PROJECTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND THESE
PROJECTS- REDUCE UNCONTROLLED
WILDFIRE EMISSIONS AND INCREASE.
CARBON ABSORPTION- WHICH DOES
IN THOSE HEALTHY FORESTS THAT
WE PRODUCE. ENCHILADAS HIS
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ENERGY CLIMATE AND ENERGY FOR
CAL FIRE AND SHE WILL- FINISH
THIS OPENING. THE MORNING
EVERYONE I THINK YOU DIRECTOR
PORTER GOOD MORNING SENATORS I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK- AS EARLIER STATED THE
CALVET COMPONENT OF THIS
FUNDING CONTINUES- AT THE
GOVERNOR COMPONENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL CONTINUES AT THE
FUNDING THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BY
YOU ALL AND SB NINE A ONE. THE
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION OF PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE ADMINISTERED BY RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT IN THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL HERE AT CAL
FIRE AND- FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FUELS CREWS- WHICH-
HELP US ACHIEVE THIS FUELS
REDUCTION REFORESTATION AND
OTHER LAND MANAGEMENT WORK. WE
ARE EXCITED TO GET GOING WITH
OUR PROGRAMMING FOR THIS YEAR
HAS BEEN ON HOLD OF COURSE
SINCE THIS PAST SUMMER AND FALL
OUTWE HAVE PARTNERS ARE READY
AND WAITING TO GET THE FUNDS
INTO ON THE GROUND PROJECTS AND
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO GET THEM
GOING THAT WE CAN BE READY FOR
THE NEXT ROUND OF FUNDING
COMING UP NEXT YEAR. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF OUR FUNDING FOR THIS YEAR
AND ALSO JUST LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE EXTENSION OF
THIS FUNDING BOUGHT THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION- WHICH WAS SET
TO EXPIRE IN TWO OF HIS CLEAR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AT THE
EXTENSION WHICH IS NOW
CONTINUES THAT BLOCK THROUGH
TWENTY THIRTY. THE END OF THE
CURRENT AND OF THE COVENTRY
PROGRAMMING- IT JUST BRINGS
GREAT STABILITY TO OUR
PROGRAMMING AND ALSO TO OUR
PARTNERS AND HOW WE CAN CONDUCT
OUR OPERATIONS FROM YEAR TO
YEAR SIR REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT'S PROPOSAL AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. OF THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THE YOU ALL ALL
COUPLE BACK IN A SECOND LET I
REALIZE I'M TRYING TO MANAGE
THE TIME HERE. LET'S MOVE TO-
SECRETARY ROSS- AT THE MORNING
STAFF AND MEMBERS RIGHT THREE
H. AS YOU KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING THE WORKING LANDS IN
THE HEALTHY SOILS AND THIS THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS. USES THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE
VERSUS THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR FIGURE FOR EARLY ACTION
AND I'M AND I KNOW YOU SPEAK
FOR THE MINISTRY HERE THANKFUL
FOR THE FIFTEEN MILLION- BUT
JUST SO THE PUBLIC KNOWS IS
WHAT WHAT WE HEAR THIS
COMMITTEE ARE TALKING IN THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN HALF
FOR THE LAST. THREE YEARS SO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD PRESENT. SURE
I'M JUST VERY BRIEFLY I DID
WANT TO TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF
POINTS AROUND THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM- WE ARE CURRENTLY OVER
SUBSCRIBED BY 2100% WHICH IS A
GOOD THING. I THINK THAT'S
BECAUSE OF THE FORMULA THAT WE
USE TO FUND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE SMALLEST FARMERS ARE
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS.
AND FARMERS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES KNOW ABOUT OUR
PROGRAMS AND HAVE THAT
TECHNICAL SUPPORT FROM FIVE
FOUR PROGRAMS. IT'S ALSO BEEN
PROVIDED THE INCENTIVE GRANTS.
AS WELL AS FOR THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS. WE NEED
TO SCALE UP ALL OF THESE
HEALTHY CELLS PRACTICES. IN THE
STATE IS LARGEST CALIFORNIA
WITH THE DIVERSITY OF
AGRICULTURE THAT WE HAVE. BUT
THERE IS THE CROP PATTERNS. OR
THE MICRO CLIMATES IN WHICH
PEOPLE ARE FARMING OR THE SIZE
OF THEIR FARMS THESE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS I THINK
HAVE REALLY HELPED US. CREATE A
PLATFORM FOR MORE FARMERS TO
SEE WHAT'S POSSIBLE AND TO
ADOPT THOSE PRACTICES
THEMSELVES. A NUMBER OF THOSE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS HAVE
ALSO COLLECTED DATA SO THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE REAL TIME
INFORMATION TO FARMERS ABOUT
WITH THE ECONOMICS ARE WHAT THE
TRADE OFFS ARE WITH THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS YEAH.
I'M TO DATE. WE HAVE FUNDED
APPROXIMATELY FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS TO A TOTAL OF
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
PROJECTS THAT'S A COMBINATION
OF FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
INDIVIDUAL FARMER INCENTIVE
GRANTS. AS WELL AS SIXTY SIX
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS. THAT
COVER OVER FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
ACRES. S. A. KUESTER CO TWO
EQUIVALENT OF A HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND METRIC TONS- AS WE
HAVE EVOLVED THIS PROGRAM IN A
FAIRLY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. WE
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ALIGNED
WITH THE USDA NATURAL RESOURCES
CONSERVATION. SERVICE THE
STANDARD PRACTICES. SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S FAMILIAR. AND
AS EVIDENCE BASED SCIENCE BASED
PRACTICES. AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL PRACTICES
AS TO GET THE DATA TO DO SO.
THE MOST RECENT ONE HAS BEEN
THIS PAST YEAR THE INCLUSION.
OF WHOLE ORCHARD RECYCLING. FOR
THOSE FOR- NEED TO BE TAKEN OUT.
AUTOMATICALLY IF A WAY OF COME
IN AND PULLING OUT THE WHOLE
TREE MULCHING AT AND THEN
IMMEDIATELY INCORPORATING THAT
INTO THE SOIL TO SEQUESTER
CARBON. HUGE POTENTIAL TO GROW
THAT PROGRAM ESPECIALLY AS WE
DEAL WITH POTENTIAL PHASE OUT
IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
AFTERBURNING. THE OTHER ONE I
WANTED TO TOUCH ON AMONGST THE
MANY HEALTH BENEFITS WE GET
FROM HEALTHY SOILS. IS A
POLLINATOR HABITAT WE HAVE
SINCE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF OUR
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM GIVEN
EXTRA POINTS TO THOSE PROJECTS
FOR HEDGE ROWS IN COVER CROPS.
THAT ARE VERY FRIENDLY FOR BEES
MONARCH BUTTERFLIES AND OTHER
POLLINATORS. OF AND WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. I
WOULD POINT THAT. OTHERS
INCLUDED IN EARLY ACTION ALLOWS
US TO KEEP THE MOMENTUM THAT WE
HAVE GOING. AND REALLY HELPS
OUR FARMERS IN PLANNING THE
SOONER THEY KNOW THAT DOLLARS
MAY BE AVAILABLE IT WILL HELP
THEM IN SOME OF THEIR PLAN TO
DECISIONS GOING FORWARD. YEAH
THANK YOU I NOTICED THAT YOU
KNOW IN THE SMART AGRICULTURE
VERSUS THE DIMERIC OR CULTURAL.
CLIMATE PROGRAMS WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY WE'VE GIVEN MONEY
FOR METHANE REDUCTION
HISTORICALLY YOU FOR PUT THE
ENERGY DEPARTMENT ON INCENTIVES
FOR FOOD PROCESSORS AND YOU'VE
ALSO WORKED WITH THE ENERGY
DEPARTMENT. FOR AGRICULTURE
RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT DAY YEAH
THE MICROGRID TO NAY THAT THE
ACT E. D. HOW ABOUT THE PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT. YOU GOT
THERE'S NOTHING IN THAT BUDGET
UNDER- FOR. SMART ACADEMICS
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE CAN
YOU HELP US OUT. SURE I'M- A
MUCH OF THAT TECHNOLOGY HAS NOW
BEEN PROVEN AND SO IT IS LISTED
AS WHAT WOULD QUALIFY UNDER THE
CLIMATE. CATALYST FUND FOR
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE THE
BUDGET PROPOSES FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO FIND EXACTLY THOSE
KINDS OF TECHNOLOGIES. IS THE
DIFFERENCE OF PROVING THAT CAN
WORK AND PRACTICAL EVERYDAY
SITUATIONS AND THEN HOW DO YOU
SCALE THAT UP AND GO THROUGH
THE COMMERCIALIZATION TO
BROADEN MAP ANDSO- LOW
INTEREST LOANS AND LOAN
GUARANTEES CAN BE VERY HELPFUL.
AND CONTINUING TO SCALE UP ITS
TECHNOLOGIES. FOR THOSE THREE
PROGRAMS HAD LIKE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TWO YEARS
AGO RIGHT SO ALL THAT'S GOING
TO COMPETE WITH ALL THE OTHER-
A PROGRAMS OKAY. HI IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE NO ONE I TALK ABOUT
DECARBONIZATION ONCE AGAIN IT
ALL I'M NOT I'M NOT LEAVING THE
BAND HERE WHAT THE DIFFERENT
TACK GESTURES BUT THE MONEY
THAT GOES IN THERE AND THE
METHANE REDUCTION AND THE DEEP
CARBONIZATION THAT IS. THAT IS
TRANSFERABLE I MEAN IF THE
TECHNOLOGY IS AS YOU SAY READY
TO GO. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
LIKE TO EXPORT TO THE
ARGENTINES AND THE OTHER CATTLE
PRODUCING PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
WORLD THE SAKE HERE'S RENT SOME
ENERGY OFF IT IS RUN SOME FUEL
OFFER THIS IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S
A- KEY ROLE FOR CALIFORNIA WITH
THE- AMOUNT OF. THE IMPORTANCE
OF AGRICULTURE FOR WE THAT'S TO
BE A LEADER IN THESE. AREAS
ACKERMAN. IF IT'S READY TO GO
IT'S READY TO GO IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE ZERO MIGHT BE. IT MIGHT BE
PREMATURE BUT WILL I'M SURE MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES WILL HAVE A
QUESTIONS. ON THAT. OKAY FROM
ALL RIGHT THAT'S IT WE'RE AT
WORK FOR THE QUESTION CENTER
DAHLE EAGLE FIRST. THANK YOU TO
SHARE SO I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
SECRETARY AG- ARE YOU FAMILIAR
WITH THE EQUIPO GRAHAM THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- USES TO.
INITIATE A PROJECT FOR. WATER
EFFICIENCIES HEALTHY SOILS I
JUST BECAUSE MY THOUGHT IS THAT
YOU KNOW FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS. LIKE YOU KNOW A DROP IN THE
OCEAN IN CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
AND I WAS THINKING ALONG THE
LINES OF SOMEBODY WHO IS VERY-
CONSCIOUS ABOUT MAKING SURE MY
SOILS ARE OUR- HEALTHY AND-
I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THE
BIO CHAR AREA IN. THE LIKES AND
YOU MENTIONED ABOUT USING- YOU
KNOW. THREE CROSSES RESIDUE TO
BUILD YOUR SOIL WHAT ABOUT
DOING MAYBE- LIKE A 75% GRANT
TO THE FARMER IN THE IN THE IN
THE PHARMACY PUT IN 25% OR
FIFTY WE GET MORE ACRES TREATED
WE GET MARK- BANKS. FOR THE
BUCK IN THE CARBON SIDE OF IT
IN HEALTHY SOILS AS ARE MANY
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT. YES THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR
AND I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS AVAILABLE ON WHAT THE
MATCH HAS BEEN FROM OUR FARMERS
HISTORICALLY- WHETHER IT'S IN
THE METHANE REDUCTIONS OR
OTHERWISE. AND WE HAVE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO ALIGN OUR
PRACTICES WITH THE NRCS LIKE
THE EQUIP PROGRAM. AND PART OF
OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GOAL%
HAS BEEN THAT WERE OUT.
PROVIDING INFORMATION ABOUT
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE AND
HERE ARE THE PLACES WHERE YOU
CAN APPLY FOR INCENTIVES. BUT
THERE IS THE USDA QUICK PROGRAM.
FOR OUR PROGRAM AND I THINK
THAT WITH SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
FROM THE FIGHTING
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAVE
ALREADY RECEIVED QUITE A BIT OF
ATTENTION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THERE'S EVEN MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US TO LEVERAGE THE DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE. AND USE THAT TO
INCENTIVIZE MORE FARMERS BEING
ABLE TO TAP INTO THOSE FEDERAL
DOLLARS AND DROP THOSE DOWN AS
WELL. THANK YOU THAT'S GOOD TO
HEAR THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
LEVERAGE. THE SMALL RESOURCES
WE HAVE I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION- FOR CHIEF OF PORTER-
SILVA AS SOMEBODY WHO WORKED-
DILIGENTLY ON SB NINE A ONE AND
WHO'S ALSO BEEN I WAS A MEMBER
THIS YOU'RE NOT A CONSERVANCY-
FOR SEVEN YEARS BEFORE I CAME
TO THE LEGISLATURE WE WORKED
ON- WE'VE WE'VE KNOWN THE FIRE
HIS. IS GONNA DO WHAT IT'S
DOING. AND SO WITH THAT I KNOW
THAT WITH THE BOTTOM MONIES
SEEM TO BE DIRECTED- TO YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND I TOURED A
COUPLE OF THE PROJECT- A BY THE
COLFAX AREA- THAT- E. THE
CALIFORNIA WAS DOING IN. THE
COST PER ACRE WAS REALLY HIGH
AND SO ONE OF THE TOOLS I THINK
THAT WE'VE I THINK MISSED OUT
ON AS ARE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
EVERY COUNTY HAS A FIRE SAFE
COUNCIL. THEY ARE WORKING WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE
WORKING WITH HOMEOWNERS AND
LANDOWNERS AND TRYING TO BE
ABLE TO MAYBE GET SOME OF THESE
RESOURCES DOWN- TO THE FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS TO ABLE TO GO OUT
AND DO SOME OF THE WORK ALONG
WITH- WHAT YOU'RE PROVIDING. A
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT AT
THE THEIR DISTASTE THE PACE AND
SCALE THAT WE NEED TO MOVE. A
IN CALIFORNIA TO GET THESE
MOVIES- TREATED- I THINK THAT
EVEN THOUGH WE PUT OF THE
RESOURCES IN THERE- THERE'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH CONTRACTORS OUT
THERE- TO DO THE WORK AND SO I
WANTED TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS WERE ON THAT IS HOW WE
COULD MOVE- THE RESOURCES AND
GET MORE WORK DONE ON THE
GROUND AT A LESSER. OF A COST.
TO TREAT MORE ACRES. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY- GREAT QUESTION
AGAIN TOM PORTER CAL FIRE
DIRECTOR AND STATE FORESTER
WEEKWHAT- WHAT I WOULD SAY TO
THAT IS- THE FUNDING THAT HAS
BEEN BUILT INTO OUR BUDGET OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS- ON THE
BACK OF SB NINE ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- HAS ALLOWED US TO
START THAT BUILDING OF THE- THE
INDUSTRY TO PRODUCE THAT WORK-
SO. THOUGH THE FOREST WORKERS
AND THE TIME IN IN CALIFORNIA
CAPABILITIES ARE INCREASING WE
HAVE SEVERAL OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
SPECIFIC FUNDING THAT ARE ARE
LOOKING AT INCREASING THE- THE-
TRAINING FOR SUCH WORKERS. BUT
THE QUESTION OF GETTING MORE
MONEY TO FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND
ARMED- THOSE THAT ARE REALLY
THE COMMUNITY BASED-
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURES TO
MANAGE SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
WERE VERY MUCH ABOUT THAT- WE
CAN CONTINUE TO REPORT BACK ON
ON WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH THE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY
BUT A LOT OF THOSE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO A NONPROFIT AS AS WELL
AS- THOSE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS.
AND OTHERS AND I DO KNOW THAT
LIKE ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS WE
ARE OVER- SUBSCRIBED WE HAVE
MORE APPLICANTS THAN WE CAN
FUND ARE CURRENTLY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OF WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS STARTING TO
GETTING GET MORE OF THOSE FUNDS
DOWN TO THOSE TYPES OF A
PROJECT AREAS BOTH OF THE
FOREST HEALTH AREA. BUT ALSO IN
THE FIRE PREVENTION WHICH IS
THAT- NEXT YEAR IN AND AROUND
CLOSER TO COMMUNITIES BUT STILL
HAS A VERY POSITIVE GREENHOUSE.
GAS ONE OF THE TOUGHEST. SO I
HAVE A ONE MORE ON KNOW WHO
THIS WOULD ANSWER THIS- WHAT
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE IN.
CALIFORNIA IS THAT. YOU KNOW
ALMOST 60% OF OUR LAND IS
CONTROLLED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND- I BROUGHT THIS
UP IN OUR LAST HEARING ABOUT
THEM BEING A PARTNER IN. YOU
KNOW DOING GOOD FORESTRY AND-
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS IT'S ALWAYS BEEN. WELL
YOU KNOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL ALL
AGREE HE HE WHEN HE SAID
CALIFORNIA'S FOREST FIRES ARE
CALIFORNIA'S PROBLEMS NO. THERE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
PROBLEM BECAUSE 60% OF THAT
LAND THEY MANAGE OR DON'T
MANAGE IN MOST CASES IN AT
LEAST IN MY OPINION. WHAT IS A
NEXUS BETWEEN. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S FOR
SERVICE IN TRYING TO
HOLISTICALLY TREAT. THE MOUNT
OF WATERSHEDS THAT ARE IMPAIRED
IN CALIFORNIA AND I SAY THAT AS
SOMEBODY WHO WORKED. WITH
SOMETHING WE CALL THE QUINCY
LIBRARY GROUP WHICH WAS TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO WHERE WE WENT
THROUGH AND WE SAID WE HAD A
FEDERAL BILL TO DO LANDSCAPE
TYPE. FUEL BREAKS SO WAS MUST
MOSAIC FUEL BREAKS IN LASSEN-
PLUMAS AND SIERRA. FOR THE PART
OF THE TITLE FORCED TO TRY TO
PUT IN THESE FUEL BREAKS WE
WOULD HAVE A FIRE LARGER THAN
EIGHT THOUSAND ACRES WE WOULD
HAVE FUEL RACING OR SO. THAT'S
WHAT NEED TO REALLY HAPPEN WE
NEED TO GO THROUGH AND PUT FUEL
BREAKS IN OUR FOR SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THESE. HUGE FOREST
FIRES THAT WE CAN CONTAIN OF
DUMB BACK AND TREAT. IN BETWEEN
THOSE FIREBRICK SO WHO WHO IS
COORDINATING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE I THINK WE REALLY MISSED
THE BOAT IN CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE
WE DON'T WE HAVE A PARTNER
WHO'S NOT AT THE TABLE. SO I'M
ASSUMING NOW THAT- WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION AND IN. DC THAT.
TALK TO THE ADMINISTRATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S NOT THIS
ADVERSARIAL. RELATIONSHIP THAT
WE CAN NOW SIT DOWN AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO TREAT.
TOGETHER THE FORCED. ALLEGEDLY
THAT AFTER. LIKE YEAH LIKE
CANCER THAT. AGAIN I WILL I
WILL PROVIDE AN ANSWER- AND
THANK YOU AGAIN SENATOR DOLLY
FOR THAT QUESTION. THE HELLO
AGAIN TOM BORDER CAL FIRE
DIRECTOR AND STATE FORESTER
WHERE WE ARE- WITH THE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PARTICULARLY
FOR SERVICE WILL JUST FOCUS ON
THEM THEY'RE THE LARGEST SINGLE
LANDOWNER OF THESE TYPES OF
PLANS IN CALIFORNIA. AND OUR
RELATIONSHIP AND OUR OUR-
PLANNING PROCESS IS VERY GOOD
AND ACTUALLY- AND THEN BE OF A
LOT OF PARTS OF THE OF THE
UNITED STATES- BECAUSE WE ARE
SO CLOSE. WHERE WE'VE HAD A
SHORTAGE IS- IN FEDERAL FUNDING
TO FEDERAL PROJECTS AND THAT IS
AN AREA THAT WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY OF THROUGH THE PROPER
CHANNELS- SECRETARY CROWFOOT OF
NATURAL RESOURCES. IS ENGAGED
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
CONVERSATIONS- AT THE- AT THE
BINDING MINISTRATION LEVEL ON
AND FOR SERVICE USDA ON.
INCREASING THAT FUNDING AND-
MAKING SURE THEY'RE MEETING
THEIR MATCH- THAT WE HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING WE PUT ABOUT
HOUSEHOLDS ARE ARE FUNDS OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS INTO
PROJECTS ON FEDERAL LANDS- THAT
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES- AND SO
WE ARE ACTIVELY THERE. WE ARE
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND-
REGION FIVE FORESTER RANDY
MOORE AND I TALK REGULARLY
ABOUT- INCREASING THOSE EFFORTS
THEY NEED MORE FUNDING DIRECTED
TO THEIR PROGRAMS OF ALL TYPES
AND- JUST TO BACKTRACK ON THE
PREVIOUS QUESTION. OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS WE'VE FUNDED A
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF PROJECTS TO NINETY ONE
A SEPARATE FIRE SAFE. COUNCILS
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. RIGHT
I GUESS FOR FINANCE TO. ADD TO
THE COVER UP BECAUSE WE DID WE
HAVE GIVEN MONEY TO CAL- YES
FOR- THE LOCAL FIRE RESPONSE IN
AND THE RESOURCE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION NATURAL RESOURCE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE REGIONAL
FOR A LOCAL FIRE- FORCE
RESTORATION PROJECTS- BUT THE
CAL FIRE WITH THE CAL WILDLIFE
URBAN INTERFACE AND OTHER FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES. AND ALSO
THE URBAN FORESTRY ALL THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE ZEROED OUT OTHER
DISCREPANCY PROGRAMS ARE ALL
GIRLS ARE NOT MEAN WE ARE WE
KNOW WE HAD A HEARING LAST WEEK
AND PRESCRIBED FIRES SOME
REDUCTIONS SO WE KNOW THAT
MONEY'S BEING REPLACED WHETHER
IT'S ENOUGH MONEY WE'RE GOING
TO GET THAT'S NOT PART OF THIS
PROGRAM BUT- I THINK. THE
MOSAIC. THAT THE CENTER DOLLIES
TALKING ABOUT THESE OTHER
PARTNERS THAT WE HAVE AT LEAST
UNDER THIS HEALTHY FOREST.
PROPOSAL IS BEEN ZEROED OUT
FINANCE CAN YOU SHED SOME LIGHT
ON YOUR THINKING. CERTAINLY
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO PUT THIS IN
THE CONTEXT OF NOTING THAT WE
HAVE LESS FUNDING AVAILABLE AS
THE LA US ANALYSIS. I WE'RE
PROPOSING ABOUT ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS
THE CURRENT YEAR AND THE BUDGET
YEAR WHICH IS ABOUT WHAT WAS
ALLOCATED IN A SINGLE YEAR. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY SO
THEREFORE WE HAVE HAD TO
PROPOSED EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT
IS TARGETED AND LIMITED. AND
PRIORITIZES FUNDING FOR EQUITY
PROGRAMS LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION THEIR MISSION
VEHICLES AND NATURAL WORKING
WITH THEM. SO HOW CAN TO PASS
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE STEVEN
BENSON TO SEE IF HE HAS
ANYTHING ADDITIONAL TIME. YES
IT IS THE CHAIR HAS NOTED
BEFORE. IT'S FINE AND DANDY
THEY HAVE THESE EQUITY PROGRAMS
BUT THEY'RE NOT DEEP CARBON
REDUCTION PROGRAM SIR THERE
THE- POLLUTION PROGRAMS WHICH
IS FINE BUT THAT'S NOT. WHAT
THE SOURCE OF MONEY SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING FOR AT LEAST WHAT FOR
THE AMOUNT OF. THE AMOUNT OF
CHANGES GOING INTO WITH THE
LIMITED MONEY THAT WE HAVE-
STEVE. EUROPE IT IS VERY
BRIEFLY- MENTIONED THAT SO IF I
AM GOING BACK. TO THE EARLIER
QUESTION A LITTLE BIT THAT.
REPORTER ROCK ABOUT A LOT OF
THE RELATIONSHIP GOING ON A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT JUST WITH
YOUR BILL. ON THAT NOTE TO NOTE
THAT- NATURISM IS AGENCY OUR
COMPUTERS OFFICE ENTERED INTO A
STRATEGIC AGREEMENT WITH THE
FOR SERVICE THAT HELP TREAT- I
THINK THEY'RE GONNA MATCH THE
GOAL OF FIVE THOUSAND ACRES
ANNUALLY AS WELL SO THERE ARE
THEY JUST GONNA TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT I'M GOING
CONVERSATIONS AND WHAT GOING ON
TO HELP BOLSTER THAT WORK
THAT'S PART OF THE MOSAIC GIVEN
HOW MUCH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
UNKNOWNS IN TERMS OF FORTUNATE
LANCE. UNDER THE PROGRAMS YOU
KNOW THAT THE WILDFIRE FORCED
RESILIENCE EXPENDITURE PLAN
THIS YEAR WE TALKED ABOUT LAST
WEEK- FOCUSES A LOT OF MONEY.
THE FAIR AMOUNT OF MONEY- IT TO
CONTINUE FOR ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS THE TO OUR MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT'S DIRECTED
THROUGH SB NINE A ONE. WELL
THAT FUNDING GOES THE FORCED
HEALTH PROGRAM AS WELL AS- THE
FUNDING THAT GOES TO HELP WITH
YOUR SMALL LANDOWNERS- SO. IT
THINK THEY'RE THERE ARE FFORTS
THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS RUN
THROUGH AL FIRE ENGINES ARE
EXTENT YOU KNOW YES AS WELL
THAT- ARE. AIMED AT TRYING TO
HALT. WITH AND IF THINK IS.
APTLY PUT THE MOSAIC OF KIND OF
LAND OWNED ALL THOSE VERY
DIFFERENT VARIOUS DIFFERENT
TYPES OF LANDOWNERS TO HELP
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. AND I WILL
I WILL GO INTO MORE DETAIL ON
THAT GIVEN HOW MUCH DETAIL WE
WENT IN LAST WEEKON THE ON THE
WELFARE FORCED RESILIENCE PLAN.
BUT YOU KNOW HAPPY TO ANSWER
HIS QUESTIONS. HELP REVAMP. ALL
RECOGNIZE CENTER STERN HAS SOME
QUESTIONS AS YOU REMEMBER FROM
LAST WEEK THEY'RE- THEY'RE
MEMBERS OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
THAT HAVE A MORE AMBITIOUS PLAN
HIS ON THE HEALTHY. FORESTS AND
THE FOREST PREVENTION- AS FAR
AS NUMBERS AND THERE'S ALSO IS
I'VE INTIMATED BEFORE THERE'S
GENERAL FUNDS FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE NOT. IT I
KNOW THE FOUR STAR BURNING
TODAY SO IT'S NOT OUT OF THE
PUBLIC SIDE YOU KNOW FROM FRONT
AND CENTER BUT THAT'S WERE.
INVOLVED IN GOOD GOVERNANCE AND
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE PLANNING
FOR THESE THINGS IN
ANTICIPATING THEM CENTER STERN
EUROPE. THANKS MISTER CHAIR-
THANKS IS CASH AND SO FAR. I
LIKE. MISTER BROWN I DO NOT
HAVE A LEAF BLOWER AND GAS
POWERED LEAF BLOWER I HAVE A
LOADING TRUCK IT IS BY THE WAY
I DON'T THINK ELECTRICALLY
POWERED- SO. WE ALL OF OUR ZOOM
CHALLENGES MORNING PLEASE BEAR
WITH ME TOO- IT IS. COMMON IN
QUESTION- AND WE SORT OF FRAME
THIS DISCUSSION AS THE ONE OF
THE DECISION POINTS BEING- WE
PURSUE EARLY ACTION. AT MY
COMMENT IS THAT I. MY UNDER I
DON'T THIS DOESN'T FEEL LIKE
EARLY ACTION TO ME IT FEELS
LIKE LEFTOVER WORK WE SHOULD
HAVE DONE LAST YEAR- RIGHT AND
I JUST WANTED. GET THIS SERVICE
STRAIGHT FROM A IS THE
BUDGETING STANDPOINT THAT. THE
REVENUES THAT ACCUMULATED OVER
THE COURSE OF LAST YEAR WERE
NOT APPROPRIATE AGE- AT THE END
OF SESSION. THE LEGISLATURE
DIDN'T DIDN'T MAKE THOSE
APPROPRIATIONS AND SO MONEY IS
BEEN PILING UP. ADMITS DEBT AND
ECONOMIC- DEVASTATION THAT WE
LIKE WE'VE REALLY NEVER SEEN
BEFORE SO I MY QUESTION IS
ABOUT. HOW FAST WE CAN GET
MONEY OUT THE DOOR TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA AND HOW- HOW HOW
IT'S HOW IT'S WORKED IN THE
PAST IN TERMS OF TIMELINE. SO
LIKE HOW TO SET SOME REASONABLE
EXPECTATIONS- AND HOW WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE- THE KIND
OF FUNDING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE WITH. WHAT WE HOPE WILL BE
SOME ACTION FEDERALLY. THE
HOUSE PASSED A ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION DOLLAR- HI MAKING
INFRASTRUCTURE ORIENTED BILL
LAST YEAR- AND WE KNOW THE
SENATE'S CONSIDERING SOMETHING
SIMILAR AND THIS ADMINISTRATION
WAS GOING THROUGH THEIR SORT OF
COVERT. PLAN IS ALSO BY
ADMINISTRATION APPEARS TO BE
INTERESTED IN. MAKING GOOD ON
THE PRESIDENT'S PROMISE- FOR A
MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN CLIMB IN
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WHEN IT COMES
TO SORT OF PRIMING THE PUMP AND
GETTING DOLLARS MOVING QUICKLY
SO THAT. WE CAN BE READY IN
THESE PROGRAMS- SORT OF GO
THROUGH THE FITS AND STARTS
MAYBE. WE CAN GET LIKE ONE OR
TWO SNAPSHOTS OF EXPECTATIONS
FOR SPEED AND TIMING IF WE WERE
TO TAKE SAY EARLY ACTION- NOT
JUST ON WILDFIRE BUT- MORE
BROADLY ON THE SORT OF. CLIMATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE START
GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. SO
MAYBE I KNOW ONE OF THE MOST
JOBS INTENSIVE SECTORS. IS OUR
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION SECTOR. IN CHIEF
PORTER I APPRECIATE- THE- YOU
KNOW THE SCRUTINY YOU'VE YOU
YOU ABSORB FROM THOSE OF US IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND GOING
INTO THE DETAILS OF ALL THESE
PROGRAMS AND TRYING TO MAKE IT
WORK FOR. YOU KNOW OUR OUR
CERTIFIER ECOLOGIES DOWN IN
SOCAL BUT I WILL SAY YOU KNOW
ON THE WHOLE THIS THIS PROGRAM
THE ANALYSIS WE'VE SEEN FROM
FROM LIKE UCLA LUSKIN CENTER
DID ONE RECENTLY- V. SINGLE
MOST. ARE JOB PRODUCING GIGI
ARE ASKED INVESTMENT WE'VE MADE
THUS FAR HAS BEEN FORCED HEALTH
ON A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS.
SO BECAUSE IT IS SO PEOPLE
INTENSIVE IS MY UNDERSTANDING
SO IF WE WERE TO TAKE EARLY
ACTION STATE IN ACCORDANCE WITH
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
OR- THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY
TRY TO PUSH YOU GUYS A LITTLE
FURTHER I THINK THE CHAIR JUST
ALLUDED TO IT I THINK WE CAN DO
MORE. I DON'T WANT TO UNDER
SHOOT THAT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN
GOING INTO THIS FIRE SEASON NOT
OVER SHOOTING- BUT HOW FAST CAN
CAN WE MOVE CAN CAN WE BEAT.
THIS FIRE SEASON- IN TERMS OF
GETTING DOLLARS OUT INTO
COMMUNITIES ON EVERYTHING FROM
FORESTRY PROJECTS TO FUEL
BREAKS TO FIRE SAFE COUNCILS TO
COMMUNITY HARDENING I MEAN HOW
FAST CAN CAN WE WILL. SENATOR
STERN- THANK YOU AGAIN TOM
PORTER CHALFORD RECTOR ST
FORSTER- I AM GOING TO JUST
TOUCH ON THIS AND I'M GOING TO
PASS THE TORCH TO ASSISTANT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. A LOT OF US
FOR MORE DETAIL. JUST IN
GENERAL WE- THIS IS A VERY LONG
TERM ISSUE AND WHERE WE DO
PROJECTS WE WILL HAVE-
IMPORTANCE- BENEFIT TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THE IN
AND AROUND THOSE AREAS AND
THOSE WIL LANDS. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO MAINTAIN A LONG TERM
INVESTMENT TOWARD EARLY ACTION
WILL GIVE US- A SIGNIFICANT.
LEG UP ON SOME PROJECTS THAT
WILL AFFECTED PIECES AND PARTS
OF THIS COMING SEASON. ABOUT
MORE IN THE COMING SEASONS-
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
LOUDEST. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
PORTER THANK YOU SENATOR- IN G.
LOUDEST ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CLIMATE AND ENERGY
THE CALIFORNIA AT FIRST I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING
THE AFFECTS THAT- THAT ARE
FUNDING HAS HAD ON STIMULATING
JOBS AND THE ECONOMY IT'S OUR
SMALL OVERSTAFFED FAVORITE
REPORTING METRICS TO COLLECT
AND IT'S HAPPENED TO. YOU KNOW
GET EMAILED AROUND EVERYWHERE
WHEN THE DATA COMES IN BECAUSE
WE FEEL THE IMPACT THAT IT HAS
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND IT'S
EXCITING TO US AS ELL WE'RE
VERY READY TO- TO AT I HAVE
MOVED ON GETTING FUNDS TO OUR
PARTNERS WITH THIS EARLY ACTION
FUNDING AND I BELIEVE THAT OUR
PARTNERS ARE ALSO EAGER TO GET
GOING ON THE GROUND BOTH
BECAUSE THEY HAVE PEOPLE WHO.
ARE READY TO GET TO WORKING
WOULD LIKE TO GET TO WORK- AND
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND- THAT
EVERY DAY WEEK AND MONTH OF
WORK COUNTS TOWARDS A
POTENTIALLY CHANGING THE
EFFECTIVE A WILDFIRE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I WOULD LIKE TO-
BY NOW- AND REINFORCE SOMETHING
THAT DIRECTOR PORTER HAS SAID
WHICH IS THAT FOR THE PROJECTS-
IT IS IT IS ONGOING WORK
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO- HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HAVE AN EFFECT AS
SOON AS IT IS DONE- AND THAT
GETTING STARTED QUICKLY AT
COULD HAVE AFFECTS THIS FIRE
SEASON AND IF T DOESN'T THEN
COULD HAVE A GREATER EFFECT IN
THE NEXT FIRE SEASON I WENT AND
WORKED WELFARE'S STRENGTH
RELATIVE TO OUR PROJECTS ARE.
THE REALLY THE SOONER WE CAN
GET GOING THE BETTER IN AND
GETTING STARTED IS THAT THE
MORE IMPORTANT THING TO FOCUS
ON RATHER THAN WHEN THOSE
PROJECTS- PUT INPUT FINISHED IS
THERE ARE CONTINUOUSLY WORKED
ON. THANK YOU OR YOUR TIME
YEAH OF COURSE ISN'T THERE I
KNOW MISTER BENSON HAD HIS HAND
UP BUT IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO TARGET THESE. FUNDS- IN
LINE WITH SOME OF EQUITY. AND
LABOR PRINCE THAT BEEN. SORT
OF- TRYING TO LOOK AT MORE
BROADLY IS A STATE I THINK IN
TERMS OF HOW WE RECOVER- I'M
THINKING OF YOU KNOW THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OUT
THERE- THAT HAVE BEEN HIT IN
THE LOOK AT THE SOME OF THE SET
SEVEN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES THAT
HAVE BURNED THROUGH IN.
COMMUNITIES LIKE IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY OR GRATTAN ST
BERNARD DINO WERE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY HAVE AS THEIR BEEN ANY
THOUGHT TO BUILDING SOME EQUITY
METRICS AS WELL AS- ALSO TRYING
TO UP LIFT ON THE WORK FORCE
SIDE I'M TO THE MISTER BROWN'S
LEAF BLOWER- EXAMPLE YOU KNOW
WE TEND TO DENIGRATE LANDSCAPE.
AND HOME HARDENING TYPE JOBS
AND TREAT THEM AS YOU KNOW MERE
LEAF BLOWING OR OR- BRUSH
CLEARANCE THAT GOES TO MANY
WORKERS WHO YOU KNOW DON'T HAVE
BENEFITS ARE CERTAINLY AREN'T
INTO A UNION BUT BUT YOU KNOW
MAYBE TREAT IT IS SORT OF-
SECOND TIER WORKERS IN LABOR
BUT ANY THOUGHTS ON ON UP LIVE
THERE IN IN THE WORK FORCE AND
WAYS TO GET PEOPLE. THE CHIEF
PORTERS POINT I GUESS ON A ON A
LONGER TERM TRACK AS WE GO
LONGER TERM DO WE BUILD THE
NEXT GENERATION OF SORT OF FIRE
RESILIENCY WORKERS ACTUALLY
MAKE THIS A LONG TERM CAREER
I'M WONDERING JUST QUICK.
THOUSAND SORRY MR BENTSEN FOR.
IN YOUR AND REYES. I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THEM- HERE CAL FIRE WE
DO SEE LANDSCAPE MANAGEMENT AS
A AS AN IMPORTANT CAREER WORTHY
OF LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AND
GOAL- THE IT'S CERTAINLY AT ANY
TYPE OF LAND BASED LABOR CAN BE
HARD AND HOT AND NOT VERY
ATTRACTIVE BUT- IT COMPLETELY
INTEGRAL TO EVERYTHING THAT WE
DO- AND SO OF COURSE THERE'S
ALWAYS SPACE. TO THINK MORE
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
WHETHER WE CAN INCREASE THE
INTENDED. IN THE FACTS OF OUR
ACTIONS I WILL SAY THAT WE DO
CONSIDER- LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- IN OUR GRANT
SCORING BOTH FOR FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE PREVENTION IT'S AN
IMPORTANT- CRITERIA. OF
PROJECTS GET MORE POINTS FOR
THE EFFECTS THAT THEY HAVE
THERE AND WE DILIGENTLY COLLECT
DATA ON ON WHERE WORKERS ARE I
THINK EVEN TO THE POINT OF
WHERE WORKERS ARE LIVING- TO
SEND SURE THAT WERE REACHING
DOWN INTO THOSE aMUNITIES-
AND SO AND- I WILL. WOULD LIKE
TO BOTH RECOGNIZE THAT- THAT WE
CAN ALWAYS. WE CAN ALWAYS
PROBABLY LOOK AT WHETHER
THERE'S MORE WE CAN DO AND I
WILL SAY THAT WE- HAVE REALLY
BEEN FOCUSING- IN. HOW WE CAN
WORK MORE WITH COMMUNITIES IN
THE VERY FAR SOUTHERN PORTION
OF THE STATE AND FINING SOME
SUCCESSES ON A YEAR TO YEAR
BASIS AND SO. ON AND SO. YOU
KNOW MAYBE OUR NUMBERS WILL BE
EVEN GREATER IN THE FUTURE BUT
ALSO TO SAY THAT IT IS ALREADY
A PRIORITY AND SOMETHING THAT
WE- WE CERTAINLY VALUE. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO. MISTER
BRANSON WITH FINANCIAL
RECOGNIZE. I THINK KNOWING JUST
PROTECT ON SPRUCE BRIEFLY THAT
PART OF THE EARLYACTION
STRATEGY HERE TO READ
EVERYTHING. HELLFIRE SAID IN
TERMS OF GETTING BENEFITS AS
FAST AS WE CAN BUT- GETTING
STARTED EARLY ALSO HELPS US TO
BUILD TRYING TO LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING BOTH
IN THE CAN ASSIST ME IN THE
HARDENING AND WELL AS A LOT OF
OTHER PROGRAMS- WITHIN CAN
THIS. HAVE FIRE REPORTS
RESILIENCE- YEAH STRATEGIES. IS
AND IT'S THOSE WORTH NOTING AS
WELL THAT IT NEARLY START- DOES
HELP IN THAT REGARD AS WELL.
EKEUS OF THE FOLLOW UP AND
CENTER STERN'S QUESTION WE HAVE
BEFORE US A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS HIS FOR THE
HEALTHY AND RESILIENT FOREST
PROGRAMS HE'S LOOKING AT. SORT
OF COLLECTIVELY OTHER PARTNERS
I REMEMBER FROM LAST WEEK WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLY MONEY OR
MONEY TO GO TO THIS YEAR
CONSERVANCY IN THE TAHOE
CONSERVANCIES I'M WONDERING.
REGIONALLY LIKE THE SAN GABRIEL
OR SANTA MONICA ARE THERE OTHER
CONSERVANCY THAT ARE IN THE
QUEUE OR ARE HAVE. RESILIENT
FORESTRY PLANS THAT WULD BE
CONSIDERED WITH THIS EARLY
ACTION MONEY OR IS THAT. FOR
ANOTHER DAY. I DON'T REPRESENT
SAN GABRIEL OR SANTA MONICA I'M
JUST ASKING. HERE TOM PORTER
I'M TO GIVE A VERY QUICK
ANSWER- THE. THE REGIONAL AREAS
ARE NOT FULLY SET UP YET THAT'S
PART OF THAT OTHER BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THOSE PLANS WERE
TO DEVELOP UNDER THAT THERE ARE
PROJECTS OF VERY LARGE NUMBER
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR- FUNDING- THAT ARE NOT
CLOSELY ASSOCIATED WITH A
REGIONAL PLAN BUT WILL BE PART
OF THAT REGIONAL PLANS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE GOING
FORWARD THAT WE WILL LOOK TO
FUND THROUGH ANY EARLY ACTION
ALONG WITH OTHER A VIABLE
PROJECTS. OKAY SO SENATE
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE CHAIR- I'M GONNA CHANGE
DIRECTION JUST A BIT TO GO BACK
TO THE NEWER- SO LONG SIR SURE
AND I JUST WANNA IS A- HOW
GRATEFUL I AM TO SECRETARY
ROSS. FOR HER LEADERSHIP OVER
THE MANY YEARS HE'S BEEN IN
THIS ROLE IN PRIOR- AND
THOROUGHLY ENJOY WORKING WITH
HUMANA SECTOR IN YOUR TEAM. BUT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT METHANE
EMISSIONS- ESPECIALLY THAT
REDUCTION FROM DAIRY AND
LIVESTOCK OPERATIONS IN WHAT I
BELIEVE WAS A COMMITMENT. TO
DAIRY FARMERS ACROSS THE STATE
WHEN INITIALIZATION WAS PASSED
IN WHERE I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE
DROPPED THE BALL. IN FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN ADMINISTRATION OR
PERFORATED. AT THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE FIFTY
MILLION. THEN IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE MILLION
MISAPPROPRIATED. I THEN LAST
YEAR TWENTY NINE MILLION WAS
APPROPRIATED EXCUSE ME TWO
YEARS AGO 222-000-1820 TWENTY
NINE MILLION WAS APPROPRIATED.
LAST YEAR NOTHING. AND NOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT LOANS. AND
HERE'S WHAT I CAN SAY AT LEAST
ON THE NORTH COAST I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE IS STILL
SIGNIFICANT NEED. FOR MANURE
MANAGEMENT OBVIOUSLY WERE NOT
DIGEST OR COUNTIES BECAUSE WE
HAVE PASSED YEAR THE MANURE
MANAGEMENT AND ASSISTANCE ON
THE NORTH COAST THE VAST
MAJORITY OF DAIRY FARMERS IN
THE NORTH COAST OUR SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS. AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT MANY OF THEM BASED
OFF OF THE CHALLENGES WITH NO
PRICING OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS ARE HANGING ON BY A
THREAD. IN WHAT I AM REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT IS SADDLING
THEM WITH MORE DEBT- TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AS THEY
ARE NOW. BEING MANDATED TO DO.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE MORE THAN
WILLING TO COMPLY BUT- IT
SIMPLY MOVING THIS INTO THAT
CATALYST FUND- I'M REALLY
CHALLENGED TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY. ESPECIALLY NOW
THAT THE PROGRAM WS OVER
SUBSCRIBED- WE'RE NOT CONTINUE
TO INVEST- AS WAS ORIGINALLY
PROMISED AN IDEAL. IN MADAM
SECRETARY I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT ANSWERS HER I SHOULD GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
CLERK ROSS. YEAH SURE- AND I
APPRECIATE- YOUR COMMENTS
SENATOR- AND OBVIOUSLY THE
JERRY FAMILIES IN THE STATE
HAVE REALLY. ON STEP AND VERY
POSITIVELY INTO THE SPACE AND
ARE REAL LEADERS IN
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE ON. NOTHING
REDUCTION- AND THEY ARE MAKING
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS TOWARDS OUR
40%REDUCTION CALL. WE HAVE
INVESTED AND JERRY NOTHING
REDUCTION OF APPROPRIATIONS
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
LIFETIME OF THESE. PROGRAMS
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN FOR DEREK I
JUST OF TECHNOLOGY. BUT
IMPORTANTLY ABOUT SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
INVESTED FOR- NONTECHNICAL MAR-
DRIVING YOUR MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS COMPOST BARNS. AT
TYSON VERY NICELY TOWARD
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM. ALL OF
THESE PROJECTS HAVE GENERATED
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN MATCHING
FUNDS. BOTH A JERRY FAMILIES AS
WELL AS BY GESTURE. DEVELOPERS
WE ARE AT A POINT OF MATURATION
IN THESE PROGRAMS THAT HARD
DECISIONS HAVE TO BE MADE. WITH
A SCARCE DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE-
WE ARE VERY OPTIMISTIC BASED ON
PRELIMINARY STATEMENTS NOT ONLY
FROM- PRESIDENT BIDEN BETTER
ALSO HIS NOMINEE. WHO HOPEFULLY
WILL BE CONFIRMED NEXT WEEK
SECRETARY VILSACK. ABOUT THE
DESIRE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE THINK THAT.
OUR TRACK RECORD HERE- AND THAT
EAGERNESS WITH WHICH I JERRY
FAMILIES HAVE HAVE FOLLOWED
THESE PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE
WELL POSITIONED FOR FEDERAL
DOLLARS. IN ADDITION TO WHERE
IT MAKES SENSE FOR THEM. EITHER
FOR A LOAN GUARANTEE. FOR A LOW
INTEREST LOAN FROM THE CATALYST
FUND. THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU IN A
CENTURY LOOK I'LL. JUST FOLLOW
UP WITH A QUICK COMMENT- BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT DAIRY DIJO IN THIS
IS WELL AWARE OF THIS REALLY
WELL SUITED FOR CENTRAL. ON THE
MINORE MEASURE SIDE ESPECIALLY.
SCOTT IS NORTH COAST. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE FOLKS HAVE
THREE HUNDRED HEAD OF CATTLE.
THREE HUNDRED IN A TRYING TO
MAKE IT WORK WITH REDUCE NO
POPS IS AN INSTABILITY IN THE
MARKET SO I THINK AGAIN NGUYEN
RIGHT NOW INSURANCE MISTER LARA
WAS A SENATOR IN ADVANCE THE
BILL THAT SET THIS TARGET ON-
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY- AND
FEEDLOTS THERE IS A COMMITMENT
THAT THERE WOULD BE MONEY THERE
TO BE A TO MAKE THAT TRANSITION
GARY FARMER SIGNED ON TO THAT
COMMITMENT AND NOW WE'RE SEEING
THE BEST WE CAN DO IS PROVIDE
THEM WITH A LOAN WHEN THEY ARE
READY ARE LOW AND THEY HAVE
LOANS- UP THE HILL. I DID
THEY'RE HAVING TO BE A TO PAY
OFF TO GO TO KEEP THEMSELVES IN
BUSINESS SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
THE SENATE IS GOING TO DO SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK ON THIS BECAUSE
IT'S CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THE
SUCCESS THAT THEY ARE NOW
MANDATED TO BRING FORWARD THANK
YOU THE SECRETARY BLOOM FOR YOU
HAVE THAT ON THE SAME THEME
SHORT TERM CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
WE'VE GOT NOTHING FOR
REFRIGERANTS AND NOTHING FOR
OUR WASTE DIVERSION HAS JUST
SORT OF BEEN THE HALLMARK
BACKBONE PROGRAMS FOR HERE FOR
THESE REALLY. BAD FIND IT. NOW
AIR POLLUTION CLIMB- WHY. IT
SEEMS LIKE THOSE ARE IT IS JUST
WE CAN RELY ON LOANS OR WHAT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THESE
TWO AREAS. THE VIJAY THAT AND
PJ- SENATE DEMS LOOK Y. AS A
QUESTION AND- THE LAUREL- SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE- YEAH IT
FEELS A SHOULDER CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS WHETHER THAT.
METHANE COMING. FROM LANDFILLS
ALBANY- ALL. FROM THE WAY
THEY'VE RE REFRIGERATE-
AERIALS- THE AND SUPERMARKETS-
SO ON THE CRIME INCLUDE- COBB
HAS SOME OF THE MOST-
REGULATIONS ON WALKS. A
REFRIGERANT CAN BE USED INSTEAD
OF REALLY S. AND NOT SAVINGS AB
CHAT IN THAT- REFRIGERATION
PROGRAMS OF THE MORE THAN
COMPENSATE MOST OF THE
FACILITIES- AND IN TERMS OF.
MEDIA MANAGEMENT- AND THE WHOLE
PANOPLY OF ISSUES IN THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE- LIKELY- YOU'RE
GONNA GET- DIRECTO R. WAGON A
LATER IN THE DAY- YOU CAN TALK
MORE EXPLICITLY ABOUT THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BUT- YEAH WE- TO
SIGNATURE ROSSES POINT REALLY
LOOKING AT THE CATALYST FUND.
THINK ABOUT HOW TO LOSE SOME OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES HOLE WOULD
THAT HAVE MATURED WHEN YOU LOOK
AT ADOPTION BECAUSE- WE'RE
LOOKING AT. MOVING PEOPLE I THE
CAB AND THEN REPLY. INCENTIVES
WHERE WE CAN- WE LEARN FUNDING
AND OPULENT- THE GOAL IS TO GET
PEOPLE TO JUST ADOPT THOSE
BEHAVIORS SO THAT'S KIND OF THE
OCT AND MANY DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES ARE AT DIFFERENT
PLACES WITHIN THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE- I DID WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE SENATE TO STAND QUESTION A
MAYBE LEFT- DEPUTY. DIRECTOR
SANCHEZ ADDRESSES WHICH WAS
ABOUT HOW I LOOK AT THE ACTION-
IS A BIT OF AN- MISS. FRAMING
IT REALLY IS- I'LL I'LL LET AND
THEY'RE PRETTY SANCHEZ TOLD YOU
THIS BUT IT'S- IT'S A
CONTINUATION OF THE PROGRAMS I
WANTED JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WAS PLAY I DON'T KNOW IT. IF
THE SANCHEZ IS ON BUT I WOULD
HOPE THAT WAS AN IMPORTANT
BUDGET ITEM THAT I WANT TO BE
CLEAR ON. THANK YOU SECRETARY-
CHAIR HAPPY JUST ELABORATE FOR.
A MOMENT- SENATOR STERN IS
CORRECT THIS IS A CONTINUATION
OF LAST SPRING'S CAP AND TRADE
DISCUSSIONS. ON FUNDING FOR
CURRENT YEAR- SO WE HAVE DOZENS
OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE. KIND OF
IN HOLD I'M MORE IN A HOLDING
PATTERN WAITING TO GET MONEY
OUT THE DOOR TO. CALIFORNIA AND
COMMUNITIES AND ORGANIZATIONS-
WE NOW HAVE THE RESULTS OF THE
FIRST TO CAP AND TRADE
AUCTIONS. AND AS WE NOTED THIS
MORNING TOMORROW IS THE THIRD-
SO WE DO HAVE FINDING IT THAT
COULD START THESE PROJECTS- AS
SOON AS- PRACTICABLE WE HEARD
FROM CHIEF PORTER- YOU KNOW
JUST HOW IMPORTANT GETTING THE
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS AT THE-
FUNDED AND OUT THE DOOR. HAD A
FIRE SEASON WOULD BE I ALSO
WANT TO. EMPHASIZE YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE WELL DOCUMENTED AND
UNDERSTOOD CONNECTION BETWEEN
AIR POLLUTION AND INCREASED
COBIT SUSCEPTIBILITY AND NOTING
THE- ONGOING STRUGGLES- WITH
THE PANDEMIC YOU KNOW
PRIORITIZING OUR- CLEANING UP
OUR AIR IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- AND PROTECTING
HEALTH GOING FORWARD. IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE HAVE AIR BOARD
COLLEAGUES ON THE LINE WHO CAN
SPEAK TO THE- OVER SOLICITATION
OF THE LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT
ARE. ALSO PROPOSED- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. WELL I
COULD GO ON FOR HOURS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY I'M UNDER A
LIMITS TO US AND SAY GOOD TO
KICK US OUT HERE SO. I'M GOOD
AT THIS MATTER IS GOING TO BE
HELD OPEN OBVIOUSLY THE SENATE
CONTINUES WITH ITS- WILL
CONTINUE WITH ITS ROBUST- ARE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
HERE AND WILL CONTINUE TO SEND
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FINANCING
FOR THE- THE AGENCIES THANK.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOUFOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. N. WE WILL
HOLD THAT ITEM NUMBER A-
FIFTEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SECRETARY THANK YOU A
BOTH SECRETARIES AND EVERYBODY
ELSE IS ON THE CALL. LET'S THIS
IS THE IDEAL NUMBER SIXTEEN IS
THE CONTINUING RESOURCES TO
SUPPLEMENT OR TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE COMMUNITY
AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM THIS IS
THE- AB SIX SEVENTEEN. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUESTS FOUR
POINT ONE SIX FIVE IN GIGI R.
F. TO SUPPORT TWENTY TWO
EXISTING A PERMANENT POSITIONS
THAT WERE APPROVED IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. I UNDERSTAND. A
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CHIANG YOU HAVE A SLIDE SHOW
FOR US. I ACTUALLY DON'T- HAVE
SLIDES UNLESS WE HAVE QUESTIONS
THAT GO TO THE SLIDES OKAY ONE
PRECEDED OKAY SO THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SHERMAN MY CASKEY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
EDIE TRYING I'M A DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED I'M HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT OUR REQUEST
FOR PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
TWENTY TWO EXISTING POSITIONS
BETTER IMPLEMENTING EIGHTY SIX
ONE SEVEN. I'M AT SIX ONE SEVEN
WAS PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO SET UP A
NEW PARADIGM FOR HOW CARBON
ENGAGES COMMUNITIES TO ADDRESS
THE LIVING LEGACY OF THE
STRUCTURAL RACISM. IT'S PAST
GOVERNMENT POLICIES. THAT HAVE
PLAYED A ROLE IN THE HIGHER
LEVELS OF AIR POLLUTION IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AS
IT AS ENVISIONED BY THE
LEGISLATURE SB SIX ONE SEVEN
HOLDS GREAT PROMISE TO BE A
POWERFUL TOOL TO ADVANCE EQUITY.
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE LEGISLATURE
THAT TWO PER. IN FISCAL YEAR
SEVEN EIGHTEEN IMPLEMENT AB SIX
ONE SEVEN. FIFTY OF THEM WERE
APPROVED WITH PERMANENT FUNDING
AND BECAUSE THIS WAS A NEW
PROGRAM AND WE WEREN'T SURE
ABOUT THE WORKLOAD AT THAT
TIME. TWENTY TWO WERE APPROVED
WITH TEMPORARY FUNDING. I
REQUEST TWO DAYS TO PROVIDE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THESE
TWENTY TWO EXISTING PERMANENT
POSITIONS. THESE POSITIONS ARE
ALL LOCATED AND OUR OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION. THIS
OFFICE IS THE NEXUS OF MEETING
OUR AB SIX ONE SEVEN STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. THE STAFF REDUCE
THE BLUEPRINT FOR COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PLANS THEY
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
WHICH NEW COMMUNITIES WE BRING
AN- THE ENGAGE IN DAILY
CONVERSATIONS WITH- COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WORK WITH LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
TO RIPON RESPOND TO THE
COMMUNITY'S CONCERNS. BAKER
CILLA TAKE. CROSS AGENCY
COORDINATION. THESE FUNCTIONS
ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO AB SIX ONE
SEVEN IMPLEMENTATION ON ARE
CRITICAL TO FOR FILLING THE
PROMISE. OF DELIVERING ZERO
EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGY AND CLEAN
AIR TO OUR MOST MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. AND I DO WANT TO
MENTION THAT ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY REALLY GIVES US A
TRIPLE BENEFIT. IT HELPS REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS. AND THE COMMUNITY.
EXPOSURE TO AIR TOXICS. I THAT
IN THE FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET THAT EXTENDED
FUNDING FOR THESE POSITIONS THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
REQUIRING CARD TO REPORT ON OUR
COSTS TO IMPLEMENT AB SIX ONE
SEVEN. AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED
THAT REPORT. THE REPORT IS
UNDER REVIEW AND WE ARE WORKING
HARD TO GET IT TO YOU AS SOON
AS WE CAN- I WANTED TO GIVE YOU
AN OVERVIEW OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THESE POSITIONS TODAY. I
WILL BE HAPPY TO DISCUSS THE
REPORT WITH THE L. A. M. O. N.
COMMITTEE STAFF ONCE THEY HAVE
HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW IT.
THANK YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. YES WE'RE
GOOD I MEAN WHEN WE WERE HAVING
THE HEARING SUN SIX ONE SEVEN
WE HAD ABSOLUTELY EVERY LOCAL
AIRPORT CAME OBJECTING TO. THE
A SIX ONE SEVEN BECAUSE THERE
WAS NO FUNDING MECHANISM AND
TYPICALLY WE HAVE THE POLLUTING
ENTITY PAY FOR THE EQUIPMENT
THAT WOULD GO OUT ON THEIR- ON
THEIR- POSITION SO. IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR US ON
TH COST BECAUSE- I KNOW THERE
WAS A GRAND DEAL WITH THE
FORMER GOVERNOR WITH THE
POLLUTING ENTITIES IN THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL. JUSTICE
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S- UNFUNDED
IT WAS A DEAL THAT WAS UNFUNDED
SO- MISTER BROWN YOUR- TELL US
HOW IMPORTANT THIS A
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AS MS
CHANG MENTIONED- A PORTION OF
THE POSITIONS FOR EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION WERE
FUNDED ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS
GIVEN SOME OF THE UNCERTAINTY
AROUND ONGOING WORKLOAD AND SO
THAT'S THE KIND OF FOCUS OF
THIS REQUEST IT'S YOUR FUNDING
FOR TWENTY TWO OF THE SEVENTY
TWO TOTAL POSITIONS- AT THE
SAME TIME THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED LIMITED TERM FUNDING
GIVEN THAT- ON THAT UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT ONGOING WORKLOAD ALSO.
REQUIRED SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE- TO BE- FROM THAT
AIRPORT TO PROVIDE A REPORT ON-
AMONG OTHER THINGS IT'S- A PAST
WORKLOAD AS WELL AS ESTIMATED
FUTURE WORKLOAD TO ACCOMPANY
ANY REQUESTS FOR FUTURE FUNDING
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR THESE
POSITIONS AND AGAIN I WAS
TRYING TO SEND THAT REPORT
ISN'T AVAILABLE YET- WE THINK
THAT'S IT AND A CRITICAL PIECE
OF EVALUATING THIS PARTICULAR
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I THINK IT
SHOULD A COMPANY. REQUEST FOR A
REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE CAN REVIEW THESE
POSITIONS ON THE ONGOING
WORKLOAD AND SO I WOULD
RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD
ACTION ON THIS UNTIL THAT
REPORT IS AVAILABLE AND OF
COURSEWE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF IN AIRPORT
IN REVIEWING THAT INFORMATION
AND THEN- UPDATING OUR COMMENTS
ACCORDINGLY. FINANCING HAVE
ANYTHING ANY FOLLOW UP. NOTHING
TO ADD AT THIS. OKAY I MEAN I
THINK THAT THE STAFF REPORT IS
QUITE CLEAR ON ON WHERE WE'RE
AT ON ON THIS ONE TO MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OF- THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OR- FINANCE. SEEING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
MATTER- ODDS IT IS THAT REPORT
THERE WILL BE GRANTED- FONG
THANK YOU. AIRBOARD FOR BEING
ON HERE WILL NOW INVITE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL AND THE ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS BEFORE US
IT'S THE COST RECOVERY. AND
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP OF. SIXTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION IN THIS YEAR
FOR BANKRUPTCY COUNSEL. AND WE
HAVE. DIRECTOR WILLIAMS GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. THE WAY
I AM VISIBLE USING. I SEE
NOTHING- ANOTHER SECOND. I SEE
THE L. A. ORDER- THEY CAN
RETORT YOU SAY HELLO THIS IS
OUR RIGHT GOOD MORNING DIRECTOR
PRETTY PLEASE PRECEDE. ZERO
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
SO THANK YOU SURE RIGHT BECAUSE
KEY AND OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS OF TEACHERS HE'S
OTHER BUDGET ITEMS MOST NOTABLY
OUR PROPOSED REVISIONS TO DGS
HE'S GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES. YOU
HAVE A BILL THAT SIGNALS A
SHARED FOCUS ON HOW TO IMPROVE
AND FORWARD AND MOVE FORWARD IN
PROVIDING GREATER TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FISCAL
STABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
ALTHOUGH WE'RE NOT DISCUSSING
THAT TODAY EXCITING IS
EMBLEMATIC OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
EACH YES HE'S WORKING
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HEAVILY
BURDENED BY POLLUTION. AND
EXPECT AND DESERVE A DGSE THAT
CAN FULFILL ITS MISSION.
YESTERDAY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON EXCITED AND PROPOSED
FUNDING TO BOTH HOLD
PASSHOLDERS ACCOUNTABLE AND
PUSH FORWARD WITH CLEANING UP
THE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
PROPERTIES THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
BEFORE. IN THE WAKE OF EXCISE
BANKRUPTCY WE ARE WORKING TO
KEEP OTHER ENTITIES ACCOUNTABLE.
IN DECEMBER DGSE FILED SUIT
AGAINST SEVERAL PRIOR OWNERS
AND OPERATORS OF THE FORMER
LEAD SMELTER IN VERNON
CALIFORNIA. ALSO AGAINST
SEVERAL AND SHE'S THAT EITHER
TRANSPORTED. SANTA OR
TRANSPORTED LARGE QUANTITIES OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE TO THAT
POSSIBILITY FOR DISPOSAL OR
TREATMENT. THIS CALLS FOR
REIMBURSEMENT TO THE STATE FOR
DHS HE'S COSTS. AS WE
OVERSEEING THE FACILITY CLEAN
UP AND PERFORM THE RESIDENTIAL
CLEAN UP. WE LEARNED QUITE A
NUMBER OF LESSONS THAT HAVE
HELPED US MAKE STEADY PROGRESS
ON THE RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE USING THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE EXTENT
BANKRUPTCY TO PUT CLEAR
ENFORCEABLE PERMITS IN PLACE.
WHERE APPROPRIATE AND ENFORCE
THOSE PERMITS AND STRENGTHENED
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR GRANT CO WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETAIL FOR OUR
BECAUSE RECOVERY WORK AND
RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP. DEPUTY
COAT. YEAH GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M GOING TO
SUMMARIZE THE RESIDENTIAL CLEAN
AT THE C. P. AND THEN ALSO THE
POINTS ON THE COST RECOVERY
BCPL SUMMER. THE RESIDENTIAL
CLEAN UP EASY PASY REQUESTED
INPUT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO
CLINICAL OF THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
THE PROJECT
THE EXPECTED FUNDS HAVE GONE TO
ACTIVITIES THAT DIRECTLY
BENEFIT CLEAN UP SUCH A IT'S A
IN ADDITION TO BEING EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
IT'S AN EXCELLENT RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. WE CURRENTLY STAND
AT ABOUT TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
PROPERTIES WHICH IS- THE PACE
OVERALL IS CLEANING UP MORE
PROPERTIES MORE QUICKLY THAN
ANY OTHER- BUT LET. PROJECT IN
THE COUNTRY. FOR THE FUNDS
REQUESTED IN THE- EXCITERS
INITIAL- CLEAR PCP WOULD GET US
TO THIRTY TWO HUNDRED. A TOTAL.
WE WILL NOW TO THE COST
RECOVERY B. C. B. OF THE
CONTRIBUTION HE REQUESTS A
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE. MILLION
DOLLARS TO HOLD RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE STRUGGLING
SAID- THE COST TO COVER IN ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES EXTREMELY COMPLEX
ENDEAVOR IT JUST IS. MADE EVEN
MORE SO IN THIS INSTANCE BY
BEING. I'M NATION CLEANING
CONTAMINATION IN AN URBAN
ENVIRONMENT. SO THE REQUEST-
ASK FOR ABOUT THIRTEEN DOLLARS
FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL-
EXPENSES- A MILLION DOLLARS FOR
OUTSIDE COUNSEL AND A TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR TO
TNCS LEGAL COSTS. WERE IN COURT
FIGHTING TO HOLD RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE- WE REALIZE
THAT THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO.
BUT THE FUNDS IN THIS REQUEST
WILL HELP US GET THERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YEAH I YEAH I
THINK EVERYBODY SORT OF QUICK
CANDIDLY SAYS EXIDE EXIDE EXIDE
EXCITED THEY REALLY ONLY
OPERATE THAT FACILITYFOR
FIFTEEN YEARS THERE WAS
SOMEBODY ELSE IN THERE FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT YEARS. AND WHILE
WE HAD THEM AS A PARTY IN THE
BANKRUPTCY AND THEY WERE THE
OPERATOR AT THE END. IT'S HARD
TO LOOK THAT LEGACY
CONTAMINATION AND PUT IT ALL ON
ON ON THEIR CLOCK- AS SO. I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATED. BENEFITS
THE WORK THAT HAS TO BE DONE-
AND ALSO THE PORTION TO GET
THOSE THE LAST. THREE HUNDRED
HOMES THREE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
HOMES- I CLEANED UP THE STAFF
REPORT TALKS ABOUT JUNE TWENTY.
THIS JUNE EXHAUSTING THE FUNDS
THESE NEW FUNDS COMING IN- IN
THE PREPARATION WHAT'S THE TIME
LINE I DON'T KNOW IF I REMEMBER
READING AFFECT THAT THAT WE
WOULD GET THIS THE WHOLE THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED PROPERTIES. FOR
HALF. HELLO THE LAST REMAINING
PROPERTIES THE TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT PROPERTIES. YEAH
GOOD QUESTION I'M SURE SO WE
HAVE ANOTHER FUNDS TO GET US
INTO THE FALL AND TO CLEAN UP
AROUND. 285-028-6020 EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWENTY
HUNDRED SIXTY PROPERTIES- WE
WOULD STILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
WORK NEEDED THEREAFTER TO DO
CLOSE OUT FOR THE- CONTRACT IT
WORK THAT WE HAVE- PAID FOR.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS WOULD GO
INTO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
UNLIKELY SEPTEMBER OCTOBER-
WHAT'S GONNA BE DIFFERENT
CLOTHES AT WORK WOULD BE NEEDED
FOR FACT CONTRACT. MARTIN
ASTERISK PUT ON THAT- THESE
THESE- KIND OF DATES IS. THE
PACE I SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER
HUSBANDS VERY SEVERELY
RESTRICTED BECAUSE OF CALVET
WILDFIRES- ANY NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME UP- THE WORLD
WELL CREATED WITH- OVER THE
LAST YEAR SO- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO RAMPING UP AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN- BUT GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
YOU KNOW CONDITIONS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST- WHERE WERE.
THAT PROJECTING- IT PASSED THE
CURRICULAR OF NEXT YEAR BUT-
BUT WE'LL SEE WHAT THE FUTURE
BRINGS. PRESUMABLY THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE SO FAR HAVE
BEEN AT THE WE'RE GOING THAT
MILE POINT SEVEN AWAY FROM THE
PLANT THE OR THE CLOSEST WORK
HAS BEEN DONE THESE ARE THE
ONES THESE ARE THE PROPERTIES
THAT DON'T MEET THE- EIGHT
PARTS PER MILLION- FOR THE LEAD
SCREENING. I'VE BEEN AND ARE
LOCATED IN THAT BAND AT THIS
GOES OUT TO ONE POINT SEVEN
RIGHT I MEAN I'M NAIVELY
PRESUMING THAT THE INTENSITY OF
THE CLEAN UP THOUGH. I GOT IT
ANY AMOUNT OF LEAD IS A BAD MN
A LEAD BUT IT'S NOT AS MUCH AS
IT WAS THE PERSON RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET. IS THAT CORRECT.
YEAH THE- THE SO YOU'RE RIGHT
THE ONE POINT SEVEN MILES
AROUND THE- FACILITY IS KIND OF
THE PROJECT AREA. WE HAVE
PURSUANT TO- KIND OF GOOD
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY WHAT DID
THOSE PARTIALS TO CLEAN UP THAT
HAVE THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF LEAD
AND GRACE FIRST RISK OF
EXPOSURE FIRST. LED AN URBAN
ENVIRONMENT- THAT'S BEEN
DISPERSED BY SANTA ANA WINDS I
REDEVELOPMENT OTHER OTHER
ACTIVITIES I FACILITY
OPERATIONS TRUCKING AT SENTARA.
IT'S NOT EVENLY DISTRIBUTED- SO
WE'VE BEEN STARTING AT THE HOT
THE AREAS WITH THE HIGHEST
LEVELS THE PARTIALS WITH
HIGHEST LEVELS AND THEN JUST
WORKING OUR WAY DOWN. AND HOW
DOES THAT WORK FOR OTHER
INSTANCE OF LEAD YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE HAVE LED-
PAINT. AND YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE
IN THESE AREAS PAINTED THEIR
HOUSES WITH LEAD PAINT AND IS
THAT IS THAT DUST. HILL HAD
BEEN NEGLECTED AND THAT MOVES
HOW DO YOU GET HOW DO YOU MAKE
A DETERMINATION THAT THIS WAS
CAUSED BY XIV'S THIS WAS
CAUSED. BY THIS BAD HOUSE
MANAGEMENT OR OTHER KEY TO
PRESERVE YOUR HOUSE. EXCELLENT
QUESTION THAT'S A IT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION- WE ANALYZE
LEVELS OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
METALS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED.
WITH I'M EXCITED OPERATIONS.
AND HAVE TAKEN EXTRA STAMP
THROUGHOUT THE AREA. FINALLY
I'M EXCITED IMPACTS. THAT BEING
SAID WE DO COORDINATE WITH- LOS
ANGELES WHO HAS A LEAD PAINT
REMEDIATION PROGRAM. TO TRY AND
LISTICLE ADDRESS BOTH INDOOR-
LEAD LEVELS AS WELL AS- LEAD IN
SOIL I FROM EXCITED ABOUT BOTH
IMPORTANT I SEE LOOKING AT KTM
OR ARSENIC OR OTHER TOXIC
CENTER IN THERE THAT WOULD ONLY
APPLY TO EXIDE. VERSUS HOUSTON.
SHERMAN WILLIAMS. THAT'S RIGHT
FIVE CENTER DOLLY. I KNOW UNDER
TIME RESEARCHERS FROM QUICKLY
WANTED I RECALL. TWEET THE
LEGISLATURE FRONT LOADED THE
MONEY YEAH. AND THEN THERE WAS
A FEE PUT ON BATTERIES THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BACK FILL THAT
RESOURCE WHERE WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THAT IS INTO A POT OF
MONEY THAT SUPPOSED TO GO INTO
CLEANING UP THOSE PROPERTIES.
YES SENATOR- VERY GOOD QUESTION
VERY GOOD MEMORY- SOME OF THE
FUNDS REQUESTED ARE GOING TO
PAY FOR. ON THE ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE DESCRIBING AND THE-
REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR THE
SPECIES. AND THAT THOSE FUNDS
ARE ACTUALLY ALSO BEING USED BY
THE DEPARTMENT TO STAND UP THE
LEAD ACID BATTERY INVESTIGATION
CLEANUP PROGRAM- THERE'S BEEN A
SEVERAL ROUNDS OF LEGISLATION
ON ON THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
BUT WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS DOING
INVESTIGATIONS NOW- IN THE LA
AREA AROUND THE FACILITY AND-
WELCOME CURRENTLY WORKING ON
INVESTIGATIONS RELATED TO OTHER
SITES WHERE WE'D LIKE TO GET ON
THE FIELD AND ACTUALLY DO
SAMPLING. I'M ON THE GROUND.
OKAY I'M NOT SEEING ANY OTHER
HANDS WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS
MATTER OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE- OUR
STAFF WILL- SUCH AS- CONTINUE
TO TALK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FIND OUT- WE GET TO. A CLEARER
VIEW ON THAT AND TAKE OUR
ACTION LATER LET'S GO TO THIS
WERE A WHOLE THAT ITEM THIS
CONDITION NUMBER EIGHTEEN. THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES AND
RECYCLING RECOVERY DIRECTOR
WAGNER THIS IS YOUR FIRST A
PRESENTATION TO THE COMMITTEE-
WELCOME AND YOU HAVE YOUR
ASKING FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PILOT PROGRAM PLEASE
PROCEED. MORNING TERM MEMBERS
IT IS SO GOOD TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING- THANK YOU SO MUCH I AM
I WILL KEEP MY REMARKS VERY
BRIEF THIS MORNING I KNOW YOU
ALL HAVE HAD. A VERY LONG
MORNING AND AS YOU KNOW CAL
RECYCLE PLAYS A VERY IMPORTANT%
ROLE IN ACHIEVING OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY EQUITY AND CLIMATE
GOALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OUTLINES HOW SUCCESSFUL
CALIFORNIA CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
AND WILL CREATE JOBS REDUCE
WASTE AND SHE CRITICAL SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE AT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS I'M WITH THE AVERAGE
AG CALIFORNIA GENERATOR- HE'S
BEEN CALIFORNIA GENERATING OVER
A TON OF TRASH EACH YEAR A
LENT- AND LANDFILL WASTE BEING
THE THIRD LARGEST SOURCE OF
METHANE. IT IS CRITICAL TO GET-
OUR PROGRAMS HERE IT COVERS I
GO BACK ON TRACK I HAD TO MEET
OUR WASTE REDUCTION RECYCLING
GOALS I'M BOTH THE BCPS BEFORE
YOU TODAY ARE AIMED AT DOING
JUST THAT THE FIRST OF WHICH AS
YOU MENTIONED SHARE IS THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- EARLY ACTION
ITEM. AND OR AT AN EXPANSION OF
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAMS PILOT
PROJECTS AS YOU AS MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE AND YOU AND HAVE
EXPERIENCED. IN YOUR DISTRICTS
I'M- RECYCLE REDEMPTION OP.
HAVE DISCRETE INCREASED AND
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND HAVE BEEN
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY THE
COBIT PANDEMIC- THIS PILOT
PROJECTS. AND EXPANSION WILL
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSIST THOSE JURISDICTIONS IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE
TO PROVIDE REDEMPTION
OPPORTUNITIES I HAD TO
CONSUMERS- AND RURAL SUBURBAN
AND URBAN AREAS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNDERSERVED.
EXCELLENT I WILL NOTE ON PAGE
THIRTY FOUR OF THE STAFF REPORT
WE HAVE A LITTLE CHART OF THE
300-300-0900 AND SIXTY SEVEN.
CONVENIENCE SOUNDS WE'RE
MISSING ANOTHER BULLET THAT
WOULD BE THE EXAM CONVENIENCE
SUNSET THE THOUSAND AND ONE AND
THEN THAT WOULD ACTUALLY ADD UP
THAT WOULD GET A 100% WE'VE
MISSED A LITTLE NUMBER THERE SO
THAT'LL BE GOOD- LET'S SEE
ALEJO. MISTER BROWN YOU'RE BACK
GOOD MORNING AGAIN- SO- JUST TO
KIND OF LEVEL SAID A LITTLE BIT
JUST TO MAKE SURE THE
COMMITTEES CLEAR SO THAT
PROPOSAL IS FOR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT YEAR AS
WELL AS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR WHICH WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO EXPAND THE PILOTS
CURRENTLY THERE ARE- THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY PROVIDED
FIVE MILLION IN THE PREVIOUS
YEAR TO. IMPLEMENT UP TO FIVE I
WOULD SWITCH THE DEPARTMENT IS
DOING NOW- AND SO THIS WOULD
ADD ANOTHER. TEN MILLION AND
WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
EXPAND FROM FIVE PILOTS TO SEND
PILOTS OUT OF TIME- SO WE THINK
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION FROM
FIVE PILOTS TO UP TO TEN PILOTS
HAS A LOT OF MERIT AND IS IT IS
KIND OF A REASONABLE EXPANSION
AND I THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
EXPLORE. ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIFFERENT
RETENTION MODELS IN DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY ISSUES OR CONCERNS WITH
THAT I THINK OUR MAIN CONCERN
IS WAS JUST THE SCALE OF THE
FUNDING REQUEST ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT EXPANSION- AGAIN THERE'S A
CURRENTLY THERE OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY PROVIDED
FIVE MILLION FOR FIVE PILOTS
THIS WOULD BE. A TEN MILLION
FOR FIVE MORE PILOTS SO IT'S
KIND OF DOUBLE THE FUNDING FOR
PILOTS- AND SO WE DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S REALLY JUST
PROPORTIONAL WITH KIND OF THE
EXPANSION IS BEING REQUESTED NO
THE MINISTRATIONS INDICATED%
THAT PERHAPS SOME OF THE MONEY
WOULD BE USED TO EXTEND SOME
PILOTS AND- THAT MIGHT BE
REASONABLE IN SOME CASES BUT WE
THINK KIND OF PROVIDING
FUNDING. IT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR EXTENSION AS LITTLE BIT
PREMATURE UNTIL I KIND OF WE
GET TO THAT POINT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKES AN
ARGUMENT ABOUT THE FUNDING DOES
NEED TO BE EXTENDED AND THAT
COULD BE REVISITED- IN AT A
FUTURE DATE SO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ARE TO
REDUCE THE FUNDING TO FIVE
MILLION TOTAL INSTEAD OF TEN
MILLION- SIMILAR TO- ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS ITEMS WE DON'T FEEL
THAT THERE'S ARE PARTICULARLY
STRONG CASE FOR IT IS NEEDING
TO BE EARLY ACTION IN THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING NOT FIVE
MILLION. JUST AS IT'S KIND OF
OVERALL A BUDGET YEAR PACKAGE
AND THAT WOULD ALLOW IT TO
EXPLORE SOME. OF THE DETAILS OF
HOW THAT THE TIONAL PILOTS TO
BE AMPLE. WHAT YOU'RE A- SAY.
THE MIGHT BE ABLE. AND TYPES OF.
MODEL MIGHT BE A- AND THEN.
WERE RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS- REPORTING
LANGUAGE- AS PART OF BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION- OUR
INTENT HERE IS NOT TO CREATES.
A LOT OF ADDITIONAL WORK FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO GIVEN THAT
THESE ARE. HIGHLIGHTS ONE OF
THE MAIN GOALS IS TO EVALUATE
HOW EFFECTIVE SOME OF THESE
DIFFERENT MODELS ARE. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE COLLECTING
INFORMATION ON RETENTION RATES
AND COSTS OF THE PILOTS AND- I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
INFORMATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. TO HAVE GOING
FORWARD AS IT CONSIDERS WHETHER
OR NOT TO EXPAND SOME OF THESE
MODELS- MORE BROADLY. THE STATE
AND SO I MEAN SOME REPORTING
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT SOME OF
THOSE OUTCOMES OF THE
LEGISLATURE CANNABINOID
PERMISSION WE THINK. OTHERWISE
THIS WILL BE SANTA MONICA ALL
OVER AGAIN I WOULD SAY THE
FIRST OF ON BEFORE WE GET TO
CENTER DOLLY- THIRTY WAGNER OR-
FINANCE. ANY PROBLEM ON THE
REQUEST FOR REPORTING LANGUAGE
AND HOLD MY HAND HERE OF. OF
ONE FIVE MORE AND LET'S SEE
WILL WILL DEAL WITH THE MONEY
LATER HOW DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
THE EARLY ACTION VERSUS THE
REGULAR. YEAR WE'RE HERE.
FEBRUARY MARCH WHAT WOULD BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH EARLY ACTION
VERSUS JUST WAITING TILL JULY
ONE. ED THANK YOU TERRAE
CASSIDY AND SO. TWO THINGS ON
THAT FIRST IF I COULD TAKE THAT
AND THAT THE LARGER
APPROPRIATION FIRST AND THE
REASON THE DEPARTMENT IS ASKING
FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS TO
ALLOW US THE FLEXIBILITY TO
EITHER GO BACK TO SOME OF THE
EXISTING PILOT PROJECTS- AND
EXPANDS THOSE OR TO ALLOW THESE
ADDITIONAL FIVE PILOT PROJECTS
TO BE FUNDED A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
LEVEL DEPENDING ON WHAT TYPES
OF. EITHER TECHNOLOGY OR
REGIONS THAT ARE BEING SERVED
WE HAVE SOME JURISDICTIONS THAT
ARE INDIVIDUAL CITIES AND THEN
LIKE IN CINEMA COUNTY WE HAVE
FIVE CITIES THAT ARE WORKING
TOGETHER AND YOU HAD
IMPLEMENTED A PILOT PROJECT AND
ALLOWING US A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
LEVEL OF FUNDING WOULD ALLOW US
FLEXIBILITY TO DO MORE REGIONAL
SOLUTIONS AS OPPOSED TO TRYING
TO- HE SAT TOGETHER WITH
INDIVIDUAL JURISDICTIONS. AND
THE EARLY ACTION ITEM WAS
SPECIFICALLY ASKED FOR BECAUSE
WE HAVE CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LIKE
THE NORTH COAST THAT ARE
CURRENTLY COMPLETELY I'M SERVE
THEIR CONVENIENCE THE CLOSEST
CONVENIENCE DOWN SERVICE- TO
HUMBOLDT COUNTY RIGHT NOW IS IN
CINEMA COUNTY- THE CLOSEST OPEN
TRANSFER FACILITY IS UP AND
CRESCENT CITY AT SO WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OPEN UP THE GRANT PROGRAM AGAIN
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. TO WORK
WITH THOSE REGIONS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE CURRENTLY COMPLETELY
UNSERVED OR SEVERELY
UNDERSERVED AND WE CANNOT DO
THAT UNTIL WE RECEIVE THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO THAT AND THE
FUNDING TO- APPROVED THOSE
BRANDS. SENATE ALWAYS HAVE
SOMETHING SAY ON A COMMUNITIES
YEAH. THE BASIC AT THE END OF
YOUR COMMERCE THERE'D ADDRESSED
WHAT I WANT I DEFINITELY THINK
YOU NEED ONE RULERS AYE. I KNOW
CENTER REQUIRED I HAVE A
DISTRICT TO LOOK ALIKE AND
THERE IS A ZERO SERVICE SO THEY
NEEDED TO DEFINITELY I SEE
DAILY- SAID THERE WAS MERIT
SIND INTO DOING A RULED PART OF
IT I THINK WE SHOULD ADD TO GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT AS WELL.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THIS
ITEM OPEN WHICH ARE. ONLY SIX.
ONLY CENTER MCGUIRE VERY QUICK
AND IT JUST FIRST AND FOREMOST
I JUST WANT TO SAY.
CONGRATULATIONS THE DIRECTOR.
AND REALLY APPRECIATED
DIRECTORS- DIRECT INVOLVEMENT
IN SOME OF THESE ISSUES- IT'S A
BREATH OF FRESH AIR. ALL OF THE
VERY QUICKLY SECURE AND JUST
SAY THIS. THE REDEMPTION ISSUE
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA. IT'S A HOT
MESS. HOTNESS AND IT'S BEEN A
HOT MESS. UP FOR A FEW YEARS
NOW. IT WOULD APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTORS APPROACH IS NOT
LOOKING AT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH. IN UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE. A FEW COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT ARE
IN LINE THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
BRING FORWARD A SUCCESSFUL
PROJECT. IT WOULD HOPE. I AND I
KNOW THE CHAIR IS WORKING WITH
THE DIRECTOR. BUT I WOULD HOPE-
THAT WE COULD LOOK AT EARLIER
ACTION BEFORE JUNE- AND NOT
WAIT TODAY BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THERE ARE. WILLING ENTITIES GO
TO MOVE FORWARD ON A CREATIVE
SOLUTION THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHER. IS HER THERE WERE
MORE APPLICANTS THAN THAN FIVE
THAT REQUIRE FUNDED ON THEIR
CURRENT. OF BILINGUAL. TOUGHER
OKAY. THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY ARE
WE WILL KEEP YOUR ARTICLE NO WE
WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
PROVIDING LEGISLATIVE REPORTING
AND AS A LONG TIME AS YOU KNOW
A LONG TIME POLICY WONK AND THE
TRUE SUCCESS AND VALUE OF A
PILOT PROJECT IS BEING ABLE TO.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS IN A PILOT
PROJECT IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
EVALUATE WHETHER OR NOT THAT IS
A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THANK YOU
ON THAT LET'S MOVE TO THE HI AT
THE NEXT ORGANIC WASTE
REDUCTION PROGRAM AND THE COST
OF IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNT. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH TERRY HOUSEKI
AND AS YOU KNOW- SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR LARA
WAS PASSED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN-
REQUIRING A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
MEASURES TO CONTROL ORGANIC
WASTE. AND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HERE AND HOW WE'RE
CYCLE WE ARE FOCUSED. ON
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION FROM
LANDFILLS AND ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING AND THIS ECP. AND
PROPOSES TRANSFERRING THIRTY
EIGHT OUR CONDITIONS FROM OUR
ARMED LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
YOU ARE ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AND
CREATING AND YOU ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH WITHIN- OUR ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION- THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
AIMED. AT COMPLIANCE AND WITH
THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REGULATIONS THAT WE ADOPTED AT
THE END OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
TWENTY TWENTY EXCUSE ME. TWENTY
TWENTY AND- ALSO ASKS FOR NINE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO HELP
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE REGULATIONS. I KNOW THAT
AND THE AT COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
GOES INTO SOME DETAIL ABOUT
CONCERN AROUND- LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND I'M NOT HAVING A
SERVICES AS SALEABLE TO YOU AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. THE WAY
THE DEPARTMENT TRULY LOOKS AT
THIS B. C. P. AS THAT WE ARE
MOVING FROM A PHASE- OF WORKING
WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE
REGULATIONS. TO THE POINT IN
WHICH WE NEED TO START FOCUSING
ON COMPLIANCE AS YOU ALL WELL
KNOW OUR FIRST COMPLIANCE
DEADLINE. AND IS- IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- AND OUR GOAL IS TO
HIT AND 50% REDUCTION IN OUR
ORGANIC WASTE BELOW OUR TWENTY
FOURTEEN BASED CLIENT AND WE
ARE ACTUALLY CURRENTLY RIGHT
NOW ABOVE OUR TWENTY FOURTEEN
BASELINE. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU ALSO KNOW
THOSE TARGETS ARE A STATE WIDE
TARGET THEY ARE NOT
JURISDICTION BY JURISDICTION
AND SO IT'S REALLY COMING UPON
US THAT COVERS CYCLE WITH YOU
IN THE LEGISLATURE. ADULTS YOU
AND PUT TOGETHER A COMPLIANCE
PACKAGE AND THAT GETS THE
ENTIRE STATE WHERE WE NEED TO
GO BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
THEN ARE 75% REDUCTION GOAL BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND WE ARE
VERY FOCUSED ON DOING THAT.
VERY GOOD L. A. YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO SHED SOME LIGHT ON
WE'RE ACTUALLY ABOVE HER TWENTY
FOURTEEN. OF COMPLIANCE LEVELS
SO WE GOT SOME WAY AWAY TO GO.
DOWN WITH AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE BUDGET
REQUEST- THE RESOURCES ARE TO
IMPLEMENT A LEGISLATION AND
SORT OF ACCOMPANYING
REGULATIONS SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS. THIS IS FOR THE
GOOD COP BAD COP THESE
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS WILL BE THE
GOOD COPS COME IN THERE AND YOU
KNOW NOT DO THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT HELP. PEOPLE GET
TO THE RIGHT PLACE ON THE
VERSION. OKAY THE SEEING NO
HANDS. FINANCE ANYTHING. WE'LL
GET A HOLD THIS MATTER. AS WE
DID RIGHT AND YOU ARE
STRUGGLING TO FINANCE NOTHING
TO ADD I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. I DON'T SEE ANY- MR
MARTZ SILVA I'M GOING TO. WE
BELIEVE THIS AT MATTER OPEN AND
HOLD IT WE HAVE SOME PUBLIC-
COMMENTS- THAT WE HAVE TO START
SO. I WILL. HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF-
THREE- IDMS. OKAY WE'LL NOW
MOVES TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ANY OF THESE ANY OF
THESE ITEMS IS ITEMS THIRTEEN
THROUGH NINETEEN OR ANY OF THE
ONES THAT WE'RE GOING TO VOTE
ON I GUESS YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT AS A REMINDER THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FORTY ACCESS CODE IS
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN SIX OH NINE
DO THESE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. THE
CREATURES WHICH IS ME IN THIS
INSTANCE MAYES TO TALK. TIME
LIMITS ON TESTAMENT TODAY I'M
GOING TO ASK EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. REDUCE THE REMARKS TWO
ONE MINUTE LET US KNOW WHAT
ITEM THEY ON WE'RE ACCEPTING
EMAILS AND LETTERS YOU CAN GO
IN SO NOW LET'S LOOK AT- THE
HEARING ROOM ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS HERE IN PUBLIC AND
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE LET'S
GO TO ROOM ONE ONE TWO IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE- ONE ONE TWO I
SEE NOBODY THERE. THE THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
PARTICIPATING A PUBLIC COMMENT
THROUGH THE TELECONFERENCE
ERVAS MODERATOR. PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WE MAKE IT RIGHT
PUBLIC COMMENTS TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A LEADING GERMAN
THE FORMER IF YOU WISH TO- HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
EIGHTEEN HE'S GOING TO GIVE
YOUR- FLIGHT NUMBER OFFLINE SO
YOU'LL YOU CAN IDENTIFY WHEN
YOU READY FOR YOUR QUESTION SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. GO
AHEAD. OUR FIRST QUESTION TODAY
COMES FROM WINE. FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD FORTY FOUR.
YOUR HONOR. FORTY FOUR. FORTY
FOUR PLEASE REVIEW I THINK YOU
TOOK YOURSELF OUT OF THE QUEUE
BY HITTING THE NUMBER AGAIN
WE'LL GO TO TWENTY ONE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD TWENTY ONE. YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO. JULIAN ALLEN
ASKED ME ABOUT THE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION
SEEKING TO ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. HOW EACH TEAM
WOULD JUST LIKE TO EXPRESS THAT
THE COURT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL INVEST FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION CAP AND
TRADE FUND. SHOULD STAND THE
SENSIBILITY INTO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. YOU KNOW VERY WELL
THAT THAT THE NEEDS CENTRAL
DOCUMENT AND IT'S ABSOLUTE BUT
IT'S ALSO THE ABSOLUTE MINIMUM
FUNDING REQUIRED. TO ACCELERATE
AND DECARBONIZE OUR
TRANSPORTATION AND GOOD. ACTORS
I THINK YOU YOU KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF
TRANSFORMING- AND THE
TRANSPORTATION FACTORED IN
THEIR MISSION MOBILITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
TRANSFORMATION PROVIDES FOR THE
AND ENVIRONMENT IN BACK. IN NAM
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO RECOMMEND
HOWEVER THAT- THAT WE RESTORE
THE FUNDING FOR LIGHT DUTY
THERE ARE MISSION VEHICLES THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM
OUR CD R. P. THIS YEAR AT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AT BASELINE- I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT THE-
LEGISLATURE HAS ARCTIC AIR
RESOURCES BOARD G. REVIEW.
FUNDING FOR ALL THE LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
ANNUALLY THEY DO THAT A COUPLE
OF ROBUST PUBLIC PROCESS AND
NOT LATEST RECORD DOES NOT
STATE THAT WE NEED TO STOP
FUNDING THE V. R. P. THIS YEAR
IN FACT IT DOES NOT WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHEN THEY NEED TO
FACT FINDING OUT THAT I DON'T
THINK HE REPORT DOESN'T SAY
THAT. THIS IS THE YEAR THAT WE
BEAR OUT. VERY SUCCESSFUL. AND
THEN ONE MORE TIME ON BEHALF OF
THE- PRIMARY ENERGY ALLIANCE
THANK YOU. A PROPER- FORTY
HEALTHY IN RECENT FOR PROGRAM
AND THE G. YEAR AFTER PUT. FOR
YEAH THIS IS A FEW LOW GREEDY
PRO THAT IS EXACTLY OUT. DOT
HAD NAY. AND WHAT WE- STOP THE-
FROM THE CAST IN THE FOR. AND
IF IS A- EARLY ACT MEASURE
WHICH SHOULD BE FUNDING. THANK
YOUNG. ARCNET. WE'LL GO BACK
ONE FOR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FORTY FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD.
YES GREAT THANK YOU SHARE WHITE
HOUSE SKIS SENATORS DOLLY.
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK WE READ THE STATE IN
THE NATION AND WORKING WITH
HARD TO REACH BUSINESSES TO
CREATE A VIBRANT GREEN ECONOMY
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX WE'VE
OFFERED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND ECONOMIC INCENTIVES TO HELP
BUSINESS OWNERS IMPROVE THEIR
BOTTOM LINE. PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT EXPAND THE WORK
FORCE AND PROVIDE A GREEN
MARKET PLACE FOR CONSUMERS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
FUNDING FROM THE STATE FOR THE
PAST THREE FUNDING CYCLE. HAS
ALLOWED US NOT ONLY HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES OPERATE MORE
SUSTAINABLY. BUT TO HELP THEM
BUILD RESILIENCE MANY OF OUR
FORTY TWO GREEN BUSINESS
PROGRAMS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
HAD PIVOTED TOWARD BUSINESS
RECOVERY. ASSISTING WITH KOBE
BUSINESS SAFETY PROVIDING
ENERGY AND WATER CONSERVING
RETROFITS DURING DOWNTIME AND
VITAL INFORMATION ON EVERYTHING
FROM GRANTS MODELS THEY FOR
DISINFECTION. WELL OUR LONG
TERM GOAL IS TO COVER THE
ENTIRE STATE ANSWER FIVE FORTY
THOUSAND BUSINESSES LIKE TWENTY
FIFTY. OR MORE IMMEDIATE GOAL
IS TO CREATE A NEW NORMAL WEAR
VULNERABLE BUSINESSES GAIN TE
GREEN BUSINESS ADVANTAGE TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC. AND
CONSUMERS ARE GUIDED TO VOTE
WITH THEIR DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
BUSINESSES THAT OPERATE MORE
SUSTAINABLY. NOW IS NOT THE
TIME TO PULL THE PLUG ON
POGRAMS TO HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE BUSINESSES. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL INITIATIVES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND FOR
SUPPORTING A GREEN BUSINESS
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AND OUR ECONOMY
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NEXT. A LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
OPERATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. I WONDER IF IT COULD
WEIGH IN ON THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL- PORTION OF THE CAPITAL
EXPENDITURE PLAN TO URGE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO. KEEP THAT
APPROPRIATIONS PACKED- I DON'T
HAVE TO TELL. EVERYBODY ELSE
CALLED ME PROBABLY KNOW THAT-
OVER FIVE THOUSAND JOBS. ARE
BEING CREATED RIGHT NOW
CONSTRUCTION JOBS NOT TO
MENTION THE THOUSANDS OF OTHER
JOBS IN THE- SECONDARY-
MARKETS. RELATED TO SUPPLYING
OF THIS PROJECT- WE ALSO HAVE A
FINELY AND MINISTRATION IN
WASHINGTON DC THESIGNALED ARE
RENEWED SUPPORT AND HOPEFULLY
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROJECT- ON THE RIGHT TRACK. IT
IS CREATING JOBS AND HELPING
THE ECONOMY CENTRAL VALLEY
WHILE ALSO PREPARING THE- OTHER
PORTIONS OF THE SYSTEM FOR. THE
NEAR FUTURE ADOPTION OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL THERE AS WELL SO
IT'S A PROJECT IT IS PAYING
DIVIDENDS CALIFORNIA. AND TO
CALIFORNIANS ALREADY- WE URGE
YOU TO KEEP IN THE PLAN NOT
MAKE ANY CHANGES TO THE
CORPORATION THANK. YOU THANK
YOU ZACKS. CARRILLO TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE MOVING
ALONG A LITTLE LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP HARD WITH THE
WESTERN CAPE CONTROLLING THE
SITUATION I'M AND I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN. I'M AND I CAN START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
ADDRESSING THE TOPIC OF THE
SCOPING PLAN CAP AND TRADE
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A FULL VIEW OF
HOW THE STATE AND TO ME IT'S
KIND OF COLD. AND WE CAN THAT
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOUR CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT DURING THE SCOPING
PLAN TO INSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTED IN THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS.
THAT WE DO HOWEVER ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE TO PROCEED WITH
CAUTION IF YOU TO PASS A
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES BUT CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM AND AS YOU
KNOW TOMORROW THE FIRST AUCTION
UNDER THE NEWLY RE OPERATE
PROGRAM AND- THEY ARGUED DURING
THE CONVERSATION DRUNK AGRAD
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES. COULD
HAVE POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THE RESULT OF THAT IN
FUTURE AUCTIONS. AND ADDS THE
CONTINUE THESE CONVERSATIONS
THAT YEAR WE REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT AS WE ENTER THE
SECOND PHASE OF THE PROGRAM
THANK HAPPEN THE KLEIN
AGGRESSIVELY AS OUTLINED BY
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD AND- I'VE
ALSO MENTIONED BY HAND
CONTEMPLATING CHANGES TO A
PROGRAM THAT HAD JUST BEGUN
THIS NEW PHASE. IT'S PREMATURE
INTENT THE WRONG SIGNAL TO THE
MARKET PARTICIPANTS AND TRADING
PARTNERS- THAT SAID WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE STEPPING PLAN
DEVELOPED TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
MEETING OUR SHARED GOALS. IN A
EQUITABLE AND COST AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE THANK
YOU AS THE. Y. NEXT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON YOU
HEAR ME. YEAH YOU'RE ON GO HEAD
YES. HELLO GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU TERAWATT COPY NUMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE STEVEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF CAL START FOR THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION MY COMMENTS ARE IN
REGARDS TO ISSUE FIFTEEN THE
CAP AND TRADE. EXPENDITURE
POINT. HOW START ONE SIX OUR
STRONG SUPPORTER DEFINITIONS
PROPOSED BUDGET WHICH TO INVEST
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE MEDIA FUNDING FOR THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
CORES THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
AN OPERATOR QUITMAN THANKS HE
CLEAN CRAMPED TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE HYBRID AND
ZERO EMISSION TRUCK AND BUS
SHELTER INITIATIVE. PROJECT
WHICH IS THE A TRIP PROGRAM.
WHAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET WE URGE THAT
CVR PETE BE RESTORED IN THE
BUDGET IT'S A CRITICAL MULTI
YEAR FUNDING MECHANISM THAT
INCREASES MEDIUM AND LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. AND FLEETS
ACCESSIBILITY PRESENTS. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION WHICH
SUPPORT THE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. OF CAP
AND TRADE AUCTION REVENUES TO
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO THE POINT.
THANK YOU SUPPORT THE PROPOSALS
THAT FOCUS ON EQUITY ESPECIALLY.
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS.
EXPRESSED A CONCERN. THAT THE
PROPOSED CULTURE OF. ET FUNDING
INVEST IN LOW INCOME. OR
DISADVANTAGED. THAT WILL ALSO
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT.
THE CHAIR LINE NUMBER FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE ZERO. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRENDAN TO AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION GIVEN THE ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES CALIFORNIANS FACING
THE HEALTH BASED AIR QUALITY
ATTAINMENT STANDARDS. USING
YOUR POLLUTION AND TOXIC IN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES WE APPRECIATE THAT
AIR QUALITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ARE PRIORITIZED FOR FUNDING IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
EXPENDITURE PLAN. WE ARE
PLEASED AB SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM IS PRIORITIZE WITH A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
EARLY ACTION FUNDING AND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR FOR
INCENTIVES TO CLEAN UP
POLLUTION IN. COMMUNITIES
ADDITIONALLY WE APPRECIATE
THERE IS FIFTY MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION HOWEVER WE MUST
NOTE THIS AMOUNT DOES NOT COVER
CURRENT COSTS ACCOUNT FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDED TO THE PROGRAM.
WE SUPPORT THE PRIORITIZATION
OF THE FARMER PROGRAM WOULD
NINETY MILLION IN INCENTIVES
FOR EARLY ACTION AN EIGHTY
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
LASTLY I'LL TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
EXPANDING CLEAN AIR PROGRAM
FUNDING THAT WAS RE AUTHORS I
RE AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY AB EIGHT. WHICH WAS
JOIN AUTHORED BY THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS PRAYER AND
SKINNER THESE PROGRAMS WHICH
INCLUDE THE CARL MOYER MEMORIAL
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS OF
PAYMENT PROGRAM AND AB NINE
TWENTY THREE LOCAL INCENTIVES
PROGRAM ARE CRITICAL TO MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR GOALS
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THAT
RECOGNITION AND COMMITMENT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. THE YOU X. WILL. WE
WILL LIVE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS ABSOLUTE CRAP
WITHOUT BECAUSE IT CAN BE A
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'LL BE SPEAKING TO
ISSUE FIFTEEN. WE APPRECIATE
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN WILL
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR AIR
DESTRUCTION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HOWEVER WE SEEK A HIGHER
LEVEL FUNDING IN LINE WITH
ACTUAL COST. NEW COMMUNITIES
ARE ADDED TO THIS PROGRAM EACH
YEAR REQUIREMENT INCREASED
EXISTING RESOURCES THIS FUNDING
IS CRITICAL TO PROTECT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
ALSO APPRECIATE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN AND
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR AIR
DISTRICTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THIS FUNDING WAS SORELY
MISSED LAST YEAR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS NEEDED TO ACCELERATE
DEPLOYMENT OF CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY THIS IS CRITICAL
GIVEN FINDINGS EXPOSURE TO AIR
POLLUTION COMBINED WITH COVERT
NINETEEN MAY INCREASE THAT'S
EXACERBATED NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS. SUCH CODES DESCRIPTION
FEDERAL GUIDELINES REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION I HAVE NOT MET
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INFECTIONS
RESTRICTIONS ON BUSINESS ON A
FEDERAL TAKEOVER COULD OCCUR.%
ONLY A SOUTH COAST THE
SUPPORTER OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
BUDGET ROLES TO REAUTHORIZE SHE
SOURCES OF AIR QUALITY FUNDING
ESPECIALLY AS A RELIGION CARL
MOYER PROGRAM AT. A TECHNICAL
CORRECTION BILLION TO CALM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
EXCELLENT TWO GO AHEAD. IT MORE
MY NAME IS CAPTAIN CRIMINAL THE
HELP STATE OF COUNTIES
RELENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT- CAL
COUNTIES WE WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
A COMMA ON THE REST COULD OF
THE AGENDA- ITEMS THE- WELL WE
SUPPORT THE CAN. UP TO RID WILD
RISK THINK HAPPENED TRADE FIVE
BUT CONCERNED ABOUT THE CAN
LACK OF FUNDING FOR ORGANIC
WITH GREAT WAITRESS. I YOU
HEARD THE MANDATE ORGANIC WAY
START NEAR THE BURDEN OF PAYING
FOR THIS FALLS ON RIGHT IS
AROUND. AND RIGHT TO STRETCH
THE LIMIT WITH MANY UNABLE TO
PAY BILLS TO COVER NINETEEN AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS ADDING DOLLARS
THEY'RE BUILT IN MIND IMPLEMENT
AT WHICH I CLING IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
HELP REDUCE THE BURDEN BY
FUNDING GRANT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IF THE COURT
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENTS FOR
THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM. OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
IMPLEMENTING THAT THEY ASK FOR
COMMONSENSE THE COURT. SAID SHE
OF THE STATE MANDATE. IN
ADDITION WE- HAVE BEEN AT THE
MOVE FROM POSITION FOR.
COMPLIANCE OF COURSE. OF LOCAL
LISTED WE THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MINISTER. MUCH
SHOULD THINK ABOUT OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS. AND
CONSIDER A- THIS SHIFT- IN A
FUTURE YEAR. A BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM
PILOT PROGRAM WE'RE SUPPORTIVE
OF THESE THEY'RE VERY USEFUL
BUT IN THAT TIME FRAME THAT
THEY WILL BE A FACTOR OF THREE
TO FIVE YEARS. WE NEED HELP
RIGHT NOW SO WE RECOMMEND YOU
REVIEW THE LETTER THAT WAS
RECEIVED FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COALITION OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA HELP THIRTIETH AND
SEE IF THAT WAS MY IMMEDIATE
PROGRAM CHANGES THAT CAN HAPPEN
RIGHT NOW. TO ACHIEVE-CONVENIENCE ON RECYCLING THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT. THANKS TO
CAROLINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE TOWN PARKING VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT THE
VALLEY FACES ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES IN THE COUNTRY AND
IS HOME TO TWENTY OF THE THIRTY
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. DEALING WITH THE
CURRENT MAINTAIN CRISIS HAS
BROUGHT UNPRECEDENTED PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGES TO OUR REGION
AND STATE RIGHT IN THE PANDEMIC
AS A STATE WE'VE SPENDING
PRIORITIES IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FOR ONGOING FUNDING
FOR AIR QUALITY EFFORTS GIVEN
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT THE AIR
POLLUTION POSES TO THE HEALTH.
OF COMMUNITIES DEALING WITH THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC THE
TYPICALLY THE DOCTOR GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS INCLUDED ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION IN GTR AT
FINDING FOR CLEAN I RECALL
TRULY COMMITMENT TO THE FARMER
PROGRAM FOR FARMER PROGRAM IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED WITH SIGNIFICANT
MATCH INVESTMENTS FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY SECOND
QUICKLY PROVIDE TREMENDOUS
ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS AND COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE FIFTY MILLION FOR
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM FUNDING-
WITH ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES CAN
CONTINUALLY ENTERING THE
PROGRAM AND ASSOCIATED COSTS
CONTINUING TO INCREASE IT WILL
BE IMPORTANT THAT. THE PATIENT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BE INCLUDED
IN FUTURE BUDGET PROPOSAL IN
ADDITION THE DISTRICT SUPPORT
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL EXPANDING
CLEAN AIR PROGRAM FUNDING THAT
WAS RE AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY EIGHTY EIGHT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL TO
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR
GOALS AND WE ARE CLOSED FOR
FUNDING FOR THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM AND OTHER LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. AS
WELL AS FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE
RESPONSE AND MITIGATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MAX.
TO ALLOW FIFTY FOUR GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING STACEY HE WITH THE
ROLE COUNTY REP OF RIGHT TWO
SEVEN ROW CAL STATEWIDE ALSO
SPEAKING TO IN NUMBER FIFTEEN
THE CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE
PLAN. ARE HERE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER A STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED%
ALLOCATIONS SB NINE A ONE BUT
THE REALLY ACTION AND FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THESE ACTIONS ARE VITAL TO
PREVENTION OF GHG AND BLACK
CARBON EMISSIONS FROM WILDFIRE
IN PROMOTION OF CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IN WILD LANDS IN
AND AROUND HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS. MANY OF WHICH ARE SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WE ALSO SUPPORT
PROPOSED ALLOCATIONS TO BUILD
HEALTHY SOILS AND THE FORMER
PROGRAMS TO REDUCE GHGS. FROM
AGRICULTURAL VEHICLES THANK YOU.
X. BORDERLINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SHARON
MEMBERS RACHAEL MARKETS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE
AND THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK SPEAKING ON
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO FUND THE HELP FILES
PROGRAMS AT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED BY SECRETARY
ROSS. WE ARE ALSO ASKING FOR
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM IT'S IMPORTANT CLIMATE
SMART AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS THE
NEAR IT OUT AS NOTED BY THE
CHAIR AND SENATOR MCGUIRE I
ALLOW MY COMMENTS TO THOSE MADE
IN THIS HEARING BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE OVER THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE BONDS. PARTICULARLY FOR
SMALL AND MID SCALE PRODUCERS
AND THE CONCERN THAT THE VERY
ARE NOT A POSITION TO TAKE ON
MORE DEBT AS OFFERED BY THE
CATALYST FUND. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT- A LINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS TO ENTER
AND CLICK HERE TO HELP THE HALF
OF THE ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY.
WE ARE A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION-
BASED MADE UP OF A ADVANCE
CLEAN ENERGY BUSINESSES. WE
SUPPORT THE FOCUS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON THE
APPROPRIATING FUNDING- IN ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
REDUCTION FONG AS PART OF THE
LARGER ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDED PROGRAM WE THINK THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
AMOUNT. IS A DOWN PAYMENT ON
OUR LARGER GOALS MATCHED IN THE
BANK WE THINK THIS INVESTMENT
TAKEN TOGETHER WITH THE GINGER
FUNDING WAS FOR MARKET
TRANSFORMATION. WE THINK THAT
LEGISLATION ENACTED A FEW YEARS
AGO BEING IMPLEMENTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION AB
TWO ONE TWO SEVEN. CONFIRMS YOU
KNOW BASED ON THEIR ASSESSMENT
OF THEIR TAKEN SYSTEMATICALLY
THAT WE NEED TO EXPAND IN ORDER
TO MAKE THIS TRANSFORMATION A
REALITY WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTY
SEVEN THOUSAND. CHARGERS AROUND
THE STATE CURRENTLY AND WE
SUPPORT WE AUTHORIZATION
SECURITIZATION OF FUTURE
REVENUES TOWARDS YOU KNOW
PROVIDING STABLE FUNDING FOR
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FOR A
PROGRAM. TO ALLOW THAT PROGRAM
TO REALLY SCALE- WE ALSO SOME
GINGER FONG. OR YOUR MEASURE
TRUCKS AND BUSES IN EVERY
REGION OF THE STATE EVERY THAT
LEGISLATURE RESTORE TO SEE THE
R. P. OUR ARE MAKING THAT
PROGRAM WIDELY AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS LOW INCOME MIDDLE
CLASS THE LIGHT. OF THE
CONCERNS ARE CRITICAL TO
BRINGING ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORTERS AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FR THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TO.
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WANTED TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE
TO POWER CYCLE PROPOSALS
FIRSTLY THE ITEM NINETEEN ON
ORGANIC WASTE PRODUCTION
IMPLEMENTATION. THIS NEW
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING PROGRAM
IS ONE OF THE MOST
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGES IN SOLID
WASTE MANAGEMENT DECADES THE
REGULATION FOR FORMALLY ADOPTED
IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR THAT
GIVES US THIS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TOOK THIRTEEN MONTHS TO
UNDERTAKE A HOST OF ACTIONS TO
ADOPT ORDINANCES- ESTABLISH NEW
RATES COLLECTION SERVICES
DEVELOP MEDICAL CREW RECOVERY
PROGRAMS AND OTHERS. THAT'S
JUST A MUCH FAR SHORTER TIME
BRINGING TWO YEARS WE
REGIONALLY ANTICIPATED THE
BEEKEEPING EXCEPT EXISTING
STAFF MULTIPLE SYSTEMS TO
ENFORCEMENT AND GIVEN THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PROGRAMS THE
NEED TO GET IT RIGHT THE FIRST
TIME THE EXTINGUISHER
IMPLEMENTATION TIME FRAME THIS
INNER STRENGTH COLLECTORS AND
PLACED ON US WE THINK IT'S
PREMATURE TO SHIP SO MANY
RESOURCES TO ENFORCEMENT. WELL
THESE PROGRAMS OR ANY OR ANY
FANCY SO WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO DELAY ADOPTION OF
THIS AND ALSO LOOK TO FURTHER
DISCUSS. THE POWER CYCLE
JURISDICTIONAL BETTER
REQUIREMENTS WE THINK THOSE
POWER CYCLE JURISDICTIONAL
BUSINESS ARE REALLY IMPERATIVE
TO- HELP COVER CYCLE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY- ENFORCE. AND THEN THE
SECOND ON THE PILOT CRAP. YOU
HAVE BATTERED SET. THAT YOU GO
OVER THE ONE YOU THIRTY SO LEFT
AND THEN AS YOU TO PLEASE WRAP
UP. I WILL BE EXTREMELY GROUP
STRONG WITH. THE PILOT GROWTH.
PROJECTS REQUIRE- THE TACTICAL
CHANGES WITH YOUR TO A COUPLE
OTHER CHAIN. THAT WE THINK
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO REDEMPTION
OPPORTUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN THE
NORTH STATE AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIS GOT OUR NEXT
CALLER MISTER MODERATOR. NEXT.
ONE FORTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
THANK FORTY ONE PLEASE. YEAH
YOU GET TERM. GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS MIGUEL STROMAL TO CALL THE
GROUP REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FROM MY
MOUTH ON BALANCE- CALLING IN
TODAY ON ITEM FOURTEEN MAR
SUPPORT- EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR
THE ECONOMY WIDE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACH TOWARDS
ACHIEVING OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION.
CALIFORNIA'S CAP AND TRADE IS
ONE OF THE ONLY ARMY WIDE
CARBON PRICES IN THE WORLD.
CONTINUE TO SPEAK THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND DEAL. STRUCK BY THE
GOVERNOR BIPARTISAN TWO THIRDS
OF THE LEGISLATURE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS UNIONS AND
COMPLIANCE AND IT WOULD
ENTITIES. NOTABLY VOTED ON BY
THREE OF THE FOUR MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE- IS THIS PROGRAM
THE MOST IDEAL PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND LATER
NOW BECAUSE WE HIGH- LOTS OF
COST CONTAINMENT LIKE OFF THE
PROVISIONS LONG WAS RAPIDLY
DECLINING INDUSTRY. THIS IS
FILE DOESN'T USUALLY A WAITING
FOR PRICE WILL EVENTUALLY HURT-
IT IS BETTER THAN THE
ALTERNATIVE YES AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT ALONG WITH ITS COMPANION
BILL EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
STRUCK A BALANCE OF MITIGATE
GREENHOUSE GASES OF THE CAPRI
PROGRAMS. AND REDUCES THEIR
QUALITY. ASIANS WITH ANY
LOCALLY- BASED EMISSIONS
REDUCTION PROGRAM. IN CONCERT
THESE BILLS WILL HELP IMPROVE
HEALTH IN COMMUNITIES AND
MITIGATE ON CHANGE. THE L. A.
RIVER MENTIONS PORTABLE
UNLIKABLE PROGRAMS. TODAY
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL PATENT TRADES
ARE THE ONLY LINK CLIMATE
PROGRAMS WORLDWIDE. POLITICALLY
CAP AND TRADE IN THE MOST
VIABLE POLICIES FOR
GOVERNMENT'S CORDED MEASURES
AGAINST. CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF
THE MOST RIGOROUS PROGRAMS. IN
THE WORLD- B. TEN H. REQUIRE
LINK ARE DIFFICULT AND IT OTHER
DRASTIC TO SHARE. IS SIMPLE
FACT THAT MOST RESTRICTIONS IN
THE UNITED STATES YOU'RE NOT
HAPPY SHE WAS HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT'S CRAZY. IN ADDITION TO
BEING ANY CHANGE TO THE PROGRAM
RESTRICTS ALLOWANCES WILL
INCREASE THIS ADDS TOO MANY
POSSIBILITIES CONSUMERS IN
RAIDERS OF THE COURSE OF
CHEATING OR CLIMB POLES WHY
SHOULD WE WANT TO AND- WHY
SHOULD WE WANT CLIMATE
MITIGATION HURT OUR PUBLIC
ANYMORE THAN THAT ABSOLUTELY
NEEDS TO IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THE CUMULATIVE THE NATIONAL
ACTION. DOES NEED TO TREAT YOU
THE STATE'S. I'M MISSION.
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE. PROGRAM
IN CAP AND TRADE- PROVIDE ONE
THE ONLY A WIDE PRICES. OUR
COMPETING STATES LACK NOT ONLY
THE ECONOMY WIDE PRICE OF SEMI
MARKET MECHANISM TRADING
PROGRAM ALSO LACKED ISSUED A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY. WHICH IS
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
BOOK OF JAIL STANDARDS FOR LIFE
ON THE STRATEGY AND MANY
OTHERS- ONCE AGAIN JUST ONE
STATE THAT WE SUPPORT THE GOALS
SHE BY AB THREE NINETY EIGHT
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE DEAL.
WILL SUBMIT ADDITIONAL WRITTEN
COMMENTS- AS WE HAVE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL AND UNDERLYING
DISAGREEMENTS WITH MANY MORE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THEIR
INPUT MAX. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUSH GOOD
MORNING CARE WHAT HELP YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALAN ABSENT WITH THE
BAY AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. LIKE THE FIRST LINE
MY COMMENTS WITH THE MY
COUNTERPARTS FROM THE SAN
JOAQUIN AND SOUTH COAST AIR
DISTRICTS. AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
REQUEST- OVERALL SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM MPLEMENTATION FUNDING
ALTHOUGH NOTING THAT EXTRA
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN ADDED IN
PAST YEARS AND THE CURRENT
AMOUNT. PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET
DOES NOT REFLECT THROUGH AIR
DISTRICT COST RUNNING. WE HAVE
SUPPORT FOR THE INFO PACKAGE OF
FOR ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR EARLY ACTION IN ONE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
ALSO SUPPORT FOR THE CLEAN
TRUCK AND BUS UP FUNDING AMOUNT
OF ONE SIXTY FIVE MILLION ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. I WOULD
LIKE TO- COUNTER AT YOUR WHITE
HOUSE HE STATEMENT ABOUT EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAMS IN THE BAY AREA AIR
DISTRICT THAT PROGRAM IS OVER
SUBSCRIBED AND YOU HAD TO USE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICT FUNDING. TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM WHILE WE
WAIT FOR NEW FUNDING FROM UP
FROM THE STATE BUDGET. AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE ABA CLEAN
AIR PROGRAMS INCLUDING CARL
MOYER PROGRAM THE AB NINE
TWENTY THREE PROGRAM IN THE.
EIGHTY ONE EIGHTEEN PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
HEY WE WILL AND SIXTY. THANK
YOU MISTER BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ERIN RODRIGUEZ UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS I
COMINTERN ISSUE FIFTEEN WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT TAKING EARLY
ACTION ON TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE JEEP CHEROKEE
ALLOCATION PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE CLEAN DEPENDABLE
TRANSPORTATION TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WILL RUN OUT OF
TIME TO FOR THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR BEGAN. TAKING ACTION TO BE
IMMEDIATELY ON THE CURRENT YEAR
JUNIOR UP TO PROVIDE RELIEF
THAT THAT'S POSSIBLE IN
ADDITION WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION IN CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS JUST EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAM
SUCH AS CLEAN CARD FOR ALL AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK. ALLOCATION
WILL IMPROVE ACCESS TO NEW AND
USE YOUR IMAGE VEHICLES
INCLUDING PASSENGER CARS MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND
OFFERED EQUIPMENT CLASSIFIED
THAT WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO RE AUTHORIZE THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AN
AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
AB ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU LOOK FOR TO WORKING WIH
YOU THROUGHOUT. THIS YEAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU
I SIXTY TWO YOU ARE THING. GOOD
MORNING CARE MEMBERS ARE BARELY
WARNING BUT LIKE WE STILL HAVE
GIVEN AT YES THE RETURN OF THE
CALIBRATION WORK COMMERCE I'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
CONTENT IN CONTEXT ITEM
FOURTEEN ON TODAY'S AGENDA SO
AFTER THE RE AUTHORIZATION OR
CAP AND TRADE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WHICH WE NEED
TO GET HOUSEKEEPER SUPPORTED
THAT EVERY SENSE OF THE WORD
DIDN'T BARK ON A DETAILED
PUBLIC STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
DEVELOP NEW BINDING REGULATIONS
THAT GOVERN THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM BUT PART OF THAT
PROCESS IN A REQUIRED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE- THERE THE EXAMINE
THE APPROPRIATE PRICING
STRUCTURE ANDPENDING
ALLOWANCES IN GOLD REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS AT THE TIME.
AND THAT WOULD IN ORDER TO
BALANCE THESE ECONOMIC
CONSIDERATIONS WHICH IS A REAL
RISK OF CARBON EMISSIONS SIMPLY
MOVING OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BE KEEN TIME RATCHETING
DOWN CARBON EMISSIONS OVER TIME
AND I REGULATION JUST WENT INTO
EFFECT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BECAUSE OF THIS- AND BECAUSE.
THIS IS A BRAND NEW REGULATION
THAT WE HAVE. I YET WE SUPPORT
THE WRECK. I THINK BLURRING
SOMETHING. THE IMPACT OF THE
NEEDS AND TRADE. IN CONNECTION
WITH BILL BEING. STARTING MONTH.
WHERE THE AIR WE WILL LOOK AT
THIS. AND LOTS OF OTHER COOL I
KNOW THERE THE PRO. FOR GOING
IN THERE BE- NEED. EIGHT
OVERALL IT ARE YOU TO CALL.
FOUR DOOR WITH THE LEGISLATURE
EVERYTHING CAPACITY AND THE
THERE BE ON THE- AND OTHER
CARBON. REDUCTION PROGRAM.
DURING A COUPLE PLAN PROCESS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU AND MY WE HAVE A HARD
STOP AT. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
SINCE. WE'RE BE VICTIMS FOR
THIS ROOM SO. NEXT OKAY. NEXT
WE HAVE A BOAT- TEN LEFT IN Q.
IT LOOKS LIKE MAYBE FIFTEEN
WILL DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN AND
THE ONES THAT WE DON'T GET TO
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE. RIGHT NEXT.
ROBERT LOCAL LINE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. MOVING
ALONG WE WILL TO LINE SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MATT
ROBINSON WITH SHALL GATHER IN A
TWEET SCHNAUZER AND LYING ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF
CATERPILLAR WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM AND WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE FUNDING IS PART OF
THE CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE
PLAN. AS YOU KNOW THE PROGRAM
IS VITAL TO INCENTIVIZING IN
SUPPORTING PROJECTS THAT HELP
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS AND
RANCHERS MANAGE THEIR LANDS IN
WAYS THAT IMPROVE SOIL HEALTH.
AND HELP REDUCE I'M SORRY HELP
RECEIVE OUR STATE'S LARGER
ENVIRONMENTAL AND AIR QUALITY
GOALS. OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD
APPRECIATE MORE MONEY FOR THE
PROGRAM. I UNDERSTAND OF COURSE
ALL THE DEFERRED INTEREST WITH
REGARDS TO THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY APPRECIATE
YOUR- TAX. ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BILL
MCGOVERN WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR ON ITEMS FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR FOCUSING ON
OVERSIGHT OF CAP AND TRADE WE
AGREE IT'S TIME TO RE EVALUATE
THE PROGRAM AND APPRECIATE
SECRETARY BLUMENTHAL'S
COMMITMENT TO DO THAT- WE NEED
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
REGULATORY STANDARDS ON
VEHICLES APPLIANCES BUILDINGS
IT'S CENTRAL HAVE BEEN THE KEY
TO CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESS. IN
REDUCING EMISSIONS CAP AND
TRADE AS A BACKSTOP NEEDS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF THE LARGE
BANK OF ALLOWANCES THE FOR
PRICE FREE ALLOWANCES IN OFFICE
THAT AS WELL AS HOT SPOTS.
SECONDLY ON THE CHEMTRADE
EXPENDITURE WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES IS
PRIORITIZING TRANSPORTATION THE
BIGGEST CAUSE OF EMISSIONS THE
CALIFORNIA. AND IS LOOKING TO
PROVIDE CLEAN MOBILITY FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS BY
CLEANING UP OUR TRUCKS AND
BUSES. AND ALSO BY FUNDING THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS
WE DO SUPPORT EARLY ACTION SO
THAT THOSE EQUITY PROJECTS THAT
ARE PROVIDING RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. DO NOT GO DARK.
FINALLY WE AGREE WITH CENTER
MCGUIRE THAT THE FORMULA OF THE
CAP AND TRADE CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS NEEDS TO BE
REVISITED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NECKS ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TO TURN
MEMBERS HELLO RUSSIAN WITH THE
FARM BUREAU WE WANT TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE EARLY
ACTION AND BUDGET ACTION FOR
THE FARMER PROGRAM HEALTHY
SPOILED AND WHILE BARK FUNDING
AND I DO ALL HAVE CLUED IN ON
AND THE METHANE EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS ARE NOT
PROPOSED UNFUNDED ACCEPTED THE
CATALYTIC. BEEN CONTINUING OUR
DISCUSSION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
CHALLENGES OF WHICH YOU
MENTIONED DAY AND ALSO NOTE
THAT- IS METHANE EMISSION
REDUCTION PROJECTS BUT HAVE TO
BE IN COMPETITION WITH ALL
OTHER CATALYSTS FUNDED PROJECT.
THAT ONLY PROPOSED AT FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT THANK YOU. WHITE LIGHT
SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. SIXTY
SIX USE THE FLIGHT SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE ACT HEALTHY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MILLION MARLINS WILL CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY I'M CALLING
ABOUT ITEM FIFTEEN THE CAPITAL.
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
WHILE WE SUPPORT GOVERNOR NEW
CONSULTANTS ON CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT
TO THE FOCUS ON EQUITY THE
REQUESTED BY YOUR STORE FUNDING
FOR LIGHT DUTY LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLE THROUGH THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT-
SPEEDIER P. ET R. P. IS NEEDED
TO RESEARCH THE GOAL. OF HAVING
1100% OF THE NEW VEHICLE SALES
DETERMINES YOUR VEHICLE. BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. NOT ALL IF
THE V. R. P. AND THAT WAS PART.
WITH A PROVEN RECORD OF EXACTLY.
THEIR MISSION VEHICLES. BUT IT
DOES COME WITH A OKAY ON THE
LAW AND MIDDLE CLASS. HE IS
THERE FOR CAL. BEING
TRANSPORTATION I PROGRAMS AND
YOU CAN PUT BEING. AFTER STRIVE
TO MILLION ARAKAN. SOLUTION
THANK YOUNG NEXT. MY SIX YEAR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MISTER
MEMBERS MICHAEL COMMITTEE
EXECUTIVE CAL TRANS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSIT ON RAIL AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE INCLUDING
EIGHTY TRANSIT AND- WHY COPIES
DISTRICT I'M PROVIDING COMMENT
TODAY ON IF YOU FIFTEEN IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO VOICE HER
STRONG SUPPORT TO THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDING PATRICK VENTURE PLAN
FOR CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF
ROAD FREIGHT EQUIPMENT- THAT
FIND THAT FUNDING OF OR TO
SPLIT. UP BETWEEN EARLY ACTIONS
AND THOSE THAT WOULD TAKE PLACE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR EARLY
ACTIONS ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
FOR INDUSTRY NOW YOU WANT TO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO CREATE
A SATISFIED WITH IN THAT
PROGRAM OF AT LEAST EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS. ZEROCHAN
TRANSIT BLASTED PRESIDENT
AGENCIES ARE LEADERS IN THEIR
MISSION BUT THE PLANET BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE STRUCTURE OF
THE PROGRAM WHICH IS FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE MEANS THAT THEY
OFTEN LOSE OUT ABOUT YOURS TO
PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES AGAIN
WOULD ENCOURAGE A SET ASIDE OF
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR YOUR
OCEAN TRANSPORT TO TAKE YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AND THANK YOU AND
THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR PUBLIC
HEARING IT'S ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
WE HAVE A HARD STOP ON ALL THE
PEOPLE LEFT IN THE QUEUE- WE
YOU HAVE THE WEBSITE THE SENATE
I WILL REVIEW THE REMARKS
PEOPLE MADE AND THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY HAVE. A CLEARLY A LOT
OF ACTION HAS BEEN ON THOSE
ITEMS THAT WERE HOLDING SO WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN ANY ACTION- SO
WITH THAT OF CLOSED PUBLIC
HEARING OF THE FOR ANY COMMENTS
IN MY COLLEAGUES CONSUME TO ME
OFF AND WE'LL GO TO OUR VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR THIS IS. ISSUES
NUMBER WE'RE GONNA HAVE THREE
SEPARATE VOTES ON THE STILL
HAVE ISSUE NUMBER SIX ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN AND ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT CENTER DOLLIES. AT A
MOTION TO APPROVE THOSE THREE
MATTERS. MISSOURI IS A MOTION
SENATOR DOLLY. ITEM C. SEVEN A
EIGHT. OF SENATE STERN. MA'AM
MISS RIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT KASKY HI MY COUNTY HI
DARLING. DAWALY II MCGUIRE. THE
CHOIR HI STERN. LET'S HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN IT DOES APPEAR TO
HAVE THE NECESSARY VOTES LET'S
GO TO OUR THE NECKS OF THE
BATCH OF BILLS WE HAVE ITEMS
NUMBER TWO ITEMS NUMBER THREE
ITEMS NUMBER FOUR AND ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SENATE MCGUIRE SAID
A MOTION TO APPROVE THOSE. MOST
BY SEN MARCO MCGUIRE IS RIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NINE BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT AND ITEM NUMBER
NINE I APOLOGIZE I APOLOGIZE I
REMEMBER TWO THREE FOUR FIVE AN
ITEM NUMBER NINE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR CASKEY HI MY
CASKEY I DALI. DALI NO THE
FIRE. REQUIRE AYE STERN. SKIP
TO MATTER. OPEN AND FINALLY
LET'S- WAS CONSIDERED ISSUE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE NUMBER TEN
ELEVEN AND TWELVE SAID REQUIRES
AND MOTION SIR PROVE THOSE.
THERE'S MUCH PRESSURE MCGUIRE-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MY KANSKE
HI MY CASKEY NINE DALAI. DOLLY
NOT VOTING FOR MCGUIRE RIGHT
MCGUIRE. STERN WE'LL GET A
CONTACT WITH CENTER STERN GET
HIM BACK ON THE SCREEN BEFORE I
CLOSE I WANTED TO YEAH THIS IS
MY FIFTH YEAR DR- ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND I DID. SHARE THE
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY COMMITTEE
FOR FOUR YEARS I'VE HAD. ARE
ANNUALLY ANNUALLY WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CAP AND TRADE WE HEAR
FROM A LOT OF INTEREST GROUPS A
LOT OF LOBBYISTS WHO WANT TO
HAVE. GREENHOUSE GAS OF FUNDING
AND- A SENATORS RIGHTLY WANT TO
HAVE FUNDS FOR THEIR PRIORITIES
AS WELL AS SAID. THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE GOES THROUGH AN
ANNUAL- DANCE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE NOTE OF
WHAT ARE DIFFERENT COMPETING
PRIORITIES ARE. AND WE ARE- BUT
IF WE ARE TO FUND OUR
PRIORITIES THAT WE WANT WE NEED
TO FIX THE CAP AND TRADE.
PROGRAM SO THE RVENUES ARE
MORE PREDICTABLE AND MORE REAL
BASS AND WE CAN RELY ON THOSE
YOU CAN EVEN TALK ABOUT
SECURITIZED EXCEL. I THANK YOU
FOR LESS WE DO THAT BOTH ARE
MISSION TARGETS AND THE FUNDING
WE NEED THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
MANY PEOPLE OF PUBLIC. ARE
GOING TO FALL SHORT SO. I WILL
CALL CENTERS STERN AND GET HIM
ON THE LINE- COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
TO THIS. LET'S SEE.
MY
APOLOGIES. I THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT FOR THE RECORD THIS IS
THE- BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES ENERGY. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT- WE ARE. CENTER
STERNEST WITH US WE HAVE A
MOTION ON ISSUES NUMBER SIX
SEVEN AND EIGHT MYSTERY PLEASE
CALL THE- I ABSENT MEMBERS
STERN I. CLOSE ROLE TELL WHY-
SO STERN I'D- THAT'S RIGHT
SORRY. FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE IS
APPROVED- THE NECKS OF MOTION
IS ON ISSUES NUMBER TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE AND NINE MISS ROY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
STERN. STERN AYE. PLEASE PLEASE
DO A TABULATE UP PLEASE NOT
AGAIN. MISTER SINISTER PLEASE
FORGET. I. THIRD STREET CLOTHES
THAT THREE OKAY STERN AYE THREE
ONE HI CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU
VOTE THE AYES HAVE A THREE TO
ONE AND ONE FINAL VOTE THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ISSUE TEN
ELEVEN AND TWELVE MISS ROY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TURN STERN HI STERN I. THE TO
CLOSE AT THREE ZERO OKAY. THAT
MATTERS PROVED THREE ZERO AND
THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
SUBCOMMITTEES ACTION TODAY
THANK YOU CENTER STERN AND
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU STAFF
FOR ALL THE GREAT PREP WORK IN
DEEP DIVE ALL RIGHT AND WE ARE
NOW IT TURNS.